DUNGENESS CRAB SEASON AS WELL
AS PUTTING FISH FROM THE
HIGHWAYS IN THE FAST LANE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA HONORED TO BE TO
BE WITH YOU MY NAME IS MIKE
MCGUIRE IN A GRATEFUL TO BE A
SHORT CHAIR THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME ALL OF OUR
HARDWORKING FISHERMEN IN AGENCY
REPRESENTATIVES AND SEEN GAS
FROM THE- CRAB AND FISH WORLD
TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY-
AND WE START. THIS HEARING
CANDIDLY ON A SOMBER NOTE IN
WITH HEAVY HEARTS. REASONS THAT
ARE STILL UNDER INVESTIGATION.
THE FISHING VESSEL MISS HALEY
CAPSIZED AND SANK QUICKLY OFF
THE COAST OF THE DATABASE. THE
RESULT IN LOSS OF A DECK IN OUR
NEW FULL SANTIAGO HAS LEFT THE
FISHING COMMUNITY GRIEF
STRICKEN AND AS WE START
TODAY'S HEARING OUR THOUGHTS GO
OUT TO HIS FAMILY IN FOR AN-
OUR FOCUS TODAY WILL BE ON WHEN
THE GOLDEN STATE SCRAP FISHERY.
CAN BE LUNCH FOR THE SEASON.
AND TODAY WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
BE FOCUSING ON THE INITIAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT LAUNCHING A
LONG TERM STRATEGY TO MAKE
STATE HIGHWAYS. FRIENDLY FOR
ENDANGERED FISH SPECIES WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER OFFER SOME
OPENING COMMENTS ON THE CRAB
SEASON FIRST. A MERE THREE
WEEKS AGO IT APPEARED WE WOULD
HAVE A NORMAL OPENER FOR OUR
CRAP SEATED IF THERE IS ANY
SUCH THING ANYMORE. WE NOW
EXPERIENCING DELAYS DUE TO CRAP
QUALITY WAIT IN PARTICULAR
RISK- MARINE LIFE ENTANGLEMENT
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON WHALES AND
TOMORROW GAS IT CONCERNS. BUT
LEVELS HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS
LEVELS A DEMO GAS IT IN MOST
AREAS OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COAST ARE LOWER THAN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST.
COUPLE OF YEARS THERE ARE ONLY
TWO LOCATIONS IT'S STILL NEED A
CLEAN TEST THAT'S IT USE ALL
NORTH OF FOR BRAG IN DUXBURY
NEAR SAN FRANCISCO. THAT WE
WANT TAKE A MOMENT SAID HOW
MUCH WE APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN PUBLIC HEALTH
TO TRULY BUSTED THEIR TAILS TO
BE ABLE TO GET FISHERMEN OUT ON
THE OCEAN. WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE FISHERMEN FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND PERSISTENCE TRYING
TO GET THIS SEASON KICKED OFF.
AB SEASON WILL BE OPENING IF
ALL GOES WELL. KNOCK WHAT
ESPECIALLY AT SOUTH IN THE
MENDOCINO COUNTY LINE I
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND WHICH I
ALSO KNOW- IS I GIVE YOU A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME TO BE ABLE TO
MOBILIZE. MENDOCINO DOWN OR
CARRY HOWEVER IS PLANNED TO
OPEN ON DECEMBER SIXTEENTH
ASSUMING WE GET POSITIVE TEST
BACK ON CRAP QUALITY FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THOSE CRABS ARE
GETTING FAT. IN MY- THERE WAYNE
ENOUGH. HERE'S WHAT THIS MEANS
THOUGH IF WE'RE ABLE TO OPEN
HERE ON THE TWENTY SECOND.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE FRESH. HIGH
QUALITY SUCCULENT CRAP FOR
THANKSGIVING CHRISTMAS AND NEW
YEARS AND ALL OF OUR FESTIVE
EVENTS OR A GUESS WHAT THE HECK
IN THE MONTHS TO COME. THE
SECOND HALF OF OUR HEARING IS
GONNA BE FOCUSING. ON HOW WE
MAKE OUR HIGHWAYS HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE FRESH FRIENDLY. AS
JOHN THOUGH CALTRANS HAS OVER
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND POTENTIAL
BARRIERS- TO ENDANGERED FISH
SPECIES WITH FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE I KNOWN. LOCATIONS
CALTRANS IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
OWNER AND MANAGER OF FISH
PASSAGE WHERE YEARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THESE
BARRIERS WALK MIGRATION OF A
DOLE IN BABY SALMON AND DENY
ACCESS TO HUNDREDS OF MILES OF
FISHERY HABITAT. WE NEED TO GET
THEM FIXING ME TO GET THEM
FIXED FAST BUT BECAUSE OUR
FISH. AND THEIR THIS SPECIES
CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER. FOR
EVERY STREAM MILE THAT WE
RECONNECT TWELVE JOBS ARE
SUPPORTED AND THERE'S MORE THAN
A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
BENEFIT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
EVERY FISH PASSAGE IMPROVEMENT
STRUCTURE THAT IS COMPLETED
BENEFITS FROM A MAINTENANCE
FREE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
LIKELY THE LAST HALF TO A FULL
CENTURY. CALIFORNIANS AND DANE
CALIFORNIA'S ENDANGERED FISH
POPULATIONS ARE ON THE BRINK
ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE OF A
CHANGING CLIMATE. THERE'S A LOT
THAT THE STATE CAN DO TO HELP
RECOVERY AT THE RECOVERY OF
ENDANGERED FISH SPECIES AND ONE
OF THE MOST CRITICAL STEPS THAT
THE STATE CAN TAKE IT TO REMOVE
THE THOUSANDS OF FISH MIGRATION
BARRIERS. THAT EXIST ON OUR
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. AGAIN WE
WELCOME ALL OF YOU HERE TODAY
ESPECIALLY THANK THOSE WHO
TRAVEL FROM FAR AND WIDE
INCLUDING OUR CHIEF CONSULTANT
WHO CAME DOWN FROM EUREKA- IT
TO PARTICIPATE IN SUCH AN
IMPORTANT EVENT. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ARE FISHERIES OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ECONOMY. WE
ARE GONNA BE LIVE STREAM TODAY.
YEAH AND RECORDED AND WE'RE
pWILDLIFE NOT TO SWEAR IS
USUALLY DOES. SO I'M KIDDING-
IN OF COURSE WE'RE GONNA BE
HAVING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE PRESENTATIONS OF
Y'ALL DON'T MIND PLEASE HANG
WITH US- IN OF COURSE BUT WE'LL
GET RIGHT TO YOU. AT THE END OF
THE HEARING WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE A THAT
WELCOME. THE DIRECTOR EFFICIENT
LILAC MISTER CHUCK BONHAM. TO
AT THE TABLE PLEASE. AT THE
DIRECTOR IS SOON GOING TO BE
THE LONGEST SERVING FISHING WHY
IT WILDLIFE DIRECTOR IN MODERN
HISTORY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU AS WELL SIR-
THAT IS- IF AND DEMOCRATS CAME
AROUND OF APPLIANCE PLEASE. IN
HE'S GOING TO BE KICKING OFF
OUR FIRST PANEL- IN ITS THE
STATE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
DUNGENESS CRAB SEASON- THE
MARINE HEAT WAVE TO MARK ACID
AND THE THREAT OF WHALE
ENTANGLEMENT. WE'RE ALSO GONNA
WELCOME UP IN SIN NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN THE DIRECTOR HI
BENSON IS THE CHIEF FOOD AND-
THE FOOD AND DRUG BRANCH FROM
CALVARY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE'RE IN A WELCOME- IT
APPEAR IF YOU ALL CAN COME ON
UP RIGHT NOW PLEASE THANK YOU
MASTER HE'S A PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR THE MARINE REGION WITH THE
CALVET. WILDLIFE WE WELCOME
SUSAN RIGHT WINE THAT TO THE
TABLE SHE'S A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST CRAP
ASSOCIATION PLEASE COME ON
FORWARD. AND WE'RE ALSO GOING
TO WELCOME WE'RE GONNA
SERGEANTS WE CAN GET ONE MORE-
AT CHAIR IS WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE ALSO GONNA WELCOME
NO OPPENHEIM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AT THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION
OF FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION. MR
BONHAM IS GOING TO BE GIVING US
AN OVERVIEW ON WHAT TO EXPECT
THIS CRAB SEASON HE'S GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON SOME VERY KEY
AREAS- OCEAN CONDITIONS WHERE
WE AT WITH. THE ARE UNDER WATER
HEAT WAVE THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEN.
IT'S GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
DISASTER RELIEF FIND
DISTRIBUTION DEMO GAP THE
TESTING CRAP QUALITY. HE'S
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON- WAY
OPENS ANDWE'RE GOING THEY
AVOID WHALES THIS COMING CRAB
SEASON. AND OF COURSE HE'S
COULD BE SPEAKING TO THE DELAY
OF THE SEASON AND OBVIOUSLY ANY
OTHER ISSUES HE DEEMS
APPROPRIATE. AGAIN MISTER AFTER
WE WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE IS
ALWAYS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS AND
YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES SIR. GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR. I SUPPOSE
SOME PEOPLE MAY NOT LIKE MY LAW
THANK TENURE AND OTHERS MET. SO
I'LL LEAVE IT TO THE- THE
DEPARTMENT STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
UP THEIR MIND ABOUT THOSE
THINGS HI. I WON'T BE AROUND
THIS AFTERNOON BUT I DID WANT
TO SAY ONE THING- THE
DEPARTMENT AND I IS DIRECTOR
ARE VERY PRO FISH PASSAGE
PROJECT. WE ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP CONVERSATIONS
WERE STARTING WITH CALTRANS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO A BRIGHT
FUTURE IN THAT WORK WITH THEM
SO WE APPRECIATE YOU HAVING A
PANEL THIS AFTERNOON ON THE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR. WE START
WITH KIND OF. A COMMENTARY
AROUND OCEAN CONDITIONS THAT
MIGHT ALLOW FOLKS TO TAKE A
DEEP BREATH AND CALM A LITTLE.
PEOPLE MAY RECALL THAT ABOUT A
MONTH AGO A WE WERE SEEING SOME
A BRICK IN OUR MEDIA SPACE
AROUND THE LIKELIHOOD OF
ANOTHER WARM WATER BLOB. I KNOW
FOR WOMAN I READ THOSE STORIES
I HAD A FREAK OUT BECAUSE THE
WARM WATER BLOOD THE LAST GO
AROUND WAS IMMENSELY
CHALLENGING FOR ALL OF US. WHAT
WE NOW KNOW TODAY IS LOOKING AT
THE LATEST IMAGES WE SEE THAT
THE MARINE HEAT FORM OR THE
HEAT WAVE HAS REFORMED INTO A
SINGLE. YET MUCH SMALLER
FEATURE AS COMPARED TO THE
MAXIMUM SIZE IT ONCE HAD- IN
THESE OBSERVATIONS IN AUGUST
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND THAT
THIS KIND OF HEAT HAS MOVED
FARTHER OFF SHORE RATHER THAN
MOVING NEAR SHORE WHICH WERE
SOME OF THE DYNAMICS WE SAW
LAST GO AROUND THEY DON'T
APPEAR TO BE ESTABLISHING
THEMSELVES. THIS GO AROUND. SEE
SERVICE TEMPERATURES HAVE
COOLED ACROSS MUCH OF THE NEAR
SHORE AREAS FOR THE ENTIRE
UNITED STATES WEST COAST. BOTH
SOUTHERN OREGON AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ARE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING COLDER THAN
AVERAGE TEMPERATURES. UNLIKE
THE BLOB OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN WHICH
REMAINED NEAR THE COAST. ALL
DURING THE FALL AND DURING THE
WINTER. THE CURRENT MARINE
HEATWAVE IS RETREATED TO A
LOCATION MUCH FURTHER OFF
SHORE. THIS IS BETTER NEWS THAN
MANY OF US ALL REPORTED IN THE
MEDIA ABOUT A MONTH AGO. NOW OF
COURSE THE CONDITIONS ARE GONNA
BECOME INCREASINGLY DYNAMIC AS
THROUGH THE TYPICAL CYCLE OF
FALL AND WINTER STORMS. AS
THOSE STORMS BEGIN FORMING IN
THE NORTHEAST PACIFIC BUT ON-THIS TOPIC I THINK THE NEWS IS
BETTER COMPARED TO WARS-
PARTICULARLY WHEN ONE FACTORS
IN THE ORIGINAL REPORTING ABOUT
A MONTH AGO. NEXT TOPIC YOU
ASKED ME TO COVER IS THE TOPIC
OF DISASTER RELIEF FUND
DISTRIBUTION. AS ME- YOU YOUR
LEADERSHIP OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE OUR CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES. BOTH GOOD
BROWN AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND
OUR DEPARTMENT OF WORKED REALLY
HARD TO PROVIDE DISASTER RELIEF
FOR AFFECTED FISHERY
COMMUNITIES WE'RE ON THE BACK
END OF A LOT OF THIS WORK THE
MONEY'S COME IN AND HERE'S
PROBABLY THE MOST CURRENT
UPDATE. SO THE FINAL BATCH OF
PAYMENTS ARE ACTUALLY IN THE
MAIL. EFFECTED FISHER MEN AND
WOMEN AND INDUSTRIES WE ARE
WORKING ON THE MITIGATION
PORTION OF THE DISASTER RELIEF.
SO OUR TOTAL PAY OUT SO FAR I
BELIEVE IS APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
TWO. MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND DUNGENESS
CRAB TOTAL WAS TWENTY TWO
MILLION ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND I BELIEVE ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND WENT TO
THE ROCK CROWDS ROCK CRAP
SECTOR WHICH IS YOU KNOW IS
GEOGRAPHICALLY MORE LIMITED
DOWN INTO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AROUND THE CHANNEL ISLANDS. SO
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTING THE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL AROUND THAT MITIGATION
ASPECT. AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR US SPENDING PLAN. TO
IMPROVE THEIR LAB CAPABILITIES
AND THAT SPENDING PLAN I
BELIEVE IS THE THIS IS AT THE
PACIFIC STATE. RAIN FISHERIES
COMMISSION WHICH BY THE WAY
CONGRATULATIONS FOR YOUR
REAPPOINTMENT TO. SO THAT'S
THAT'S OUR QUICK SUMMARY ON
DISASTER RELIEF. YOU ALSO ASKED
THAT I COVER WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT BELIEVES TO BE THE
DUNGENESS CRAB TASK FORCE
PRIORITIES AS WE'VE HEARD THEM
EXPRESS POSSIBLE PRIORITIES TO
US. HERE'S OUR IMPRESSION OF
THE THINGS THEY'D LIKE TO FOCUS
ON IN THE MEDIA FUTURE. NOT
SURPRISINGLY THEY REQUESTED A
MORE DETAILED ACCOUNTING OF THE
DUNGEON IS CRAB TRAP LIMIT
ACCOUNT BECAUSE I BELIEVE THERE
ARE PERPETUALLY INTERESTED IN.
THE SPECIFICS OF HOW THE
DEPARTMENT TO SPENDS THESE
FUNDS SO WE'RE VERY OKAY WITH
GOING TO THAT NOVEL NEXT LEVEL
TRANSPARENCY. THEY ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE I THINK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CONTRACTS THAT
WE ARE ENGAGING AND ARE FOR THE
FULL APPROVED AMOUNT OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. AND I THINK
THEY'RE FOCUSED ON THAT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE AN NTEREST IN MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR TASK FORCE
MEETINGS CAN OCCUR. AS NEEDED
ON A REGULAR FREQUENCY AND THAT
TRAVEL REIMBURSEMENTS FOR
MEMBERS ARE AVAILABLE SO THAT
WE CAN ENSURE SUFFICIENT
PARTICIPATION. MY IMPRESSION IS
THE TASK FORCES SUPPORT OF OUR
DEPARTMENT AND OUR SISTER
HEALTH AGENCIES. STARTING TO
DEVELOP SOMETHING I BELIEVE
WE'RE CALLING KIND OF A BIO
TOXIN MANAGEMENT ZONE APPROACH.
IF WE CAN BRING A LITTLE MORE
MORE CLARITY TO THE PARTS OF
THE OCEAN AND THAT WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON FOR MANAGEMENT. AND
HEALTH CONCERNS AND THINK ABOUT
DOING THOSE MANAGEMENT ZONES
CONNECTED TO REGULATIONS AROUND
OF THIS RACE OR ORDERS. SO
THAT'S KIND OF SOMETHING I
THINK THEIR SUPPORT OF WE DO
WE'RE IN THE EARLY CHAPTERS OF
BUILDING THAT OUT WITH THE PH
BUT I EXPECT THAT'S WORK AHEAD
WITH THE TASK FORCE. OKAY SO
LET'S SHIFT THE CRAB AND START
WITH THE RECREATIONAL GRAB. SO
THE FOLKS THAT ARE OUT THERE IN
A SPORT FISHERY NOT A
COMMERCIAL FISHERY. SO THE
UPDATE ON RECREATIONAL DUNGEONS
GRAB IS AS FOLLOWS. ON NOVEMBER
SECOND THE RECREATIONAL FISHERY
OPENED- WITH TO MOLECH ACID
HEALTH ADVISORIES FOR SHELTER
COVE IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY. SOUTH
TO POINT ARENA IN MENDOCINO
COUNTY AND FROM POINT REYES IN
MARIN COUNTY. SOUTH TO PILLAR
POINT IN SAN MATEO COUNTY. ON
NOVEMBER FIFTH OUR DEPARTMENT
DISCUSS CHANGES IN FRONT OF THE
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
THROUGH THE COMMISSION'S MARINE
SOURCE RESOURCES COMMITTEE THAT
WE THINK SHOULD BE MADE TO THE
RECREATIONAL FISHERY. TO MOVE
IT INTO A MORE ANALOGOUS
APPROACH THAT THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR IS TAKING IN ORDER TO BE
WILL SAVE. AS YOU KNOW IN THE
LAST YEAR TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF ENERGY
AROUND WHAT MIGHT BE CHANGES A
PRACTICE IN THE COMMERCIAL
FISHING SPACE. AND WE BELIEVE
IT THE DEPARTMENT'S IMPORTANT
TO PURSUE SIMILAR CHANGES IN
THE RECREATIONAL CRAB FISHERY
SPACES WELL. THERE'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE BETWEEN THE TWO SECTORS
AND THERE'S ALSO I BELIEVE-
TRUE INTEREST IN BOTH SECTORS
UNDERSTANDING HOW TO BE MORE
WILL SAVE. SO WE'VE TAKEN THAT
TO OUR FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
WHY DO WE NEED TO GO THERE.
THEY HAVE THE STATUTORY
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY OVER THE
RECREATIONAL FISHERS. WE HAVE
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY OVER
THE COMMERCIAL FISHERS. SO MY
IMPRESSION IS THAT- COMMISSIONS
MARINE RESOURCES COMMITTEE-
DISCUSSED A VARIETY OF OPTIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND PLANS TO
PRESENT IN THE DECEMBER MEETING
WHICH I BELIEVE IS IN
SACRAMENTO. AROUND RULE MAKING
OPTIONS FOR CHANGING THE
RECREATIONAL CRAB FISHERY. SO
THAT BRINGS US TO- PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT UPDATE I HAVE.
AND THAT'S AROUND THE OPENING
OF THE DUNGEON IS GRAB
COMMERCIAL FISHERY AND THE WAY
I STARTED THINK ABOUT IT IS TO
USE THIS IDEA OF RULES AND I'M
I MEAN IT KIND OF AN INFORMAL
SENSE. BUT TO HELP PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE THREE SETS
OF RULES THAT ARE PRIDE TO
OPENING DUNGENESS CRAB
COMMERCIAL FISHERY. AND IT
TURNS OUT QUALITY TESTING THE
TESTING OF THE MEAT IN THE CRAB
TO FIGURE OUT IF THEY'RE FAT OR
SKINNY. IS ACTUALLY OUR OLDEST
AND ARGUABLY OUR MOST RELIABLE
SET OF RULES AT THIS POINT.
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME
THE STATES OF CALIFORNIA OREGON
AND WASHINGTON HAVE US TRY
STATE APPROACH TO THIS QUALITY
TESTING THE FLEET UNDERSTANDS
THESE RULES AND EVERY YEAR
WE'RE LOOKING AT TESTING OF
QUALITY DETERMINE OPENER SO
WHAT'S HAPPENED SO FAR. IS THE
CRAB QUALITY TESTING RESULTS IN
THE PROGNOSIS SOME THINGS WE'VE
DONE IS REALLY ONLY APPLICABLE
TO THE NORTHERN MANAGEMENT
AREAS SO THINK MENDOCINO ON UP
THE COAST. AND ON NOVEMBER
THIRTEENTH WE CAN CONFIRM WE
HAVE POOR CRAB QUALITY BASED ON
THESE TESTING PROTOCOLS. THE
TRI STATE KIND OF STRUCTURE A
GOOD READ TO DELAY THE DECEMBER
FIRST OPENER UNTIL DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH. SO WE'LL KEEP DOING
TESTING THE FIRST WEEK OF
DECEMBER. WE WILL HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED FAIR START TRIGGERED IN
THE NORTHERN MANAGEMENT AREA.
AND WE'VE HAD A DIRECTOR MEMO
PUT OUT TO DELAY THE FISHERY DO
THE QUALITY WE'VE DONE OUR
TYPICAL INFORMATIONAL PRESS
RELEASE AND WITH POSTED ALL OF
OUR USUAL FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTION KIND OF OUR REACH
MATERIAL AROUND THE ISSUE OF
CRAP QUALITY. I WOULD ALSO SAY
WE THINK INTERNALLY THE
PROGNOSIS IS IFFY THE NOT SO
GOOD FOR THAT NORTHERN FISHERY
TO OPEN ON DECEMBER FIFTEENTH.
AND IT'S POSSIBLE IT COULD
CONTINUE TO BE DELAYED UNTIL
JANUARY. AND REMEMBER THIS IS
ALL ABOUT THE QUALITY OF THE ME
FOLLOWING THAT OLDEST AND MOST
RELIABLE SET OF RULES WE HAVE
AT THIS POINT. THAT REALLY
BRINGS US TO THE SECOND SET OF
RULES AND AGAIN I USE RULES IN
THE MORE INFORMAL SENSE. THIS
SET OF RULES IS AROUND THE
TOPIC OF THE MALL LIKE ACID.
IT'S NEWER FOR US IN SOME SENSE
COMPARED TO THE CRAP QUALITY
TESTING RULES. AND IT'S REALLY
ABOUT OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
FLEET AND OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR SISTER PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
NOT A PRODUCT OUT IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THAT PUTS
CALIFORNIA'S AT RISK FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. SO
AS YOU MENTIONED WE HAVE A
NORTHERN MANAGEMENT AREA AND
THIS IS UP YOU KNOW FOR BRAG
USE ALL AREA AND WHAT WE HAVE.
AS A NEED THERE IS TO GET ONE
ADDITIONAL CLEAN TEST THE CLEAR
AND AVOID ANY DEMO LIKE ACID
DELAYS IN THE NORTHERN
MANAGEMENT AREA. AND I BELIEVE
THE RESULTS ARE EXPECTED
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND. SO THEN%
KIND OF MOVING SOUTHWARD WE
HAVE A CENTRAL MANAGEMENT AREA
AND THIS IS AROUND THE DUXBURY
REEF POINT REYES AREA YOU
MENTIONED IT. ON NOVEMBER FIFTH
WE HAD A SAMPLE OF ONE CRAB
OVER THE LIMIT WE IN OUR
PARLANCE KIND OF SHORT HANDED
SAY A HOT CRAP IT'S OVER THE
THRESHOLD OF THIRTY SIX PARTS
PER MILLIMETER. MILLION AND SO
WE HAVE SINCE THAT NOVEMBER
FIFTH SAMPLE OF A HOT CROWD WE
HAVE OUR FIRST REQUIRED CLEAN
SAMPLE THE CAME IN LATE LAST
WEEK. AND WE NEED ONE
ADDITIONAL CLEAN SAMPLE BEFORE
WE CAN OPEN THE AREA SO THESE
ARE RULES AROUND OPENING
CLOSING BASED ON THE TESTING.
WE COLLECTED OUR SECOND SET A
SAMPLES YESTERDAY ON MONDAY THE
EIGHTEENTH. WE'VE DELIVERED
THEM TO OUR SISTER AGENCIES LAB
WE HAVE SOME INTERNAL PROTOCOLS
ESTABLISHED BETWEEN IS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE HITTING ALL OF OUR
PROCESSING MARKERS TODAY AND
TOMORROW. FOR EXPEDITED REVIEW
AND WHAT WE'VE TOLD THE ENTIRE
FLEET I BELIEVE THE MEDIA AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IS WATCHING. IS
WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE
NOTIFICATION NO LATER THAN SIX
PM TOMORROW. ABOUT THIS LAST
SAMPLE AND WE BASICALLY COULD
END UP WITH THREE SCENARIOS AND
WE'VE ALSO KIND OF BROADCAST
THESE LIKELY SCENARIOS THE
FLEET SO THEY CANNOT PLANNING
CERTAINTY AS MUCH AS THAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THIS CLIMATE. ONE
SCENARIO IS THE SAMPLE COMES
BACK CLEAN. WE'VE GOT AN
OPENING WE'RE GOOD TO GO.
ANOTHER SCENARIO IS THE SAMPLES
WE CAN'T GET THEM PROCESSED
AGAINST THE SIX PM MARKER. THE
MACHINE COULD BREAK DOWN. YOU
KNOW SOME OTHER ACT OF GOD
COULD INTERVENE AND WE JUST
CAN'T GET THEM PROCESS OKAY SO
RIGHT NOW WE'RE HITTING ALL OF
OUR INTERNAL MARKERS FOR OUR
EXPEDITED APPROACH. AND UNDER
THIS CAN'T GET IT PROCESS THE
SAMPLE RESULTS AREN'T AVAILABLE
BY SIX O'CLOCK TOMORROW. YOU
COULD SEE A COUPLE OF KIND OF
SUBSTANCE AREAS WE WOULD BE
DELAYING THE OPENER IN AN AREA
FROM PILLAR POINT TO POINT
RACES. FAIR START WOULD BE
INVOKED AND THEN AT A
SUBSEQUENT MOMENT WE MIGHT
EITHER BE ABLE TO SAY THE
SAMPLE IS COME BACK CLEAN. IF
THAT WERE THE CASE WOULD STILL
APPLY SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE
TO THE FLEET. FOR PRE SOAK IN
CERTAIN AREAS OR THAT SAMPLE
COULD COME BACK HOT. IT COMES
BACK HOT THEN WE NEED TO
CONSECUTIVE WEEKS OF CLEAN
SAMPLES BEFORE WE CAN OPEN AND
WE WOULD ALSO BE USING THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR NOTICE- FOR
PRE SOAK- INFORMATION. AND THE
LAST SCENARIO. IS BY SIX
O'CLOCK TOMORROW WE PROCESS THE
SAMPLE AND IT COMES BACK ABOUT
THE LIMIT TAUGHT. AT WHICH
POINT WE WOULD DELAY IN THE
AREA FROM PILLAR POINT OF POINT
REYES AND WE WOULD HAVE FAIR
START INVOKED AND THEN WE WOULD
NEED TWO CONSECUTIVE WEEKS OF
CLEAN SAMPLES REQUIRED WE WOULD
AGAIN GIVE SEVENTY TWO HOUR
NOTICE ONCE WERE READY TO OPEN
FOR PRE SO. THAT'S A LOT. IT'S
PARTICULARLY A LOT FOR THE
AVERAGE CITIZEN WHO'S
LISTENING. IT'S FAMILIAR FOR
THOSE OF US THAT ARE IN THIS
INTENSE SPACE- BUT I'M
SYMPATHETIC FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC THIS TRYING TO TRACK
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE. SO THE
LAST SET OF RULES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY THE NEWEST FOR US IN
SOME SENSE AND ARGUABLY THEIR
THE LEAST PREDICTABLE. SET OF
RULES AROUND THE OPENING FACTOR
OUR MARINE LIFE ENTANGLEMENTS.
IT'S BEEN WELL DISCUSS YOU'VE
HOSTED SEVERAL WORKSHOPS AND
HEARINGS ABOUT IT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS. WE CHERISH OUR
ICONIC MARINE MAMMALS THAT ARE
OFF OUR SHORE. AND WE HIGHLY
VALUE A SUSTAINABLE DUNGENESS
CRAB FISHERY AND I FOR ONE AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING A MOM
MY THANKSGIVING PLACE. THE
DEPARTMENT IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
ACHIEVING BOTH THOSE SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH FOR THE
FIRST TIME. IT'S GOT SOME FLAWS
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT IT'S
WORKING. WE'VE FACILITATED A
WORKING GROUP OF EXPERTS ACROSS
ALL THIS CONSTITUENTS INTERESTS
BASE AND WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
MOMENTS WHERE WERE CONVENING
THEM WE'RE LOOKING AT BEST
AVAILABLE INFORMATION WE'RE
DOING A RISK ASSESSMENT AND
THAT STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP
IS ADVISING THE DEPARTMENT. ON
WHETHER WE SHOULD OPEN THE
SEASON OR DELAYED THIS SEASON
BASED ON THE REST TO WELL
ENTANGLEMENTS MARINE MAMMAL
ENTANGLEMENTS SO ON NOVEMBER
FIFTH BASED ON THIS STRUCTURED
PROCESS. INFORMED BY
RECOMMENDATIONS THE CAME FROM
THAT GROUP AND ALL THE COMMENTS
DURING A FORTY EIGHT HOUR
WINDOW. I ANNOUNCED WE WERE
GOING TO DO A SEVEN DAY DELAY.
TO WELL RISK SOUTH OF THE
MENDOCINO CINEMA COUNTY LINE.
SO INSTEAD OF OPENING ON
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH. WE'RE NOW
SET TO OPEN IN A COUPLE OF
DAYS. AND WE HAVE OUR PRE SOAK
READY TO START AT SIX AM ON
THURSDAY NOVEMBER TWENTY FIRST.
THE BASIS FOR THAT SEVEN DAY
DELAY WAS WE COULD SEE A LARGE
NUMBER F WHALES STILL OUT IN
THE FISHING GROUNDS. WE DON'T
HAVE A HISTORICAL RECORD IN THE
SPACE TO TELL YOU IF THEY'RE
MORE OR LESS PER SE WHAT WE CAN
IDENTIFIES PRESENCE OR ABSENCE
AND WE'RE SEEING. CONGREGATIONS
STILL IN THE FISHING GROUNDS SO
WE PUSH THIS DELAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR THE WHALES
TO SWIM SOUTH ON THEIR
MIGRATION YET. SECURING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FLEET TO
GET THE PRODUCT INTO THE
THANKSGIVING MARKET WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT TRADITION
PARTICULARLY HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO LET ME TELL YOU
ONE LAST UPDATE AND THEN STOP.
SO AT OUR DEPARTMENT THIS IS A
NEW EXPERIENCE FOR US LEADING
THIS KIND OF ADVISORY GROUP
THROUGH STRUCTURE DECISION
MAKING AROUND MARINE MAMMAL
ENTANGLEMENTS. WE MADE A
DECISION A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO
GATHER INFORMATION SO YESTERDAY
FIRST TIME WE'VE DONE THIS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS REASON.
WE PUT ONE OF OUR OWN
DEPARTMENT PLANES IN THE AIR.
ALONG WITH SOME QUALIFIED
SCIENTIFIC OBSERVERS.
HISTORICALLY WE'VE RELIED ON
OTHER AGENCIES FLYING THEIR
PLANES TO GATHER INFORMATION WE
WANTED TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
SITUATION SO I THINK THIS IS A
POSITIVE STORY WE ARE COMMITTED
TO REAL TIME MONITORING TO
INFORM DECISION MAKING. WHAT
ARE FOLKS LANDED YESTER DAY
THEY LET US KNOW AT THE
LEADERSHIP LEVEL THEY STILL SEE
THE PRESENCE OF WALES NEAR THE
GULF OF THE FOR AIRLINES THEY
STILL SEE WHALES OFF POINT
REYES AND SOME DOWN IN HALF
MOON BAY. IN PARTS OF THE
FISHING GROUNDS. SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S CONTINUED PRESENCE
OF THESE WELLS. AT THIS MOMENT
WE DON'T THINK IT WARRANTS ANY
ADDITIONAL DELAY WE'RE GOING TO
STICK WITH THE OPENER. BUT WE
ARE GOING TO BE ADVISING TODAY
AND IN THE COMING DAYS IN VERY
CLEAR TERMS. WE KNOW THE FLEA
CAN FISH RESPONSIBLY THEY HAVE
COMMITTED TO US THEY WILL FISH
RESPONSIBLY WE EXPECT THE FLEET
THE FISH RESPONSIBLE. WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP OUR PLANE IN THE
AIR AS MUCH AS THE WEATHER
RESOURCES PILOT AVAILABILITY
ALLOWS US. WE THINK WE COULD BE
EVOLVING TO A FUTURE WHERE
WE'RE GATHERING INFORMATION
FROM THE AIR. AND WERE RELAYING
IT TO SOME FORM OF UNIFIED
COMMAND ON THE GROUND THAT'S
ADVISING OUR PARTNERS IN THE
FLEET WHERE THEY SHOULD AND
SHOULDN'T GO WHAT THEY MAY AND
MAY NOT WANT TO AVOID RELATIVE
TO PRESENCE OF WALES WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO INVOLVED IN THAT
KIND OF ADAPTABILITY. AND WE
NEED TO FLEE TO THIS
RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IF WE HAVE AN
ENTANGLEMENT. I HAVE A SERIES
OF ADDITIONAL RISK ASSESSMENTS
COMING UP AND I MAY CONCLUDE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS TO
CLOSE THE FISHERY PERMANENTLY
FOR THE SEASON SO THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THIS LAST PIECE OF
INFORMATION. IT'S BEEN
COMPLICATED EVERY YEAR OF MY
EIGHT YEARS AS DIRECTOR ON CRAB
OPENERS AND IS JUST GETTING
MORE COMPLICATED BECAUSE OF
THESE THREE SETS OF RULES AND
HOW THEY INTERFACE. NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS A DRESS FROM
STRUCTURE SO IT JUST
PERSPECTIVE WEISS. HI THE
ABSOLUTE STORM THAT WE SAW IN
REGARDS TO THE WARM WATER INTO
MùT GAS IT- BACK IN
200-015-2000 SIXTEEN. AND YOUR
PERSPECTIVE I AND THEY WERE
ALSO ASKED MR HE'S WELL. WERE
IN MUCH BETTER SHAPE ON THE
DEMO GAS AND LEVELS UNDERSTAND
WE STILL HAVE SOME HOT TESTS
OUT THERE BUT MUCH BETTER
SHAPE. THAN WE WERE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IF YA CAN
JUST QUICKLY- COMING ON THAT
AND THEN I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ON- ON WHEELS I AGREE THAT
GENERAL CHARACTERS STATION
WHERE BETTER. WITH REGARDS TO
DEMONIC ACID TODAY THAN WE WERE
IN THE PEAK OF THE WARM WATER
BLOOM AND THAT PRIOR. TO MARK
ACID INCIDENT. I WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT TOO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH A- WALES AND THEN I'M ALSO
GOING TO ASK A AND I KNOW WE
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM. A MISS
ROBIN TIME AND MISS RIGHT WINE
BUT HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR
THEM AND OBVIOUSLY WILL HAVE
YOU. MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION AS
WELL O THAT MISTER DIRECTOR
TALK A BIT ABOUT THE ISSUE ON
WHALES- SO YOU YOU'D SAID THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLAN UP
IN THE AIR. YOU'RE GONNA
CONTINUOUSLY. ON THE OCEAN IS
WELL WHAT WHAT TYPE OF BACK AND
FORTH GOES- GOES ON BETWEEN
YOUR DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS
FLEETS. WE ARE IN REGULAR
COORDINATION WITH THE FLEA AND
THAT HAS BEEN TRUE FOR YEARS.
WHAT I THINK WILL BE NEW IN THE
NEXT TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS SEVEN DAYS TEN DAYS. IS
THIS IMPORTANT MANAGEMENT IDEA
WE HAVE. IF WE CAN MARSHAL THE
RESOURCES SWIMMING WEATHER
DOESN'T KEEP US OUT OF THE YEAR
AND WE'VE GOT PILOT
AVAILABILITY WE'D LIKE TO GET
UP IN THE AIR SO WE HAVE A GOOD
VISUAL OF PRESENCE AND ABSENCES
THE WELLS ARE MOVING SOUTH. WE
DON'T YET KNOW AND I THINK
LATER TODAY AND TOMORROW WE'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO HUDDLE WITH
MR OPPENHEIM. HOW TO FIND A
PRINCIPLE POINT OF CONTACT IN
THE FLEET THAT'S ON THE GROUND.
AND THEN USE THEIR PRETTY
REGULAR COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
FISHING VESSELS WHILE THEY'RE
OUT IN THE WATER. I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
PROBLEM SOLVING THE NEXT DAY OR
TWO. SO BY THE TIME WE GET TO
THURSDAY AND FRIDAY WE HAVE
SOME. INFORMAL BUT BETTER
STRUCTURE AROUND HOW TO RELAY
INFORMATION BACK AND FORTH AND
AGAIN ASSUMING WHETHER IN SEES-
WE WILL ALSO LIKELY BE PUTTING
SOME OF OUR PATROL BOATS ON THE
WATER AND THAT'S AN ELEMENT OF
COMMUNICATION CONNECTIVITY. NOT
A ONE OF THE ASPECTS WE WILL
ALWAYS HAVE IS. IF THE DATA.
EXISTS. AT A FUTURE MAMA FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO FURTHER
RESTRICT BECAUSE A MARINE
MAMMAL ENTANGLEMENT WE'RE GONNAFALL THE WORKING GROUP PROCESS
WE WANT THEIR ADVICE WE WANT TO
CONSULT WITH THEM AND WHEN WE
TAKE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIVE
MEASURES WE ALSO ARE COGNIZANT
OF DOING IT IN A WAY. THAT
DOESN'T CREATE A PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK. AND COGNIZANT OF AN
ORDERLY FISHERY OUT IN THE
WATER WHICH IS ANOTHER REASON
WE NEED GOOD COMMUNICATION WITH
THE FLEET. THANK YOU SO MUCH
QUICKLY AND GO TO A MISTER
OPPENHEIM IS RIGHT ONE SUGGEST
THE ALL DON'T MIND TALK TO US
ABOUT- LOOK FLEET HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY PROACTIVE. IN REGARDS
TO THE ISSUE OF ENTANGLEMENTS
AND IMPLEMENTING THE RETRIEVAL
PROGRAM YOU'RE THE ONE THAT
CAME TO US AND SAID WE GOT TO
MOVE ON THIS. AND THERE ARE
VERY FEW INDUSTRIES IN THIS
STATE THAT WOULD SAY REGULATE
ASSN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THE RIGHT THING BECAUSE YOU ALL
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING SO
TALK TO US ABOUT. THE
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND AND
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
CONSECUENCIA FUEL MIND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT PRIORITY
FOR YOUR MEMBERS. DROPPING ON
THE GOING THIS ROUTE ONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU CENTER WIRE AND
LOOKING FOR TO FLUSHING THIS.
ISSUE OUT EVEN MORE IN OUR-
PREPARED REMARKS BUT JUST
BRIEFLY ON THIS CONCEPT- WHICH
IS A NEW ONE I'VE- BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH OUR LEADERSHIP JUST
THIS MORNING ABOUT. THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT KIND OF
SPATIAL AWARENESS AND CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER AT THIS
VERY MOMENT BUT THE
CONVERSATION IS GOING ON
CERTAINLY AT FIRST BLUSH. THE
NOTION THAT KNOWING WHERE WELLS
ARE LOCATED IN REAL TIME IS AN
ASSET. IT'S A NEW KIND OF
INFORMATION AND WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL THAT THE WAY THAT WE
ARE APPROACHING MANAGEMENT ON
THE WATER THIS YEAR'S NEW AS
THE DIRECTOR NOTED IN HIS
TESTIMONY IT IS IT IS A NEW
APPROACH. AND WE NEED TO BE
VERY CAREFUL THAT WE ARE USING
THIS AS A LEARNING EXPERIENCE-
AND AS WE GATHER MORE
INFORMATION. ABOUT HOW HOW WE
CAN USE SPATIAL DATA. WE CAN
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT
WHAT THAT MEANS ON THE WATER
FOR FISHERMEN BUT I THINK IN
GENERAL- WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
EXPLORING THIS CONCEPT. YEAH I
WOULD IMAGINE IT'LL TURN OVER
MISS FRONTLINE IN JUST ONE
MOMENT IS THAT- YOU'RE GONNA
BEING CONSEQUENT CASE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT- IN ENSURING
THAT THERE IS A PROACTIVE
APPROACH. TO THIS ISSUE-
UNDERSTAND THAT CONDITIONS HAVE
CHANGED I IN YOUR ALL ADAPTING
BUT YOU'RE ADAPTING I KNOW THAT
THIS IS COMING. CAN BE VERY
PROACTIVE I WOULD ASSUME I IN
THAT COMMUNICATION IN TRYING TO
AVOID I'M IN AREAS WHERE YOU
MAY SEE. IT ON THIS TO WALES
FOR EXAMPLE WITHOUT QUESTION
THE NOTION THAT FISHERMEN WOULD
BE ABLE TO RESPOND- IN IN REAL
TIME IS A COMPLEX ONE BUT
WITHOUT QUESTION FISHERMEN WILL
USE THIS INFORMATION AS BEST
THEY POSSIBLY CAN. FISHMAN ARE
GOOD AT MOVING HERE- IT IS
HOWEVER AT A TEDIOUS PROCESS
WITH EQUITY ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH SCALE OF OPERATION
ETCETERA. SO IT WILL BE COMPLEX
BUT THIS IS A SWEET. KNOWN FOR
ITS INGENUITY AND THAT'S-
DESIRE TO NAVIGATE THE
SITUATION EFFECTIVELY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH REVEREND MISS
FRONTLINE IN- THEN WE'LL GO TO-
WESC IF THERE'S INCLUDING
COMING FROM THE DIRECTION OF A
GOOD MYSTERY BUT PLEASE
DESTROY. THANK YOU SENATOR-
JUST TO ADD AND BUILD ON TO-
BUT NO I HAS PRESENTED SO FAR-
WE WOULD CONCUR AND I WOULD ADD
TO THAT. THAT ONE OF THE
RESPONSIBLE THINGS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COAST CRAP
ASSOCIATION IS DOING. IS AN
INITIATIVE CALLED OUR SLACK
LINE INITIATIVE AND THAT IS
SOMETHING WHERE WE REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF LINE TO THE BILL E.
IN OUR ACTUAL FISHING
OPERATIONS. IN THAT REALLY HAS
BEEN DEMONSTRATED IN THE LONG
IN THE LONG RUN TO REDUCE
INTERACTIONS SO AGREEING THAT
THERE ARE CHALLENGES IN TERMS
OF THE COMMUNICATION I THINK
THE- ESTABLISHING THIS SORT OF
POINT OF COMMUNICATION IS
SOMETHING THAT. WE COULD
DEFINITELY ASSIST WITH THROUGH
OUR ASSOCIATION AND AGAIN WE'RE
BEING PROACTIVE WITH OUR. SLACK
LINE INITIATIVE YEAH I PRECIADO
THANK YOU SIMPLY. I'M GONNA
TURN OVER THE DIRECTOR FOR ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS AND JUST. ONE
LAST THING FOR ME IS THAT SO.
PLAN IS THIS. YOU'RE GONNA BE
HAVING HER WITH THE FLEET
LEADERSHIP TODAY WE'RE ALL
GONNA KNOCK ON WOOD AT FOLKS
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT
ON THE WATER ON THE TWENTY
SECOND. I AND THEN THE PLAN
WOULD BE IS. PENDING CONDITIONS
YOU'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT
FLIGHTS ABOUT. YOU'RE GONNA BE
TO PAULINE- DEPARTMENT VESSELS
ON THE WATER WHERE YOU KNOW
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME- HIDES
AND THEN THERE'S GOING TO BE
THE REAL TIME COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE FLEET IN SEEING
WHAT THEY'RE SEEN ON THE
GROUND- AND ON THE OCEAN IS
WELL WHEN MAKE SURE THAT'S
ACCURATE BECAUSE THAT SOUNDS.
LIKE A HECK OF A PLAN IN
GRATEFUL FOR THAT IN RESPONDING
RIGHT TO THESE CHANGED
CONDITIONS PLEASE FILL IN ONE
INNING I MAY MISS ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS. ONLY TO ADDITIONAL
THINGS- THE FLEET IS TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE SIX PM MARKER
TOMORROW. FOR THE DEMO LIKE
ACID IF WE GET A CLEAN WE'RE
GOOD FOR HOT AND WILL HAVE
VARIATIONS PLAY OUT. SECOND AS
WE GET INTO THE FIRST PART OF
DECEMBER WE WILL BE CONVENING
ARE ADVISORY GROUP AROUND THE
WHALE ISSUE. AND WE THEN WILL
THROUGH DECEMBER HAVE DIFFERENT
RISK ASSESSMENT MOMENTS. WHERE
WILL DELIBERATE AND THEN INFORM
THE PUBLIC WHAT THOSE RISK
ASSESSMENTS LOOK LIKE. IT'S
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
TO REFER THAT YOU'RE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
TURNED OVER TO- BITS AND HE- HE
RUNS THE FOOD AND DRUG BRANCH
OF THE CABIN PART IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH. I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
MYSTERY IN HIS TEAM. A BEING
EXTREMELY PROACTIVE AND
RESPONDING QUICK STYLE- ON ALL
ISSUES RELATED TO THE TESTING
IT IS NOT BEEN EASY THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS SEE IF
FIVE MINUTES NOT TURN OF YOU
SIR IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION TODAY AND AS YOU
STATED ON CHIEF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
FOOD DRUG BRANCH AND I'M HERE
TODAY PROVIDE EVERYBODY AN
UPDATE. ON THE POST HARPER
DEMOTE ACID TESTING. FOCUSING
ON CRABS. IN OUR DEPARTMENT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE PROGRAMS
THAT WORK CLOSELY TOGETHER. TO
MONITOR THE POTENTIAL IMPACTS
AND RISK OF HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS. IN THE OCEAN AND THE
TOXINS THEY MAY PRODUCE. THEIR
BAR MULTIMETER ANCHE. MONITORS
BLOOM CONDITIONS IN THE OCEAN
AND POTENTIAL PRE HARVEST RISKS
WHILE THE FOOD DRUG BRANCH
WHERE I WORK. MONTRES
POSTHARVEST RISK IMPACT ON
SEAFOOD PRODUCTS HEADING TO
CONSUMERS. AND THEN WE WORK
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENT IS THE
FOOD DRUG LABORATORY FRANCE
WHICH PERFORMS DOG DEMOTE ACID
TESTING ON FISH AND SHELLFISH.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE MORE GAS IT
IS A TOXIN PRODUCED BY CERTAIN
PHYTOPLANKTON. AN OCEAN LEVELS
INCREASES DURING BLOOMS THAT
OCCUR AT SOMETIMES. THE
CONDITIONS THAT RESULTS IN THE
FINAL PLANKTON BLOOM MORE
COMPLEX BUT ARE THOUGHT TO
INCLUDE CURRENT NUTRIENT LEVELS
CURRENTS WARMING OCEAN
TEMPERATURES AMONG OTHERS. THE
TOXIN CAN ACCUMULATE IN
SHELLFISH THAT CONSUMED THE
FINAL COLLECTING AND THEN CAN
CAUSE ILLNESS IN HUMANS AS WELL
AS MARINE MAMMALS AND BIRDS
THAT CONSUME THE SHELLFISH. IN
HUMANS THIS CAN RANGE FROM MILD
GASTROINTESTINAL ILLNESS TO
SEVERE SYMPTOMS THAT MAY
INCLUDE PERMANENT LOSS OF SHORT
pAS AMNESIC SHELLFISH POISONING.
OTHERS CAN ALSO CAUSE COMA AND
OR EVEN DEATH. THE DEPARTMENT
IN COORDINATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND THE INDUSTRY
HAS BEGUN PRE SEASON TESTING
FOR TOMORROW CAST IN DUNGEONS
CRABS. AND WE'VE BEEN WATCHING
THE DATA COME IN AND HOPING TO
SEE ALL OF SAMPLE POINTS BELOW
THE ACTION LEVELS.
UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER WE HAVE TWO AREAS WHERE
THE SAMPLES HAVE TESTED ABOVE
THE THIRTY PARTS PER MILLION
ACTION LEVEL. OFFERS SUMMARIZE
THE RESULTS BEEN PROVIDE AN
UPDATE TO THE CURRENT
ADVISORIES IN EFFECT. AS OF
TODAY PRESEASON TEST RESULTS OF
DUNGEONS CRAP FROM NORTH TO
SOUTH CHAU CRESCENT CITY ALL
CRABS BELOW THE ACTION LEVEL.
TRINIDAD ALL CROWD BELOW ACTION
LEVEL EUREKA ALL CROWD BELOW
THE ACTION LEVEL. FORT BRAGG
17% OF THE SAMPLES FROM USE ALL
EXCEED ACTION LEVEL. THE
DATABASE AFTER TWO ROUNDS A
RESAMPLING ALL CRIMES ARE BELOW
THE ACTION LEVEL. HALF MOON BAY
AT SAN FRANCISCO 70% OF THE
SAMPLES FROM DUXBURY EXCEED THE
ACTION LEVEL. MONTEREY ALL
CRABS BELOW THE ACTION LEVEL
MORAL BAY ALL CRABS BELOW THE
ACTION LEVEL. AS A REMINDER THE
ACTION LEVEL FOR DEMOTE ACID IN
CRAP IS GREATER THAN THIRTY
PARTS PR MILLION IN INTERNAL
ORGANS VYSERA OR GUTS IF YOU
MAY. AND IS TWENTY PARTS PER
MILLION IN THE MEAT. EVEN IN
PRE SEASON TESTING WHEN A
LOCATION COMES BACK WITH THE
NEXT SEASON'S WE REQUIRE TWO
SETS. TO CLEAN SETS OF SAMPLES-
SEVEN DAYS APART TO REMOVE AN
ADVISORY. ADVISORIES ARE
CURRENTLY IN EFFECT FOR THE
FOLLOWING DUNGENESS CRAB FORT
BRAGG- USE ALL THEIR SHELTER
COVE HUMBOLDT COUNTY TO POINT
ARENA THIS AREA STILL UNDER
ADVISORY PENDING RETEST ROUND
ONE RETEST SAMPLE SET- FROM TEN
TWENTY NINE. HAD PASS IN THE
SECOND SAMPLE SAID IS EXPECTED.
TO BE COMPLETED- HOPEFULLY AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. DON'T DO THIS
CRAP- SERVICES GOING DUXBURY
POINT REYES TO POLLUTE POINT AS%
YOU WERE THE NATIONAL SAMPLE-
DID NOT PASS. ROUND ONE RETEST
ALSO DID NOT PASSED AROUND TO
THE FOR SAMPLES THAT PASSED.
ROUND TWO SECOND SAMPLE SAID-
ARE EXPECTED- TOMORROW- SO WE
PLAN TO GET THAT OUT RIGHT AWAY
IF THERE ARE NO UNEXPECTED-
ADVANCE THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE- WE HA. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
WANTED TO PAY THAT DUXBURY-
DELAY. EVEN WHEN THE STATUS
WILL BOB RITTERMAN AND
COMMUNICATED TO THE FLEET WITH
THAT BY THE SIX EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED HOURS OR SIX O'CLOCK
WEDNESDAY. ROCK CRAB ANOTHER
ADVISORIES ARE UPDATES ARE ROCK
CRAP CAUGHT IN THE STATE WATERS
AROUND SANTA ROSA. ISLAND
NORTHERN CHANNEL ISLANDS IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. ROCK CRAP
FROM MISSY NO HUMBOLDT COUNTY
LINE NEAR CAPE MENDOCINO
HUMBOLDT COUNTY. ROCK CRAB FROM
THE NORTH JETTY OF HUMBLE BAY
ENTRANCE TO THE CALIFORNIA
OREGON BORDER. THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
HAVE BEEN MAINTAINING ONGOING
EFFORT WITH THE VOLUNTEERS AND
INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE SAMPLES AS
PART OF THE DEMONIC ACID
MONITORING AND AS YOU CAN SEE
ON THE SLIDE- THE SAMPLING IS.
PRETTY COMPLICATED PROCESS. BUT
IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT
THE INDUSTRY SUPPORT AND IT'S
BEEN CRITICAL AND I REPEAT
CRITICAL IN OBTAINING
ADDITIONAL SAMPLES. OF THE
IMPACTED AREA SO OUR DEPARTMENT
CAN MAKE A DETERMINATION TO THE
POTENTIAL RISKS TO PUBLIC
HEALTH. WE WISH TO THANK. THEM
PUBLICLY FOR THE HARD WORK IN
THE SUPPORT THEY PROVIDE. OUR
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO POST RESULTS ON
OUR WEBSITE THE PUBLIC CAN
CONDUCT A SEARCH INTERNET
SEARCH UNDER FOOD DRUG BRANCH
DEMOC ACID OR C. PH TO MARK
ACID. AND IN CLOSING I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
INVITING US HERE TODAY. REALIZE
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF OUR ACTIONS
AND I'M AWARE I'M HERE TO
REAFFIRM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- COMMITMENT TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR PARTNER
AGENCIES. FISHERMEN AND
ASSOCIATED INDUSTRY AND THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE TIMELY AND
RELEVANT INFORMATION AND TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THE
PUBLIC WHO CONSUME THIS
CALIFORNIA COMMODITY. DURING
THIS HOLIDAY SEASON AND
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU SEE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND I THINK
WE'RE ALL GONNA KNOCK ON WOOD
RIGHT NOW- AND THAT. WE HAVE
SOME CLEAN TEST COMPANY SO
AGAIN. WILL SAVE TRENDS HAVE
BEEN GOOD- BUT UNDRSTAND THAT
WE HAD THE WITCHING HOUR
TOMORROW AT SIX O'CLOCK THAT IS
CORRECT ALL RIGHT. THERE WE GO
THANK YOU BREAKING HAVE BEEN.
IS YOUR SON'S DAYTIME APPLE
CIDER NOT CHAMPAGNE. IF WE GET
IT SO WATCH OUT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR THANK YOU IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO SEE AN PLEASE A PESAR
THANKS TO THE TEAM AS WELL. AS
YOU GUYS HAVE REALLY BEEN
WORKING HARD WITH A DEPARTMENT
FISH WILDLIFE WILL DO THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
TURN IT ON TO THE ENVIRONMENT
PROGRAM MANAGER- THERE AT THE
PROVINCIAL LIFE THANK YOU
MASTER. HE'S GOING TO BE
TALKING TO US ABOUT THE WORKING
GROUP THAT YOU'VE HEARD IN
REGARDS TO- WHALES IN TRYING TO
EVALUATE THE RISK OF MARINE
LIFE AND TACKLE MAKING
CANDIDLY. HOW WE DON'T. GET
INTO THE CHALLENGES WITH
ENTANGLEMENT AS WELL HE'S GONNA
BE TALKING TO US ABOUT RULE
MAKING- AS WELL AS DEVELOPMENTS
ON THE CONSERVATION PLAN. IN OF
COURSE SAID INCIDENTAL TAKE
PERMIT ALTERNATE. OVER TO SAKE
FOR HIS REPORT IF I'M ANSWER.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
YEAH I'D PROVIDE A SHORT UPDATE
ON OUR EFFORTS TO THE WORKING
GROUP IN THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
CONSERVATION PLAN- ULTIMATELY
TO GET THE IN N. H. I.
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
AGENCY. TO IDENTIFY THE TARGETS
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE LIKELY
TO APPROVE. AND THEN OF COURSE
IS PART OF THAT REQUIREMENT IS
TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS SUCH
THAT WHEN WE- IMPLEMENT THE
CONSERVATION PLAN UNDER THE I.
T. P. WE THE DEPARTMENT CAN
ACTUALLY. PROMULGATE THAT
ACTIVITY THROUGH RULES SO. AS
YOU'VE HEARD WE SHARED WITH THE
WORKING GROUP IN SEPTEMBER OUR
TRASH- REGULATORY PROPOSAL TO
BUILD THAT. A MANAGEMENT
FRAMEWORK WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT
INPUT FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS ON
THAT WERE MAKING SOME MINOR
MODIFICATIONS. WE HOPE TO-
DISTRIBUTE A DRAFT PROPOSAL FOR
THAT COMING LATE WINTER EARLY
SPRING. ON OUR DRAFT PROPOSALS
FOR THAT RULE MAKING THAT WILL
BE VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
WILL BE THE GUIDING RULES AND
AS YOU KNOW THE IT WILL REPLACE
THE STATUTORY. STRUCTURE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDED TO
MANAGE- MARINE LIFE
ENTANGLEMENT SO IT'S A PRETTY
IMPORTANT RULE MAKING TO PAY
ATTENTION TO. WE ARE STILL
DEVELOPING TOOLS TO HELP ASSESS
RISK. ONE OF THE KEY THINGS IS
THE MODELING WORK TO IDENTIFY
TRENDS IN OCEAN CONDITIONS AND
PARTICULARLY RELATED TO FORAGE
AS WE SAW YESTERDAY OUR
OBSERVERS BY PLANE- WELLS LOVE
ANCHOVIES IT'S- IN THE WORKING
GROUP PARLANCE THIS IS AN
ANCHOVY YOU'RE NOT A CREEL
YEAR. AND WHEN WE HAVE ANCHOVY
YEARS THE HUMPBACKS IN
PARTICULAR HANG AROUND LONGER
AND TEND TO BE CLOSE TO SHORE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
ANCHOVIES THAT IS A HIGHER RISK
ENVIRONMENT THAN WHAT WE WOULD
CALL A CREEL YEAR WHICH TENDS
TO KEEP THE WHALES FURTHER
OFFSHORE. THOUGHT DEVELOPING
THOSE TOOLS ARE GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS WAS
MENTIONED HERE EARLIER ONE OF
OUR GOALS IS TO GIVE THE FLEET
SOME SENSE OF PREDICTABILITY SO
THEY CAN MAKE THEIR DECISIONS
RATHER THAN THE POTENTIAL CHAOS
OF AT THE LAST MINUTE KNOWING
WHERE THEY CAN GO FISH SO
THAT'S A LONG TERM PROJECT. THE
OTHER THING AS- SUSAN ROCKLINE
POINTED OUT IS HOW TO FISH.
WITH GEAR OR METHODS THAT JUST
WON'T CATCH WHALES. SO WHETHER
IT'S GETTING RID OF SLACK LINE
WHICH THERE'S A LOT OF
SUSPICION IS CERTAINLY
CONTRIBUTES TO ENTANGLEMENT-
WERE INVESTIGATING AS YOU KNOW
ROLL BLISS TECHNOLOGIES THERE
STILL A WAYS OUT I BELIEVE SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WORKING WITH
INNOVATORS THE FISHERMAN WAS
ALSO POINTED OUT THERE VERY
INNOVATIVE BUNCH. WERE TRYING
TO FACILITATE THEIR INNOVATION-
THROUGH PROGRAMS TO GET TESTING
OUT ON THE WATER THIS SEASON.
TO HELP DEVELOP LESS WELL
STICKY GEAR- AND I THINK I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT UNLESS THERE'S
ANY PARTICULAR QUESTIONS REST
OF TALK ABOUT- THIS IS GONNA BE
AN ISSUE NOT JUST HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
WEST COAST IN JUST ENHANCE
COORDINATION FOR EXAMPLE. ON
THE SPECIFIC ISSUE- WITH ORGAN
IN WASHINGTON IS CAME UP AT THE
COMMISSION MEETING THAT WE ARE
AT AND I THINK THE IMPORTANCE
OF IT HAVE UNIFORM STANDARDS I
WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH. BUT I CAN'T CHOCOLATE
ABOUT THAT YES SURE. FOR A FEW
YEARS NOW- BECAUSE THE TRISTATE
WHALES POPPED UP ON THAT-
AGENDA COUPLE YEARS AGO- TO BE
FRANK IT FIRST OREGON
WASHINGTON REALLY THINK THEY
HAD A WEL PROBLEM UNTIL THEY
DID. AND SO THEY- AS A RESULT
OF THAT WE FORMED A MUCH
STRONGER PARTNERSHIP WE ARE
WORKING TOGETHER. THROUGH
ROUTINE- CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHAT METHODS ARE LOOKING AT
REGULATIONS. OREGON WASHINGTON
ARE BOTH LOOKING AT POT LIMITS.
DURING HIGH RISK PERIODS WHERE
THEY WOULD REDUCE THE PERCENT
OF GEAR THAT EACH PERMIT HOLDER
CATFISH. AS A WAY TO REDUCE
LINES IN THE WATER- THEY'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT A SPECIAL
PERMIT FOR THOSE ONE A FISSION
THE SPRING TIME THAT WOULD.
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF FISHERMEN
AND GEAR SO THEY'RE LOOKING AT
ALL KINDS OF TECHNIQUES.
WASHINGTON REQUIRES A
RECREATIONAL FISHERY TO CARRY
UNIQUE BUT WE ON THEIR GEAR.
OUT WE'RE BORROWING THAT
PROPOSING TO BAR THAT FOR
RECREATIONAL FISHERY BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW UNDER THE TERMS OF THE
SETTLEMENT. AND ULTIMATELY WHAT
I THINK THE TAKE PERMIT RULE
REQUIRES OF IS WE DON'T WANT
UNIDENTIFIED GEAR. CLOSING OUR
COMMERCIAL FISHERY SO AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE PROPOSALS
WERE GONNA BE ASKING THE
COMMISSION LOOK AT IT IS A
UNIQUE IDENTIFYING A MARK ON
THE RECREATIONAL GEAR SO WE
DON'T. INADVERTENTLY CLOSER
COMMERCIAL HERE. MY LAST
QUESTION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE IF
YOU WILL THE PROGRAM WRAPPED UP
IN. FORMALIZED HERE WHAT DO YOU
THINK IN I IN REGARDS TO ALL
ISSUES OF. THE RULE MAKING. HOW
LONG YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH.
OUR HOPE IS TO HAVE THE RAMP
RULE MAKING READY FOR NEXT
SEASON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CRAB SEASON UHHUH WE AS YOU
KNOW WE PLAN ON SUBMITTING A
COMPREHENSIVE DRAFT
CONSERVATION PLAN THIS MAY.
WHICH WILL START THE FEDERAL
PROCESSES OF REVIEW. SOUL I
THINK THE BOTTOM END I SHOULD
MENTION WERE. POSING TO HAVE
THE FIRST RAMP RULE MAKING DONE
FOR NEXT SEASON WERE CALLING
THAT RAMP ONE POINT I'LL- WE
KNOW WE'RE LIKELY TO HAVE TO
MAKE MODIFICATIONS BASED ON THE
FINAL VERSION OF THE
CONSERVATION PLAN THE FEDERAL
AGENCY PROS SO WE'LL DO A
FOLLOW UP RULE MAKING TO
IMPLEMENT ANY CHANGES. BUT
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET AS CLOSE
AS POSSIBLE SO WE PLAN ON
HAVING. MOST OF THE HEAVY
LIFTING DONE BY THE NEXT SEASON
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY NEXT UP OR TO SEE
THANK YOU. I THINK EVER NOT
ONLY MOVING FORWARD THE BILL TO
HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THOSE WHO
REPRESENT THE FISHMAN
THEMSELVES AND THAT'S GONNA BE
SEASON RIGHT WINE IN NOAH
OPPENHEIM. HIS ROUTE WINE IS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA CAST
CRAP ASSOCIATION- IT'S A NEWLY
FORMED ASSOCIATION FOCUS ON
NORTH COAST FISHERY. I AND SHE
CAN TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE SITUATION. IN THE
PERSPECTIVE OF THE UPCOMING
SEASON AS WELL AS- DOING LITTLE
BIT OF A DEEPER DIVE RIGHT.
ONLINE ISSUES OF WHALES OR DEMO
CASSIDY SANDRA WE'RE GONNA TURN
THE FLOOR OVER TO MISS RIGHT
WINES FROM WHEN YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEES GOOD TO SEE YOU AND
THANK YOU. FOR MAKING THE TREK
UP FROM HUMBLE COUNTY TRINIDAD
DOWN SACRAMENTO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
MORNING. AND I JUST WANT TO PUT
ONE CLICK. SLIDE UP ON THEIR.
JUST SO I CAN REMEMBER THE
PLACE I'M FROM A YOU'RE GOOD
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO NEXT ONE UP.
NEXT ONE UP. THERE YEAH.
PERFECT AND THEN YOU GET A BLOW
IT UP. I DAM. AGAIN THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION IN THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY. I'D
LIKE TO PROVIDE A STATEMENT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR
CALIFORNIA COAST CRAB
ASSOCIATION THAT WAS DRAFTED BY
A PRESIDENT HE'S BUSY GETTING
READY FOR CRAB SEASON AND
COULDN'T ATTEND TODAY. AND I
THINK OUR CRAB GOING TO BE
READY BY THE FIFTEENTH. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID THE CALIFORNIA
COAST CRAB ASSOCIATION- CC CA
IS A NON PROFIT COMMERCIAL
TRADE ORGANIZATION THAT IS
FUNDED BY CRAB FISHERMEN CRAB
BUYERS AND DONATIONS FROM LOCAL
COASTAL COMMUNITY BUSINESSES.
OUR MEMBERS ARE A DIVERSE GROUP
OF DUNGEON AS CRAB BOAT OWNERS
HIRED SKIPPERS CRAB BUYERS AND
PROCESSORS. SEE SEE SEE A WAS
FORMED AFTER THE OUT OF COURT
SETTLEMENT IN THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY VERSUS
CHUCK BONHAM IN THE DEPARTMENT.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS BANDED
TOGETHER TO PRESERVE AND
PROTECT OUR MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR COMMERCIAL CRAB
INDUSTRY THE PAYS THE BILLS
WITH THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES IN
OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
WITHOUT A VIABLE CRAB FISHERY
MOST OF US COULD SIMPLY NOT
AFFORD TO CONTINUE ON. THE
TERMS FOR FISHING UNDER THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT. ARE AN
OVER REACH THAT WILL RESULT IN
A SEVERELY CRIPPLED CRAB
FISHERY THESE TERMS INCLUDE
UNREASONABLE AN INEFFECTIVE
EXPENSIVE GEAR MODIFICATIONS
CONSTANT CLOSURES WHICH MAY
CAUSE A FISHERY COLLAPSE. IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT OUR
INDUSTRY HAS PROACTIVELY
ADDRESSED WILL INTERACTIONS FOR
YEARS BEFORE THIS LAWSUIT WITH
VOLUNTARY MEASURES IN
LEGISLATION THAT INCLUDES
STRAPLINE GEAR MODIFICATIONS
THE WORKING GROUP. AND THE LOS
GEAR RETRIEVAL PROGRAM THESE
MEASURES HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
REDUCED CONFIRMED INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN LISTED OF WILLS AND
COMMERCIAL CRAB GEAR TO
PRACTICALLY ZERO. RECENT
STUDIES SUGGEST AN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE IN THE POPULATION OF
HUMPBACK WHALES THAT MY GREAT
ALONG OUR COAST IT IS BECOMING
CLEAR THAT ARE FISHERIES
MINIMAL INTERACTION WITH WHEELS
IS HAVING LITTLE TO NO EFFECT
ON THE ROBUSTLY GROWING
POPULATIONS. THIS NEWS SHOULD
BE CELEBRATED. NOT MET WITH
DRACONIAN AND UNNECESSARY
FISHING RESTRICTIONS. AS A
MEMBER OF THE WILL WORKING
GROUP MYSELF I'VE BEEN AN
ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN THE RISK
ASSESSMENT PROCESS FOR UPCOMING
SEASON. THE OTHER TWELVE
INDUSTRY MEMBERS ON THE ON THE
WORKING GROUP WHO ARE ALSO
MEMBERS OF THE CC CA WERE
CONCERNED LAST MONTH WHEN THE
DIRECTOR DID NOT FOLLOW THE
FINDING OF LOW RISK THAT WAS
DETERMINED BY THE FULL GROUP
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT'S OWN
SCIENCE TEAM AND THE MARINE
MAMMAL EXPERTS FROM NOVA.
INSTEAD CHOSE TO DELAY THE
OPENING OF OUR SEASON BASED ON
CONCERNS FROM THE MINORITY
OPINION FROM THE NON
GOVERNMENTAL ASSOCIATIONS. SEE
SEE SEE A REQUEST THAT THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ENCOURAGE THE
DIRECTOR TO RESPECT AND FOLLOW
THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATION PROCESS SET
FORTH IN THE WORKING GROUP'S
GUIDELINES. AND MAKE DECISIONS
BASED ON SCIENCE AND ECONOMIC
CONCERNS AND NOT POLITICAL
PRESSURE FROM NGOS. GOING
FORWARD FISHERIES MANAGEMENT
MUST BE ADAPTIVE TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE DRAMATIC INCREASES
IN MARINE MAMMAL POPULATIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT MUST ALSO USE
THE PRINCIPLE THAT GUIDES
FISHERY Là OF THE NATION. THAT
REGULATIONS AND RESTRICTIONS
PLACED ON ANY FISHERY MUST BE
IN DIRECT PROPORTION TO THE
ACTUAL RISK TO THE LISTED
SPECIES ENDS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE ECONOMIC IMPORTANCE OF THE
COMMERCIAL FISHERY TO ITS
COASTAL COMMUNITIES. SEE SEE
SEE A HAS SUBMITTED A DETAILED
PROPOSAL FOR FURTHER MITIGATING
MARINE MAMMAL INTERACTIONS TO
THE WORKING GROUP AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO DATE WE HAVE
RECEIVED NO FORMAL RESPONSE. WE
HAVE OFFERED TO HELP FACILITATE
WIDER AND MORE FREQUENT SERVICE
AND WE HAVE ACCESS TO BOATS
PLANES AND CREWS THAT COULD
HOST THEM. WE ARE OURSELVES
DESIGNING A RESEARCH STUDY
USING OUR MEMBER VESSELS THAT
WILL IMPROVE THE UNDERSTANDING
OF FLEET DYNAMICS IN RELATION
TO WILL MIGRATION. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE ARE
ACTIVELY PROMOTING OUR SLACK
LINE INITIATIVE THROUGHOUT THE
FLEET. IT HAS BEEN PROVEN THAT
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF SLACK
AND BELIEVE LINE'S GREATLY
REDUCES THE POSSIBILITY OF
INTERACTIONS WITH MARINE
MAMMALS. WE HAVE ALSO PROPOSED
MULTIPLE PRACTICAL GEAR
MODIFICATIONS TO OPEN THE
SOUTHERN HALF OF THE STATE THIS
SPRING WHICH WILL BE CLOSED. BY
THE TERMS OF THE SETTLEMENT.
THE SIMPLE GEAR MODIFICATIONS
COULD BE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE WILL
NOT SERIOUSLY CHANGING HOW WE
ALREADY FISH WERE BE COST
PROHIBITIVE LIKE THE
IMPRACTICAL AND HIGHLY
EXPENSIVE WROBLEWSKI YEAR BEING
PROMOTED BY NGOS. IN CONCLUSION
WE ASK THAT THE JOINT FISHERIES
COMMITTEE SUPPORT THE CRAB
FISHING INDUSTRY IN THIS
CRITICAL TIME. IN PARTICULAR WE
ASK THAT ARE COASTAL SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS STAND UP
FOR THEIR MANY CONSTITUENTS IN
THE DOZENS OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES IN THEIR DISTRICTS.
WE REQUEST THAT THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE ENCOURAGE THE
DEPARTMENT AND DIRECTOR TO DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO SUPPORT
THIS FISHERY AND WORK WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION AS THE PRIMARY.
FOCUS OF OURS IS OUR DUNGENESS
CRAB SEASON. WE REQUEST THAT
THE COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE DIRECTOR HELP SECURE A
SEAT AT THE TABLE FOR OUR
ORGANIZATION FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION PLAN AND IN
INCIDENTAL TAKE PERMIT
APPLICATION WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY GUIDE THE MANAGEMENT
OF OUR FISHERY. FINALLY THAT
THE DIRECTOR IN THE APARTMENT.
MANAGE OUR SUSTAINABLE
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERY BASED ON
OBJECTIVE SCIENCE AND ECONOMIC
CONSIDERATIONS AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING US IN TODAY'S
TESTIMONY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING PRODUCTIVELY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE DEPARTMENT
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT OUR
FUTURE FISHERY. THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THROWING
HOUSEHOLD QUESTIONS COMMENTS
UNTIL WE HEAR FROM YOU TO YOU
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN OVER TO
KNOW OPPENHEIM THE EXECUTRIX OF
THE PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATION- MISTER
OFTENTIMES GIMME GIVEN US
PERSPECTIVE ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT IN THE
OCEAN AS WE ARE ABOUT TO OPEN.
CRAB SEASON AND WILL ALSO BE
FOCUSING ON SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WITH THESE
DELAYS AS WELL MISS ROBIN I'M
YOUR FIVE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WILL OPEN IT UP AND
ENTERTAIN- QUESTIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
FOR THE RECORD MY NAME'S NO
OPPENHEIM AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS. OUR
ORGANIZATION IS A NON PROFIT
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN PORT AND
SECTOR MARKETING ASSOCIATIONS
FROM SANTA BARBARA CRESCENT
CITY CALIFORNIA AND FOR FORTY
THREE YEARS PC OF A HAS BEEN
FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF WORKING
FISHERMEN THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AND THE RESOURCES
ON WHICH THEY DEPEND TO
PRESERVE THE PROSPERITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF THIS INDUSTRY
ACROSS MULTIPLE SECTORS. AND
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT TWENTY
NINETEEN HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
MOST CHALLENGING YARS IN THIS
ORGANIZATIONS HISTORY I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM WORKING
ON THIS FISHERY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT
TWENTY TWENTY IS BETTER NOT
WORSE FOR THE CRAB FISHERY IN
IN A MOMENT I'LL TALK ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
GOAL. SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE SETTLEMENT IN THE C. B.
D. V. BOTTOM LITIGATION IN
MARCH THE UNCERTAINTY
SURROUNDING THE OPERATION OF
THE DENTURES CRAB FISHERY HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY FISHMAN WERE
ABLE TO CELEBRATE A SMALL
VICTORY THE SUMMERS THE PS SOME
OF SEE FINALLY DISTRIBUTED HOT
HARD FOUGHT FISHERY DISASTER
FUNDS TO OUR MEMBERS IN THE
CRAB FISHERY. WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR REQUIRES WAS STAFF AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF. FISH AND
WILDLIFE NATIONAL OCEANIC AND
ATMOSPHERIC. ADMINISTRATION THE
PACIFIC STATES MARINE FISHERIES
COMMISSION AND A FEW KEY
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION AND
THEIR STAFF FOR SECURING THESE
FUNDS. THEY WERE CRITICAL PART
OF- THE BOTTOM LINE FOR
HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES AND
BUSINESSES THIS YEAR BUT TO
MANY THESE DISASTER FUNDS
COMING MORE THAN THREE YEARS
AFTER THE INITIAL DISASTER AT
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR. WE'RE
SMALL COMFORT GIVEN THE NEW
CHALLENGES WERE FACING. SAYS OF
OPENING THE DUNGEONS CRAB
FISHERY IS THAT CHALLENGE THIS-IS BECOME A GORDIAN KNOT OF
INTERACTING REGULATORY PROCESS
SEES. THAT A FISHERMAN ON PINS
AND NEEDLES EVERY DAY. IN THE
CHALLENGES GET MORE MORE
SERIOUS AS MORE MORE LAYERS OF
UNCERTAINTY ARE ADDED. STAFF
AND LEADERSHIP OF THE MARINE
REGION OF CDS W. IN AT CITY PA
TO VOTE DEVOTED A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. THEY WIN WORKING LONG
HOURS AND SOME OVER THE WEEKEND
TO ENSURE THAT THE DEMO GUESSES
ACID TESTING THAT IS OCCURRING
AS WE SPEAK. GO BY THE BOOK AND
I WANT TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
TO THEM WE'RE ON A PATH TO
OPENING THIS FISHERY THIS WEEK.
AND I AND MY COLLEAGUES KNOW
THAT THE INDUSTRY WILL TAKE
GREAT CARE WHILE ENSURING THAT
THE PUBLIC CRAB RESOURCES WILL
BE ENJOYED Y THE PEOPLE.
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
THANKSGIVING CRAB. ON DINNER
PLATES IN THE MARKET BUT I'M
ALSO LOOKING AT THE SERIES OF
DECISIONS THAT FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER AGENCIES WILL. BE MAKING
AS WE PROCEED AND I THINK THERE
ARE FOUR KEY NEEDS- THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS FIRST WE MUST
AND DESIGN FLEXIBILITY INTO THE
STATE'S INCIDENTAL TAKE
PERMITS. FOR THIS AND OTHER FIX
YOUR FISHERIES THAT MEANS WE
MUST USE MOVING AVERAGES OF
IMPACTS PROTECTED MARINE MAMMAL
STOCKS WE MUST UPDATE
THRESHOLDS TO REFLECT THE
RECOVERY OF THE STOCKS. GETTING
THEIR MEANS STRONGLY
ENCOURAGING THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE TO RESOLVE
THE KEY ISSUE REGARDING THE
INTERACTION OF THE TWO OVER
ARCHING FEDERAL STATUTES
GUIDING THIS PROCESS. AND TO
CONDUCT A LONG OVERDUE UPDATE
TO THEIR LARGE MARINE MAMMAL
STOCK ASSESSMENTS. SECOND WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE WORKING
GROUP. IS ABLE TO MAKE SURGICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
ANY IN SEASON ACTION TAKEN TO
REDUCE ENTANGLEMENT RISK. AND
REOPEN ANY CLOSED AREAS AS
EXPEDITIOUSLY AS POSSIBLE WHICH
IS REQUIRED IN SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH NINE. THIRD WE MUST
SEE COST EFFECTIVE GEAR
MODIFICATIONS FOR THIS UPCOMING
SEASON AS WELL AS FUTURE
SEASONS. I THANK THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL- FOR LAYING
OUT A GOOD PATH OF THIS
APPROACH IN ITS PROPOSED TO
TEACH YOU PLAN BY HIGHLIGHTING
COOPERATIVE RESEARCH. AS THE
IDEAL APPROACH HERE AS THEY
PROPOSE COOPERATIVE RESEARCH
WILL BE CHANNELED THROUGH THE
WORKING GROUP I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT SUPPORT COMING
FROM THIS PROCESS BE USED TO
PRIORITIZE TESTING IN
IMPLEMENTING READILY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGIES. RATHER THAN
SUBSIDIZING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW GEARS LIKE POP UP SYSTEMS.
AND FOURTH WE MUST EXPAND THE
SCOPE OF PROTECTIONS TO MARINE
LIFE TO OTHER SECTORS AND I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE BEGUN
EMBARKING ON THAT PATH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S THE
RECREATIONAL SECTOR. OFFSHORE
ENERGY IMPACTS TO MARINE
MAMMALS SHIPPING OR PURSUIT OF
MARINE MAMMALS IN TOURIST
INDUSTRIES- RESPONSIBLE
MITIGATION OF RISK MUST BE
SHARED ACROSS SECTORS AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE WORKING ON THAT.
RESPONDING TO THE ESSAY IS
NOTHING NEW TO THIS FISHING
INDUSTRY. IN THE CASE OF A
CALIFORNIA DUNGEONS CRAB
FISHERY RISING TO THIS
CHALLENGE MEANS UNITING IN
COMMON PURPOSE TO ACHIEVE THE
MOST FAVORABLE I TT POSSIBLE.
THE FIGHT ANY FUTURE LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO THE STATE'S
PROGRESS AND TO WORK WITH YOU
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHER
LEADERS IN THE STATE INCLUDING-
DIRECTOR BONHAM AND THE PUBLIC
OF COURSE TO REMIND THEM OF THE
VALUETHAT BIBLE OR SHOULD
FISHERIES BRING TO THEM. WHILE
ENSURING THAT WE CAN HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS WE CAN PROTECT
WHALES. SEA TURTLES AND WE CAN
PROTECT COMMERCIAL FISHING
COMMUNITIES. FURTHER CALIFORNIA
FISHERIES IN ANOTHER WEST COAST
STATES THE ROAD AHEAD IS LESS
CLEAR THE RIGHT NOW WE ARE OUT
IN FRONT OF A MASSIVE
TRANSITIONAL PROCESS TAKING
PLACE WE MUST TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY.
BECAUSE WE DESIGN A PATH FOR
THAT IS INFLEXIBLE AND IT FAILS
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE RECOVERY
MARINE MAMMAL STOCKS WE WILL
FAIL TO ACHIEVE THE BALANCE WE
NEED TO ENSURE. THAT FISHING
COMMUNITIES AND MARINE LIFE CAN
PROCESS WE MUST APPROACH THESE
ISSUES IN A REASON AND
COORDINATED WAY AND SOON THE
CONSEQUENCES OF FAIING TO
ORGANIZE OUR ALL TOO CLEAR TO
ALL OF US. WITH YOUR HELP
SENATOR WE'RE GOING TO WORK TO
GET TO TACKLE THIS INCREASINGLY
CHALLENGING ISSUE. FOR THE SAKE
OF OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES AND
YOU CAN. ONCE WE MUST. TRUMP
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THROWING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK TO BETTER DIRECT OF ONE
OF THE ITEMS THAT- I NAY
PARAPHRASE HERE FROM A
STRUGGLING TO THE DIRECTOR HERE
AND TO BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON IN
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THERE'S GOING
TO BE REPRESENTATION IN
INTERACTION ON THE WAY WORKING
GROUP- WITH AT BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS. AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD ONLINE AT THE STATE
PERMIT THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
BE TO GO TO THE FEDS WITH I
SOON IT IS GOING TO BE SOME
INTERACTION- WITH- EACH
ASSOCIATIONS ULTIMATELY IT'S
GOING TO BE THE DEPARTMENTAL
DECISION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE FINAL BUT CAN YOU JUST TALK
TO US ABOUT THAT AND HOW THAT
OUT REACH WOULD LOOK LIKE. AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THE-
STATE PERMIT. OF COURSE THEY'LL
BE A RICH. WE NEED THE INPUT
FROM ALL OF THE EXPERTS WHETHER
THEY'RE IN THE COMMERCIAL FLEET
SECTOR. AARON ACADEMIA OR THAT
UP OR THEY MIGHT BE IN OUR
SISTER FEDERAL AGENCY THE
NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES
SERVICE. SO THE OTHER THING I'D
SAY IS LISTENING TO MISS ROUTE
ONES TESTIMONY I ACTUALLY THINK
SHE AND I SHARE SOME CORE
VALUES. FOR EXAMPLE. I HEARD
THE VALUE EXPRESSED OF
INCLUSIVENESS I AGREE. IT'S
PRETTY DIVERSE GROUP THAT
EXISTS WITHIN- WORKGROUP WE'VE
ESTABLISHED AND IT INCLUDES THE
ASSOCIATION. AND I THINK FORMAL
RECOGNITION OF THE
ASSOCIATION'S ACTUAL ATTORNEY.
AS ONE OF THEIR SPOKESPERSONS
AND THE WORKER SO INCLUSIVENESS
I'M FOR. I THINK ANOTHER SHARED
VALUES TRANSPARENCY. I AGREE
WITH MISS ROB WIND THAT THE
WORKING GROUP FUNCTIONS BEST.
IF PARTIES ARE BRINGING BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE OPENLY. AND
DISCUSSING IT TRANSPARENTLY
THAT COMMITMENT TO TRANSPARENCY
IS A REASON WHY I WANTED TO
DAYLIGHT THIS MORNING THAT WE
HAD A PLAN IN THE YEAR
YESTERDAY. AND I THINK A THIRD
SHARED VALUES IS ACTUALLY
BALLOTS. SO LET ME CORRECT ANY
MISIMPRESSION. SO THERE WAS A
WORKING GROUP MEETING IN
NOVEMBER. AND AT THAT MOMENT IN
TIME THE WORKING GROUP REACHED
CONSENSUS I BELIEVE. THAT THE
RISK THEY SAW FOR WILL
ENTANGLEMENTS DIDN'T
NECESSARILY WARRANTED DELAY IN
THE OPEN. BUT THE WORKING GROUP
WELL KNEW THEY WERE HAVING A
SECOND MEETING. AND IN BETWEEN
THE FIRST MEETING IN THE SECOND
MEETING NO- AND OTHER
SCIENTIFIC ENTITIES HAD
GATHERED ADDITIONAL TRANSECT
DATA. AT THE SECOND MEETING.
THE WORKING GROUP BROKE INTO A
MAJORITY OPINION AND A MINORITY
UP AND- THE MAJORITY OPINION
ADVOCATED THAT THE DEPARTMENT
STICK WITH THE NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH OPENER. THE MINORITY
OPINION WHICH INCLUDED SOME
COMMERCIAL CRABBERS AS WELL AS
ARGUABLY THE VOICE OF OUR
SCIENTIFIC FEDERAL AGENCY STAFF.
ADVOCATED THAT WE DELAYED UNTIL
DECEMBER FIRST. BALANCE TO ME
IS THE DEPARTMENT'S OUTCOME WE
DELAYED SEVEN DAYS UNTIL THIS
COMING WEEKEND. THAT BALANCE
WAS STRUCK BETWEEN MANAGING TO
AVOID WAYLAND HANG ON THE BASED
ON OBJECTIVE SCIENCE. WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE ECONOMIC
VALUE OF HAVING THIS PRODUCT ON
THE THANKSGIVING PLAY. AND THE
LAST THING I'D SAY IS WE REMAIN
OPEN TO ANY INSTRUCTION OR
ENCOURAGEMENT FROM THE JOINT
COMMITTEE PARTICULARLY THE
CHAIR. CAN YOU JUST OUTLINED AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD ON THE PERMIT
AND- AND SEEKING FEEDBACK AND
HOW THAT LOOKS. MY IMPRESSION
AND MISTER MASTER CAN CORRECT
ME IF I HAVE IT WRONG IS WE
NEED TO USE THE WORKING GROUP
AS A ENTITY THAT ADVISES US ON
THE PARAMETERS. AND THE
COMPONENTS OF WHAT MIGHT BE IN
THE FINAL APPLICATIONS FOR A
FEDERAL PERMIT. WE NEED TO DO
THAT IN PARALLEL WITH USING
THAT ADVICE TO POPULATE THE
STATE WILL MAKING WE WILL
PURSUE IN FRONT OF OUR FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION. WE CAN'T DO
WITHOUT THAT BODY GIVING US THE
ADVICE ON CONTENT AND APPROACH.
SMASHED OF ANYONE AND THEN TURN
IT BACK OVER TO MISS YET ONE
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU. I WOULD
JUST ADD. A KEY DOCUMENT AND
THAT OUTRAGE IS THE ACTUAL RULE
MAKING THAT IS THE POWER.
BEHIND THE CONSERVATION PLAN I.
T. P. WE SHARE THAT IN
SEPTEMBER HAVE GOTTEN INPUT.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE WE WILL
BE DOING OUT REACH ON THE FULL
CONSERVATION PLAN BUT MOST THE
CONSERVATION PLAN IS CONTEXT.
THE CORE ELEMENT THAT WILL ACT
ON THIS FISHERY IS THE RULES
AND SOUL ANYONE INTERESTED
FOCUS ON THOSE THAT'S WHERE WE
NEED THE INPUT BECAUSE IT IT IS
IT REPRESENTATIVE OF WHAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES. A WHAT THEY FEEL THEY
WILL BE FIND ACCEPTABLE. AND AS
MENTIONED EARLIER WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THOSE RULES.
PROVIDE THE KIND OF CLARITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND HOW THAT
FISHERIES GOING TO BE REGULATED
UNDER THIS ENVIRONMENTAL FOCUS
ON THE RULES THAT'S THE KEY
ACTION ITEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH
S. THREE SERVICE ROUTE ONE AND
A START WHEN SHOPPING AND THIS
TIME IT WILL GO TO HIS RIGHT
MIND- MR UP NINE. ANY RESPONSE
TO THAT IN REGARDS TO. BOTH IT
WILL WORKING GROUP UTILIZING
THAT AS WELL AS- FORMALIZING
FEEDBACK AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE STATE PERMIT PROCESS PLEASE
MR OPPENHEIM THEY'LL TURN FROM
IS WRONG. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE FEEDBACK HERE. THROUGH
THE WORKING GROUP IT IS A KEY.
AVENUE BY WHICH GROUND TREE
THING THE REGULATORY
DISCUSSION. IS ACCOMPLISHED. I
WANT TO COOK JUST DIVE A LITTLE
DEEPER INTO THE ISSUE I
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT. IT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE FEDERAL
AGENCY. THE FEDS HAVE. A KEY
QUESTION ON RESULTS HERE.
WITHOUT THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION THE STATE CAN'T
PROCEED. THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
WE RECONCILE POTENTIALLY-
DIFFERING IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
MARINE MAMMAL PROTECTION ACT
AND THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
WHICH BOTH EVALUATE IMPACTS AND
STOCKS OF MARINE IMPACTS TO
MARINE MAMMALS AND STOCKS OF
MARINE MAMMALS. IN DIVERGENT
WAYS. IN SOME WAYS THE MARINE
MAMMAL PROTECTION ACT TIED IT
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
IN OTHER WAYS IT DOES NOT AND
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT IN
THE WAY THAT IT. EVALUATES AND
CONTEMPLATES IMPACTS TO THE
POPULATION AS A WHOLE AND-
JEOPARDY OR NO JEOPARDY TO THAT
POPULATION IT IS DIFFERENT.
RECONCILING THOSE ISSUES IS KEY
AND I'VE SPOKEN WITH THEM STAFF
ABOUT THIS. LEADERSHIP THERE AS
WELL I KNOW THEY KNOW THIS IS A
TOP PRIORITY BUT UNTIL THEY CAN
PROVIDE GUIDANCE THE STATE. WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD SO I'M USING
THIS PLATFORM IS AN OPPORTUNITY
SHOULD SOMEONE OUT THERE IN THE
UNIVERSITY LISTENING THAT WE
NEED THIS NOW AND CERTAINLY THE
STATE PROCESS SEES TO ENCOURAGE
OUR OUR FEDERAL COLLEAGUES. TO
GET THIS DONE QUICKLY IS
WELCOME. APPRECIATED THANK YOU
SO MUCH INSTRUMENT TURN OVER
MISS RILEY FORESHORES. THANK
YOU. I OF FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF ORGANIZATION THINK WERE
LOOKING TO FORMALIZE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT'S BEING SAID
WE HAVE PROVIDED FEEDBACK TO
THE REGULATORY PROCESS THAT
SAKE- IS ALLUDING TO AND I
THINK THAT OUR CONCERN IS THAT
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED ANYTHING
BACK WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT FORM
AVAILABLE TO HAVE THAT ROBUST
DISCUSSION. NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH- IN A GO TO CLOSING FOR ME
TO YOU MISTER DIRECTOR YOU WEAR
A DRESS. THE DOCUMENT WAS
SUBMITTED I'M THROWIN
ASSOCIATION AND I ASSUME THERE
WILL BE SOME- CONVERSATION HERE
IN THE COMING WEEKS ON THAT OF
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO YOU. I A
COMMITTED TO GOING IN READING.
OF THE SUBMISSION FROM THE
ASSOCIATION WHICH I HAVEN'T
DONE YET. AND THAT WE WILL HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED MOMENT- HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ASSOCIATION AND THE WORK GROUP.
AND MY ONLY OTHER CLOSING
REMARK IS. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
AT THE DEPARTMENT. NAVIGATE
THROUGH THE COMING MOMENTS
TOGETHER. OUR COUNTERPART
AGENCIES AND ALL THE VOICES
THAT PARTICIPATE ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SEMESTER YEAH
I JUST TO CLARIFY- YESTERDAY I
IN ONE OF OUR ATTORNEYS HAD AN
HOUR AND A HALF CALL WITH CC CA
TOURNEY'S. DISCUSSING LINE FOR
LINE THEIR PROPOSAL SO THERE
HAS BEEN SOME OUT REGION
FEEDBACK NAM WERE BUSY BUT WE
WILL DO BETTER AND CONTINUE TO
DO THAT. NO THANK YOU SO MUCH
SPECIAL COMMITTEE CLOSING
COMMENTS PLEASE. I WANTED TO
THANK AGAIN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
DEPARTMENT REMAINS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
STATE AGENCIES AND ALSO THE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS AND THE
PUBLIC TO EXPEDITED TESTING
ABOVE A DUNGEON SCRAPS AND-
MARK ACID. INTO MANAGEMENT
THROWING CLOSING COMMENTS
PLEASE. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ORGANIZATION TO SPEAK TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FORMALIZING
OUR- RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PARCHMENT AND OUR CONTINUED
WORK TOGETHER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND CONSTRUCTION I'M
CLOSING COMMENTS PLEASE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SENATOR
MCGUIRE I WANT TO THANK OUR
FLEET FOR THEIR PATIENCE FOR IT
HONESTLY THERE THEIR DEDICATION
AND FOR THEIR- STICK TO IT IF
MISS. THESE OF AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING TIMES. AND A
FISHERMAN REMARKED TO ME THIS
MORNING. THAT IT'S BECOME SAD
THIS USED TO BE FUN THIS USED
TO BE A TIME WHEN YOU WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO. BOTH FEEDING
YOUR FAMILY FEEDING YOUR
COMMUNITY AND WE'LL BE HONEST
BLESSING OF YOUR BANK ACCOUNT
BECAUSE OF CHALLENGING SALMON
SEASONS OR A LONG TIME BETWEEN
THE LAST CRAP HALL BACK SO.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE THIS SYSTEM
WORK IT'S TIME TO MAKE THIS
FISHERY OPERABLE AGAIN SO THAT
WE DON'T START OUT YET ANOTHER
SECTOR OF THE COSTA ECONOMY
FROM THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A LIVING IN THIS HISTORIC
INDUSTRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU ALSO I'LL
JUST ADD TO THE SUPPORT FROM
THESE TWO AGENCIES THE
REPRESENTATIVES AND THEIR STAFF
WHO HAVE BEEN. CERTAINLY GOING
ABOVE AND BEYOND THIS WEEKEND
AT THE END OF LAST WEEK TO
ENSURE THAT THIS TESTING
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD- AS IT
SHOULD AND I HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ABILITY TO
GET ON THE WATER THIS WEEK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR BUT I MEAN
ALL THE STATUS BEFORE WE
ADJOURN THIS PANELS AT A FALL
REALLY HAS BECOME A CHALLENGING
TIME WHICH IS A FAVORITE
STEVENS SEASON FOR MANY IT'S
FINDING A TIME WHERE CRABBERS
HE GET OUT OF THE WATER- AND
MAKE IT THEIR HONEST LIVING.
THERE AMONG SOME OF THE HARDEST
WORKING IN THE STATE I AM AND
IT IS MAN ONE CHALLENGE AFTER
ANOTHER AND THE NEW TOP IT OFF
WITH FIRES IN THE FALL RIGHT UP
FALL HAS NOW BECOME A SEASON F.
CHALLENGE FOR SO MANY IN THE
STATE. I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS WHEN IT COMES OF THE
CRAB FISHERY. WE MUST COEXIST.
A IN THE HEALTH OF THE OCEAN
MEANS A HEALTHY CRAB FISHERY
AND I'LL BE THE FIRST TO SAY
THAT THE THOUSANDS WHO DEPEND
ON HEALTHY CRAP FISHER THE
FIRST ON THE FRONT LINES THEY
SAID THEY WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR
WALES FOR OTHER MARINE SPECIES
I AND OF COURSE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES A AND I HAVE EVERY
CONFIDENCE THE WORLD THAT
FLEET- BUT WE HOPE WOULD BE ON
NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH THOUSAND
MENDOCINO. FROM CAROLINE WILL
BE OUT IN THE WATERS MAKE IN
THEIR HARD EARNED LIVING IN
PROTECTION- THOSE SPECIES OF
WHALES THAT ARE OUT WITH HIM-
AND I KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE AYE DILIGENT IN THOSE
EFFORTS AS WELL AS WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FISHERMEN I
WANT TO SAY NEVER THANK YOU TO
EACH OF THE DEPARTMENT WHO
REALLY IT WE HAVE GONE FROM.
BEING REACTIVE. FIVE YEARS
GOING TO BE OUR MEMBER THAT.
HEARING THAT WE HAD IN SANTA
ROSA- IN- DO IT TYPICALLY HAS A
WORD IN FRONT OF THE SHOW- IN
HOUSE CHALLENGING IT WAS AT
THAT TIME TO BE ABLE TO REACT
TO- DEMOC ACID AND WATER CRISIS
THAT WE'RE IN. TO WHERE WE ARE
AT NOW WHILE WE STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO PUT IT INTO
CULTURE- INTO OPERATIONS AND
VERY GRATEFUL. AT HIS APARTMENT
FOR WORKING THAT IS WELL SO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
PANEL IN WHICH ALL OF YOU HAPPY
THANKSGIVING THAT IS FILLED
WITH CRAB. ON OUR PLATES SO-
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO A SECOND
HALF OF OUR HEARING WE'RE GONNA
WELCOME OUR NEXT PANEL. MR
OPPENHEIM IS GONNA BE HANGING
WITH HIS SO BECAUSE YOU'RE ON
THE NEXT PANEL AS WELL BEFORE
WE DO WE WANT TO TAKE A QUICK
MOMENT TO DO A KNOWLEDGE AN%
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S BEEN WITH THE
SENATE. FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
THAT IS. SENATE SERGEANT
JOHNSON- AND HE'S GOING TO BE
RETIRING ON ASKING THE PLEASE
STAND HE'S IN THE BACK THERE-
IN ANY WE GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
THIS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE
HEARING THIS IS GOING TO BE HIS
LAST HEARING IN HIS CAREER
WHICH WE REALLY DON'T WANT HIM
TO LEAVE AND WE'RE ALSO PRETTY
PISSED ABOUT IT- BUT- HE LOVES
TO FISH- IN SO WE NEED TO GET
HIM ABOUT A HUNDRED POUNDS OF
CRAB HERE ADD TO BE AND SAY
CONGRATULATIONS BUT- YOU'RE
GONNA BE MISSED- YOU REALLY.
MAKE THIS PLACE A SPECIAL PLACE
TO WORK WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR DEDICATION THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN A VERY KEEP THIS
BUILDING. INTO THE THOUSANDS OF
FOLKS WHO WALK THROUGH SAFE
FROM AROUND THE CLASS PLEASE
THE STAFF SERGEANT. VERY
GRATEFUL IN THIS MAN CAN FISH-
SO IT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE- IN
HOW WE BASS TO CATCH UP AND
CLEAR LIKE. FORTY HI DAY WATCH
OUT. OKAY A GOOD DAY FOR- KEVIN
IN A BAD DAY FOR THE FISH SO-
AGAIN REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
WORK SIR- IN YOU ARE SUCH A
PLEASURE TO WORK WITH AND WE
ARE GOING TO MISS YOU DEEPLY-
WE NOW WOULD LIKE ME TO MOVE
FORWARD ON OUR NEXT PANEL IN
THIS IS THE SECOND HALF OF OUR
HEARING WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING THAT IS REALLY IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT ADOPTING A COMPREHENSIVE
LONG TERM PLAN FOR FISH FROM
THE HIGHWAYS BEFORE WE GET INTO
TODAY'S PANELS I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO CALTRANS IN IN
PARTICULAR AT THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION WHO
BY THE WAY- IT HAS RECENTLY
BEEN APPOINTED WE WANT TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS AND THAT'S
MISTER JIM DAVIS I MISTER
DAVIS- HAS BEEN WITH CALTRANS
FOR QUITE A QUITE A FEW YEARS
NOW AND HE'S VERY FOCUSED ON
DELIVERING- BRIDGES AND
HIGHWAYS ON TIME AND NOW HE'S
GOING TO BE DEALING WITH FISH
AND- WE HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL MEETINGS- OVER THE PAST
MANY MONTHS AND I JUST WANNA
TAKE A MOMENT TO THE DOLLARS
MISTER DAVIS IS THIS IS NOW
PART OF SPUR FULLY THAT HE'S
WORKING ON IN A TRULY MISTER
DAVIS. MIGHT TAKE MOM SAY THANK
YOU YOU'RE SUCH A PLEASURE TO
WORK WITH WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING FORWARD ON- ARE PUTTING
FISH PASSAGE IN THE FAST LANE
PANEL FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH
THE PROMISE OF FISH FROM THE
HIGHWAYS IN HEARING FROM FISH
ASK EXPERTS FROM ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
DOCTOR ROBERT WAS STARTING TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD HE'S AN
AMAZING WORK AT UC DAVIS HE'S A
RESEARCHER A COLLEGES AND- HE
IS WITH THE CAL TROUT AS WELL.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK SIR HE'S-
WHILE THE COLD WATER FISH
SCIENTISTS FROM THE CENTER. OF
WATERSHED SCIENCES- AT- AT
DAVIS AND WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
THAT YOU WERE HERE TODAY SIR.
WE'RE ALSO GONNA BE A WELCOME
THE MARK LANCASTER THE BILL TO
PLEASE JOIN US HE'S THE-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FIVE
COUNTY SALMON CONSERVATION
PROGRAM. AND MARK IN HIS TEAM.
HAS DONE INCREDIBLE WORK. FINE
I FISH PASSAGE PROJECTS AND
PARTICULARLY IN THE NORTH
STATE. I HE'S GONNA BE SHOWN
AS- FROM THAT AS WELL HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SIR. IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE YOU. AND THEN OF COURSE AT
NO OPPENHEIM FROM THE EXACT.
HE'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE PACIFIC COAST. FEDERATION
OF FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS I
MEAN HE'S GONNA BE TALKING TO
US ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE. OF
GETTING THESE BARRIERS- CAM-
DOWN BECAUSE IT IMPACTS THE
TOTAL FISH POPULATION. ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. DOCTOR THE START
IT'S GOING TO KICK US OFF HE'S
GOING TO PRESENT. AN OVERVIEW
OF THE STATUS AMMONOIDS- THE
STATUS. OF CALIFORNIA'S SALMON.
HIGHLIGHTING THE URGENT NEED TO
BE ADDED BOTH PROTECT AND
RESTORE. CALIFORNIA'S NATIVE
FISHERIES. IN THE ERA OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. HE'S ALSO GOING
TO ADDRESS. THE PROBLEM OF.
FISH PASSAGE BARRIERS IN TRULY
THAT ONE PUT. WORDS INTO THE
GOOD DOCTORS AND MATH BUT-
THERE IS AN URGENT NEED. A AN
URGENT NEED FOR FISH TO ACCESS.
HAD WATER HABITATS NEEDS CAN BE
FOCUSING ON THAT IS WELL. WE'RE
GOING TO GIVEN THE DOCTOR A
LITTLE MORE TIME- SO HE HAS A
SEVEN TO TEN MINUTES WE'RE
INTERNET FOR OVER TO YOU SIR.
TO BE ABLE TO KICK US OFF AND
GIVE US THAT THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT VIEW. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK THE FLOOR
IS YOURS DOCTOR THIS ART. THANK
YOU SENATE MCGUIRE FIRST I KIND
OF WANTED IT TO BASICALLY
PROVIDE SOME BACK AND THE
CURRENT STATUS SOMEONE IT'S IN
CALIFORNIA- AND THEN REALLY
DISCUSS A MECHANISM TO DECLINE
BUT- THERE ARE SEVERAL BUT THE
ONES THAT THE ONE PRIMARILY ON
FOCUS ON TODAY OUR OUR FISH
BARRIERS- ONE OF THE PRIMARY
QUESTIONS WE ASKED IN THE STILL
SUPPORT SOMEONE IS REPORT WAS
WHAT IS THE STATUS O ALL
CALIFORNIA SOME ON ITS- IN
GENERAL SEVEN INTRON CALIFORNIA
OR CONTINUE TO BE IN THE
JOURNAL STATED KLEIN. WE
PREDICT THAT 45% AND 74% OF ALL
SALMON TROUT IN CALIFORNIA ARE
LIKELY TO BE EXTINCT WITHIN
FIFTY TO A HUNDRED YEARS.
RESPECTIVELY IF PRESENT TRENDS
CONTINUE. ANADROMOUS OCEAN
MIGRATING FISH SUCH AS SNOW CAN
STILL HIRING GENERAL GREATER
RISK OF EXTINCTION IN RESIDENT
OR INLAND SPECIES. IN THE
REPORT AND I SHOULD ALSO
MENTION THAT- DOCTOR PETER
MOYLES LEAD AUTHOR THIS REPORT-
I WORKED ON THIS REPORT AS WELL
WITH JACOB CATS- AND PAT SAMUEL
CAL TROUT AS WELL. WE THEN
ASKED WHAT FACTORS OF BECAUSE
OUR DECLINE THERE SEVERAL
FACTORS CONTRIBUTING TO-
SOMEONE A DECLINE IN THE STATE
ONE OF THE MAJOR SINGULAR
THREATS THAT WE FOUND AND SEE
TO SOME ON ITS WITH THIS
PASSAGE. HERE'S A MIGRATION FOR
JUVENILES AND ADULTS- MONADS
ARE LEADING CAUSE OF POPULATION
DECLINE FOR SOMEONE IT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ANOTHER
IMPORTANT- IN MAJOR THREAT
CONTINUES TO BE CLIMATE CHANGE.
BOTH BARRIERS AND CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE INHERENTLY LINKED.
ACCESS THE COLD AND CLEAN WATER
WILL BE PARAMOUNT AT THE
SPECIES ARE TO PERSIST INTO THE
FUTURE. IN PART THE KETER
STORING SALMON AND TROUT
THROUGHOUT CALFORNIA'S
RESTORING ACCESS TO DIVERSE IN
PRODUCTIVE HABITATS THAT
ALREADY EXIST INDEED THIS IS
ONE OF THE MAIN CONCLUSIONS IN
THE STATE OF SOME ON ITS REPORT
THE EASIEST WAY TO DO THIS IS
NOT TO SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AN ILL ADVISED CHANNEL
RESTORATION PROJECTS OR
PRODUCTION HATCHERIES TO
PRODUCE MORE FISHING HABITATS
WHERE THEY CAN'T EXIST OR
SURVIVE. IT SIMPLY TO PROVIDE
FISH PASSAGE HISTORICAL HABITAT
HABITAT THAT ALREADY EXISTED IN
MANY CASES IS IN PRISTINE
CONDITION. THE REASON TO DO
THIS ARE TWO FOLD FIRST SALMON
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
GENERAL BECOME GENETICALLY
HOMOGENIZE ELECT DIVERSITY
MAKING AN EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
TO SUDDEN CHANGES IN THEIR
ENVIRONMENT. ACCESS
HISTORICALLY PRODUCTIVE IN
DIVERSE HABITATS WILL IMPROVE
POPULATION DIVERSITY AND
SPECIES RESILIENCE IN THE FACE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. SECONDLY
REMOVAL BEARERS WILL PROVIDE
ACCESS TO COLD HAD WATER
HABITATS AND SPRINGS. THESE
HABITATS WILL BE KEY ON A
RAPIDLY CHANGING CLIMATE AND
THE STREAM WATER TEMPERATURES
WARM. IN THE PERIOD BETWEEN THE
SPRING SNOWMELT AND FALL RAINS
BECOMES A PROLONGED. TRANSCRIPT
HOW TRANS CURRENTLY HAS OVER
FIVE THOUSAND ROAD CROSSINGS
AND SOMEONE IN STREAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND AS
SUCH IS THE SINGLE LARGEST
OWNER MANAGER FISH BEARS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS COMEDIAN
CALTRANS OF AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY TO RESTORE FISH
PASSAGE THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ACCESS IMPORTANT HERE
HISTORICAL HABITATS. THAT ARE
BEING KEY TO LONG TERM
PERSISTENCE OVER NATIVE AND
ENDEMIC SOME ON ITS- THIS
CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER IT HAS
TO HAPPEN NOW. RESTORING FISH
PASSAGE MANY THESE BETTER SHUT
SHOULD FOCUS ON FULL
REMEDIATION AND NOT PARTIAL
REMEDIATION TECHNIQUES. BRIDGES
IN FULL SPAN TO BE HIGHLY
PRIORITIZE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
PARTICULARLY LOS OF THOSE
LOCATIONS WERE FISH STAND TO
BENEFIT THEMOST. BRIDGES AND
FULL SPANS ENSURE UNIMPEDED
ACCESS TO HAD WATER HABITAT.
PROCESS CEASE TO FUNCTION
PROPERLY PROCESSES TO DELIVER
VITAL INPUT NECESSARY TO CREATE
COMPLEX HABITAT FOR SALMON
INCLUDING A LARGE WOULD
SETTLEMENT IN AND FOOD WEBS.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON FOR
REMEDIATION IMPAIR SITES TO
OFTEN MANAGERS FOCUS ON
RESTORATION DYSFUNCTIONAL
HABITAT IN PLACE A PASSENGER
WERE PARTIAL SOLUTION SUCH AS
ROAD CULVERT OR EVEN ARTS
CULVERTS ARE YOU ARE
CONSIDERED. THESE PROJECTS
ALMOST ALWAYS INVALUABLE IN
THAT INEVITABLY FAIL TO SOME
EXTENT BECAUSE THEY IMPEDE
NATURAL GM GEOMORPHIC AN
ECOLOGICAL PROCESSES
IMPLEMENTING BRIDGES SIMPLE
SPENDS BERRIER SITES IS
ABSOLUTELY THE BEST. PATH
FORWARD. I'D LIKE TO END MY
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS WITH HOW
IT BEGAN THE SIMPLE FACT IS
THIS WE PROJECTED THAT FORTY
FIVE AND 75% OVER NATIVE
SOMEONE AS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
EXTIRPATED THE NEXT FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED YEARS RESPECTIVELY. IF
PRESENT TRENDS CONTINUE AND THE
FISH BIRDS ARE MAJOR REASON FOR
OBSERVE DECLINE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. BUT AS THE LAST PORTENT-
THE LAST PART OF THIS RESULT
FROM SOS REPORT THAT IS KEY
QUOTE IF PRESENT TRENDS
CONTINUE TO BE CLEAR
EXHORTATION EXTINCTION OF
SOMEONE THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
NOT A SELF FULFILLING PROPHECY.
AND THAT THIS COMMUTING
CALTRANS OF ENORMOUS AN AMAZING
OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO
RESPONSIBILITY INFERNO THEM
YOUR JOB IS EASY PROVIDE ACCESS
TO STORE CALL HABITATS IN THE
FISH WILL RETURN. THIS WORK
HOWEVER CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER
TIMES QUICKLY RUNNING OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH I
JUST IF YOU QUESTIONS SO. TALK
TO US ABOUT THE CHALLENGES SO-
KNOW THAT CALTRANS HAS. BEEN
WORKING ON MAKING PROGRESS
THERE'S A LOT OUT THERE IN IN
CANDIDLY RIGHT THIS IS
HISTORICAL PROBLEM THIS IS BEEN
HAPPENING ACROSS THE
GENERATIONS. SO TELL ME SOME OF
THE MOST COMMON CHALLENGES THAT
YOU SEE TO BE ABLE TO GET UP TO
THOSE- HIS STORE COLD WEATHER.
AT HABITAT IF YOU DON'T MIND
THE FISH THE FISH PASSAGE IS A
BIG ONE RIGHT SO I LEARNED
ACTUALLY FROM A DEAR FRIEND.
TWENTY YEARS AGO TOM WHY SLOW
ABOUT FISH PASSES SUCCESS
STORIES IN THE NORTH COAST- AND
I HAVE THE VIDEOS AND WE TALKED
ABOUT IT EXTENSIVELY THE
CHRISTMAS DAY FLOOD FROM THE
SIXTIES RIGHT. LOT OF ROADS
BLOOD OUT WHAT CULVERTS WHEN
AND THAT PROVIDED ENORMOUS-
PROBLEMS FOR SOME ON IT- FISH
PASSAGE IS A HUGE DEAL THE
IMPORTANT THING THAT I WANTED
TO CONVEY. IS THE STATE OF THE
HABITAT IN MANY CASES ABOVE
THOSE BARRIERS IS IN EXCELLENT
CONDITION SO RATHER THAN
SPENDING MILLIONSAND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OF RESTORING KIND OF
DYSFUNCTIONAL HABITAT. IT
REALLY HAS A VERY SORDID.
HISTORY RIGHT IT IS TO IF THEY
CAN SUPPORT FISH IT'S MUCH
EASIER I HINK TO RESTORE.
ACCESS TO HABITATS THAT ALREADY
EXIST. AND THAT HELPS AT ALL
YEAH IN A ARE YOU DO YOU HAVE A
LENS ON MORE OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS IN THE
NORTH COAST IN PARTICULAR
WHERE- IN IT IS WHEN I GET
WHERE. YOUR EYES ARE ON THIS IS
THAT. MENDOCINO HUMBLE DOWN
NORTH. NOT SO MUCH SONOMA
COUNTY HI CAN YOU GENERALLY
TALK ABOUT THAT. BECAUSE A IS
SPECIALLY ON THE NORTH COAST IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT MENDOCINO IN-
IN HUMBLE IN DOWN OR- THAT A
LOT OF FOLKS. PRISTINE HABITAT
PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD YEAH
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY YOU HIT
THE MAIN POINTS RIGHT THERE
MOST OF MY RESEARCH IS FOCUSED
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
SOMEONE TO SUPPORT OLD. COVERED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT THERE
ARE A FEW FOR YOU KNOW IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMPARATIVELY SO. MENDOCINO
HUMBOLDT THOSE. ARE HUGE AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE FEW PEOPLE. THE
HABITAT AGAIN IS RELATIVELY
PRISTINE THERE ARE ISSUES OF
COURSE WITH WATER TROLLS AND
WHATNOT- ILLEGAL DIVERSIONS BUT
THE KEY IS THE HABITAT IS THERE
AND IS VERY GOOD CONDITION. NOT
SEEN SOME OF THAT HABITAT I'VE
BEEN OUT THERE ON ON TOWARDS
WITH FOLKS AND CAL TROUT WITH
UC DAVIS AND OTHERS SO. YEAH IN
A CAN YOU ARE ALSO TALK ABOUT
HOW CLIMATE CHANGE AS
EXASPERATED THIS PROBLEM- AND-
OBVIOUSLY WERE. SOME OF THE
PREVIOUS REPORTS WE'VE HEARD IN
COMMITTEES SPECIALLY. ON THE
SACRAMENTO. BUT THAT IS ONE OF
THE MOST THREATENED RIVERS
RIGHT ESPECIALLY WITH
TEMPERATURES BUT- CAN YOU JUST
TALK ABOUT HOW CLIMATE CHANGE
HAS EXASPERATED ISSUE. SO TO IT
THERE ARE MANY FACTS RELATED TO
SOME ON AS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
THE BIG ONE OF COURSE IS-
GENERAL PROJECTIONS IS AN
INCREASE IN WATER TEMPERATURE
THAT ROAD ALREADY SEEING AND
PERCENT MORE PRECIPITATION
FALLING AS RAIN LOSSES NOW AND
HAVING THAT PERIOD- FROM THE
SPRING TO THE FALL THAT THAT
BASEBALL PERIOD REALLY
EXPANDING RIGHT. THAT'S AT OVER
SUMMER PERIOD AND SO OPENING UP
PASSAGE TO THESE PRISTINE
HEADWATERS IN MANY CASES AND
SPRINGS ALLOWS FISH TO OVER
SUMMER IN COLD WATER- THERE'S
AN ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT
RECENTLY ABOUT A FISH CALLED
THE SAWFISH. IN THE IN THE
GREAT BARRIER REEF AND
SCIENTISTS HAVE SEEN HOW IT IS
BEEN ABLE TO MIGRATE TO
DIFFERENT WATERS. TO
ESSENTIALLY DEAL WITH THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REALLY INTERESTING- SOME MONADS
FOR THEIR- INLAND PART OF THEIR
OR THEIR RESIDENT PART OF YOUR
LIFE HISTORY DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THEY REALLY CAN'T
GO ANYWHERE RIGHT THERE IN
STREAMS- AND SO OPENING THAT
HABITAT UP THAT HAS BEEN CLOSED
OFF FOR. IN SOME CASES SIXTY TO
SEVENTY YEARS WOULD BE VERY
GOOD FOR THE FAST BECAUSE IT BE
ABLE ACCESS THAT COLD WATER
DURING SUMMER AND THAT'S WHEN
THEY NEED IT. SOMEONE IS ARE
THE MOST. INSENSITIVE SPECIES
TO WARM WATER RIGHT FROM FOR
NATIVE FISHES IN CALIFORNIA-
AND SO THEY REALLY NEED THAT
COLD WATER IN THE CONCERN IS.
THAT THEY IN SOME CASES ALREADY
SEEING THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THAT THEY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO
OPENING UP FISH PASSAGE
BARRIERS TO THOSE HABITATS WILL
ALLOW THEM. TO REALLY DO WELL
DURING SUMMER PERIOD. IN YOUR-
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
SPECIFIC NUMBER OR MORE OF THAT.
KIND OF A ROUGH ESTIMATE- ARE
WE LOOKING AT. AGAIN ROUGH
ESTIMATE. HALF OF STREAMS FOR
IT WITH THEIR I. IN THE NORTH
COAST. AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAVE SOME TYPE THE BARRIERS
BASED OFF OF. HISTORICAL
HIGHWAY PROJECTS WHAT ARE WE
LOOKING AS FAR AS PERCENTAGE
THAT MAY BE OUT THERE. YEAH I
I'M NOT SURE I COULD TELL USE
IN AN EXACT PERCENTAGE TO BE
HONEST ON ROADS IN CULVERTS AND
KIND OF HOW MUCH HABITAT IS CUT
OFF BUT I WOULD CERTAINLY SAY.
HUNDREDS IF NOT A THOUSAND
MILES OF FISH HABITAT- AND
AGAIN. IT I WANT TO REFLECT
BACK ON THE CLIMATE CHANGE
QUESTION IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT-
COLD WATER BUT IT'S ALSO
PROVIDING THE FISH WITH WHAT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR LIFE CYCLE
FOR THEIR LIFE HISTORY. GETTING
TO THE HABITATS WERE
HISTORICALLY THEY SPAWNED IN A
REAR DOES ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT
OF THAT. I THINK THAT WE'RE
LOOKING IT OVER A AND I KNOW
CALTRANS WILL GO INTO THIS BUT
I THINK I TOTAL INVENTORY OF
APPROXIMATELY SIX THOUSAND
ACROSS THE STATE. FIVE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETED OVER THE LAST MANY
YEARS- BUT REALLY. THERE'S SOME
KEY PROJECTS THAT COULD BE
ADVANCED AT THAT WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE IMPACT OF
THE SPECIES- WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN. DR ANY
OTHER ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
BE A TO MENTION BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO SOMETHING I'VE JUST SAID
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
KIND OF THE PRIORITIZATION AND
THE IN THE BROADER TIMELINES ON
THIS AND HOW IT'S BEEN GOING- I
KNOW THAT. I APPRECIATE
CALTRANS WORK- AND I KNOW THEY
ARE VERY BUSY KEEPING THE ROADS
INTACT RIGHT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND SO THEY HAVE OTHER
THINGS BUT- THE BIG THING HERE
IS. IF WE'RE GONNA DO THIS IT
HAS TO HAPPEN SOON BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF TIME LEFT
RIGHT AND SO IF FOR SITTING
AROUND. AND NOT GETTING IT DONE
THAT COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE FOR SO ON ITS IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
HAVE A HANG WITH US RIGHT THERE
OR YOU SHEET THAT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO. A
MARK LANCASTER HE'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE FIVE
COUNTY SEMINAL AID.
CONSERVATION PROGRAM. IN WHAT
MARK IS THAT IS PRETTY COOL-
HE'S WORKED WITH FIVE RURAL-
ECONOMICALLY CHALLENGED
COUNTIES. TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT REALLY A-
BIOLOGICALLY IMPORTANT.
PROJECTS BASED OFF OF- FISH
PASSAGE. AND TAKING DOWN
HISTORICAL IMPEDIMENTS. BY ANY
IS BEEN ABLE TO DO WHAT. AT A
BARGAIN BASEMENT PRICE IF YOU
WILL- WHICH IS PRETTY- JUST.
REALLY IMPRESSIVE MARK ALSO-
WORKED ON IN THE REGIONAL SB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. RELATED TO FISH PASSAGE
IN CALTRANS. AND I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MISTER LANCASTER SIR
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO BE A
TALK ABOUT. CHALLENGES YOU SEE
HOW YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU HAVE. IN
SOME POTENTIAL OPTIONS. AT THAT
COULD BE DEPLOYED- WITHIN THE
STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. FOR SHORE
SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU THANKS
VERY WORK. A GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU MY POWER POINT IS A
WHIRLWIND IT'S BASICALLY A
CELEBRATION OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE SINCE SB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN PASSED. YOU SHOULD
JUST BE ABLE TO HIT. START FROM
FOR FROM BEGINNING. AND IT'S
ALSO TRYING TO BE FIVE MINUTES
AND THIRTY SECONDS LONG SO GOOD
MAN. SO GO BACK TO THE POWER
POINT ITSELF INTO UP ABOVE IT
SHOULD SAY START. LYTRO. WE CAN
EITHER WING IT OR WE CAN MAKE
IT WORK ONE OR THE OTHER. SO
BASICALLY IF I CAN ON THE FIVE
COUNTIES. REPRESENTS THE
NORTHWEST CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
IN WHICH HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND MILES OF ROADS.
THE FIGHT CAN IS PROGRAM
STARTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN WITH A LISTING OF THE CO
WHO IS A FEDERAL AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES ARE THREATENED SPECIES.
AND THE ISSUE FOR THE COUNTIES
WAS REALLY SIMPLE THE NORTHERN
SPOTTED ALLAH BECAUSE A LOT OF
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC DISRUPTION.
SO THE COUNTIES DIDN'T WANT TO
FACE THE PROBLEMS A NOT
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE WITH
SOMEONE AND SO THE FIRST THING
THEY DID. IS THEY ASSEMBLED OUR
PROGRAM THE- THE AGREED TO
ELIMINATE POLITICAL BOUNDARIES
FOR DECISION MAKING AROUND
SALMON CONSERVATION AND THEY
FOCUSED ON WATERSHED
BOUNDARIES- THE PROGRAM IS
PARALLEL TO CALTRANS IF YOU
WILL IT'S COUNTY ROADS IT'S
FOUR THOUSAND MILES OF ROADS.
THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS
COMPLETE THEM MIGRATION BERRIER
INVENTORY WE IDENTIFIED THREE
HUNDRED BARRIERS ON COUNTY ROAD
SYSTEMS AS WELL AS A
SIGNIFICANT SETTLEMENT SOURCE
PROGRAM. IN THE KILLINGS BEGIN
IMPLEMENTING- PROJECTS AS SOON
AS THEY DID THE THREE HUNDRED
BARRIERS THE- THE REALIZE IT
WAS BIGGER THAN THEY CAN TACKLE
SO THEY CREATED A BIOLOGICAL
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS. TO
FOCUS WHICH PROJECT WOULD BE
DONE FIRST. ZOOMING VERY
QUICKLY FORWARD TO TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
BEARS HAVE BEEN REMOVED AT
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS OR
ABOUT. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MILE OF
RESTORED HABITAT WHICH IS VERY
CHEAP. BUT THE PROGRAM ALSO
SERVES AS A PEARL TO CALTRANS
AND SO ON. BY THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND. IT WAS APPARENT TO ME
THAT CALTRANS WAS MOVING VERY
VERY SLOWLY. IN FACT I'D SAY
NOT MOVING AT ALL. AROUND
MIGRATION BARRIER REMOVAL SO.
BY TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE WE
BASICALLY HAD HEARD A SERIES OF
ARGUMENTS BY CALTRANS AS TO WHY
THEY COULD NOT MOVE FORWARD IN
THOSE VERY VERY BRIEFLY WERE.
THE EACH PROJECT HAD TO BE
INDIVIDUALLY DESIGNED THAT THE
DESIGN PROCESS WAS VERY SLOW
AND VERY CUMBERSOME- AND THAT-
THERE JUST WASN'T ENOUGH
SUFFICIENT FUNDING NINE AND
AGAIN THE SLIDES ARE MORE OF A
CELEBRATION OF THE PROJECT AS I
GO FORWARD BUT- THAT THAT
SIMPLY IS NOT. CORRECT THE FIVE
COUNTIES HAVE USE OFF THE SHELF
STRUCTURAL DESIGNS TO IMPLEMENT
SEVENTY THREE PROJECTS. THOSE
PROJECTS REPRESENT NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY YEARS OF PASSAGE
SINCE- NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
WHEN THE FIRST ONE IS INSTALLED
TWENTY ONE YEARS AGO. THE LAST
ONE STALLED LAST YEAR. THESE
ARE ALL PRODUCTS A RAPIDLY
AVAILABLE THROUGH
MANUFACTURERS- THEY'RE ALL
SPANS FROM TWENTY FOUR TO A
HUNDRED FORT. THE PRIMARY
DELAYS I SEE WITH CALTRANS OR-
RELATED AROUND THEIR IABILITY
TO PUSH PROJECTS THROUGH. AND
THAT DOESN'T NEED TO BE THE
CASE. THE HOUSE OF THE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE EXACT SAME
ARGUMENTS THAT THEY HAD SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND. THEY HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL ADVISORY COMMITTEES
PRESENT WE HAVE THOSE SAME
COMMITTEES THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BEING DISCUSSED TODAY IN THOSE
COMMITTEES ARE NUANCES. OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE DISCUSSED IN
THE PAST THEY'RE NOT
SIGNIFICANT- NEW AREAS OF
DEVELOPMENT AND I AND SO I'M
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED AS TO.
CONVINCING CALTRANS TO MOVE
FORWARD IN A MUCH RAPID MUCH
MORE RAPID PROCESS ON. 90% OF
THE FIVE COUNTIES PROGRAM
PROJECTS ARE FULL STREAM
SIMULATION 10% OR ADAPTATIONS I
BELIEVE THAT- OF THE FORTY
THREE PROJECTS CALTRANS IS DONE
SINCE THE- IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN SIX HAVE BEEN
FULL STREAM SIMULATION. I GUESS
THE THING THAT I WOULD
RECOMMEND IS TO RECOGNIZE THIS
IS NOT THAT DIFFICULT TO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE. FROM THESE
STRUCTURES SPAN- SMALL STREAMS
TO MID SIZE STREAMS ALL OF
WHICH FALL WITHIN RELATIVELY
EASY ENGINEERING. DESIGNS. AND
IRONICALLY. WHEN AND I'M SORRY
WE PASSED THE SLIDE THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE BUT- I
WOULD LIKE TO USE A COUPLE OF
CASE STUDIES RELATIVE TO OUR
PROGRAM AND TO CALTRANS AND
THAT IS- RYAN CREEK IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. WE REMOVE THE
DOWNSTREAM MIGRATION BARRIER
WHICH WITH A FULL STREAM
SIMULATIONS STRUCTURE. AND THEN
THE HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE LIES
JUST UPSTREAM OF THAT BARRIER
WHICH WAS A PARTIAL BERRIER. AN
UPSTREAM OF THAT WAS A PRIVATE
ROOM BERRIER WE EMOVE THAT ONE
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN.
THE CALTRANS PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WAS ABLE
TO MODIFY THE HIGHWAY ONE A ONE
STRUCTURE WITH NOT A FULL
STREAM SIMULATION BUT RATHER.
TO CULVERTS THAT WERE JACKSON
BOARD UNDERNEATH THE HIGHWAY SO.
THE THEY WERE NOT EVEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE FULL STREAM SIMULATION
IN THE SAME WATERSHED UPSTREAM
AND DOWNSTREAM THE PRIVATE AND
THE COUNTY WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
THAT. BUT I RECOGNIZE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF HIGHWAY ONE A
ONE MAKES THAT MORE DIFFICULT.
BUT I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
GOOD FOR THE COMMITTEE. AND FOR
CALTRANS TO TAKE A MORE.
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH AND
EXAMINE HOW WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH SEVENTY THREE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER COST FOR
THE SAME SIZE PREMIUMS IF YOU
WILL AS WELL CALTRANS FACES FOR
MOST OF THESE AND I WOULD SAY
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE. THE
DECLINE THE CHANGING IN
CLIMATIC VARIATION IN AND ONE
OF THINGS THAT WE'RE SEEING
MORE SUBSTANTIALLY. IS THE
EFFECTS OF WILDFIRE AFFECTS ON
THESE WATERSHEDS THE AMOUNT OF
HABITAT AVAILABLE IS DECLINING
EVEN AS WE RESTORE BECAUSE
WE'RE LOSING SO MUCH OF THAT
HABITAT. PARTICULARLY IN THE-
IN THE INTERIOR IS AND THAT IS
FIVE MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS.
I WILL STOP THERE. YEAH IN IF
YOU DON'T MIND TALKING ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THAT LOOK- YES A
652% OF LAKE COUNTY'S LAND
MASSES BURN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN RIGHT MASSIVE OVER- IN
THE CHICO PARADISE BUTTE COUNTY
AREA. CINEMA COUNTY. YOU CAN'T
KEEP UP RIGHT AGNESE BARRIERS
EMPLOYED- WITH THE MASS OF THE
SIZES COMPANIES FIRES TO TALK
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT YOU
JUST START TOUCHING ON. THE
PROJECTED BURN RATE FOR THE
KLAMATH TRINITY AT THIS POINT
IS THE ENTIRE- WATER SHOULD BE
BURNED WITHIN A THIRTY YEAR
PERIOD AND THESE ARE NOT ON THE
LOW INTENSITY FIRES THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEN IN THE PAST. THESE
TEND TO BE VERY HIGH INTENSITY
AND SO THE- THE ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF HABITAT THAT'S BEING
LOST THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE FUTURE FOR THE
SPECIES IS TO MOVE NOW. WE
LITERALLY CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PEOPLE THAT
SIT ON THE VARIOUS ADVISORY
COMMITTEES TO CALTRANS OR- OR
THE THIRTY ENGINEER DESIGNS TO
COME UP WITH STANDARDIZED
DESIGNS THAT ALREADY EXIST. THE
ISSUE HERE IS. THAT THE
DECLINING HABITATS ARE THE
PRIMARY. DRIVER OR SHOULD BE
THE PRIMARY DRIVER NOW IN SB
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN AND YOU'LL
HEAR CALTRANS SAY THIS
REPETITIVELY. THEY CAN'T DO
FISH PASSAGE IN LOSS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION RELATED OF FACT
WELL IN FACT THE- THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON MADE THE SAME
ARGUMENT IN THE SUPREME COURT
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SAID%
NO RELATIVE TO AT LEAST INDIAN
TRIBE. TREATY TREATY OBLIGATION
AREAS WHICH WOULD INCLUDE THE
KLAMATH TRINITY. BUT I THINK
THAT THE ISSUES AROUND YES THEY
ARE NOT THAT DISSIMILAR TO THE
ISSUES AROUND THE TRIBAL
CONCERNS. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
REFOCUSING CALTRANS TO MOVIES
PROJECTS FORWARD MUCH FASTER
AND. I WILL JUST SAY I DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS AN
INHERENT. FOSSILS THERE THAT
NEEDS TO BE MODIFIED STE SHAKEN
UP IF YOU WILL BECAUSE TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE. MANY OF THE SO
WE YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT MANY
OF THESE. RURAL COUNTIES
RESOURCES ARE LIMITED RIGHT AND-
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS. THE VERY AND
I'M GLAD YOU ASKED THAT. THESE
GUYS ARE PROBABLY THE POOREST
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA AND YET
THEY HAVE COMPLETED THE MOST
BARRIER PROJECTS AND IN THE
STATE AND POSSIBLY IN THE
COUNTRY. THEY'VE DONE IT
BECAUSE THEY'VE USED LITERALLY
OFF THE SHELF DESIGNS FROM
MANUFACTURERS FOR THE BULK OF
THEM THE VIEWS THE WIDE VARIETY
OF TECHNIQUES THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF TECHNIQUES AND IN
DESIGNS FOR THESE THINGS IS NOT
THAT DIFFICULT ONCE YOU'VE DONE
THE MODELING FOR THE FLOWS AND
SCOUR ANALYSIS THE FOOTINGS.
THEN IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
FINDING FOR MANY OF THESE
CROSSINGS NOT ALL FOR MANY THIS
IS FINDING THE RIGHT PRODUCT TO
BE ABLE TO CONVEY EITHER FULL
PASSAGE WERE IN THE CASES WHERE
YOU CAN'T. AND I DO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE THAT WE
NEED TO OPEN THE CALTRANS AND
OTHERS HAVE USE THE ARGUMENT.
THE FULL SPAN FULL CONVEYANCE
STRUCTURES. ARE THE ONLY WAY TO
GO AND SO THE DELAYS HAVE BEEN
IN TRYING TO GET THAT DONE AND
THAT HAS ACTUALLY CUT OFF
HABITAT FOR MORE THANTWO
DECADES IN MY OPINION. THAT
SHOULD BE OPENED UP AT LEAST
WITH A OF SMALLER STRUCTURES
WERE NECESSARY WE'RE PLAYING
TRIAGE. BUT THE COUNTIES OF
USES OFF THE SHELF DESIGNS THEY
HAVE USED TO ARM IN REPETITIVE
USE OF THE SAME TYPES OF DESIGN
SO THEY HAVE FOR THE CONSISTENT
ANALYSIS IN THIS ASSESSMENT OF
THE- EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO DO THE
WORK. THE TECHNIQUES THE TIME
LINES AND ALL OF THAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS FRANK HAS TO
RETURN IT OF FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS WERE PANEL HERE AFTER
WE HEAR FROM NO OPPENHEIM. AS
YOU ALL OF HER DISEASE I COULD
DIRECTOR OF THE PACIFIC COAST.
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION LOOK. AT SALMON
FISHERMEN. ARE IMPACTED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE LOSS OF
SALMON HABITAT. AND HE'S GOING
TO BE TALKING ABOUT RESOLVING
FISH PASSAGE CHALLENGES N
PARTICULAR. IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON IN THEIR DESIRE. TO
BE ABLE TO GET PROJECTS MOVED
ON THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
ALTERNATE OVER TO MR UP IN A.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
IT REMAINS GOOD TO BE WITH YOU
THIS MORNING- THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS ISSUE SALMON.
HAVE THRIVED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
MILLENNIA. THEY USED BOTH FRESH
AND SALT WATER HABITATS I THEIR
DIVERSE LIFE HISTORY STRATEGIES
HAVE ENABLED THEM TO SURVIVE
THE EVER CHANGING AND SOMETIMES
VIOLENT. NATURE OF OUR REGION
OFTEN PRONE TO EARTHQUAKES
DROUGHT MUD SLIDES WILDFIRES
FLOODS EVEN VOLCANIC ERUPTIONS.
BUT THESE FISH DON'T STAND A
CHANCE AGAINST THE RAVENOUS
THIRST OF CORPORATE
AGRIBUSINESS THE DAMMING OF
NEARLY EVERY RIVER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND AT ISSUE
TODAY THE CONSTRUCTION OF
IMPASSABLE ROADS OR POORLY
ENGINEERED CULVERTS. THESE
MICHAEL FISHER BORN IN
FRESHWATER STREAMS ACROSS THE
WEST AFTER VARYING AMOUNTS OF
TIME IN FRESH WATER THEY
MIGRATE DOWNSTREAM HUNDREDS OF
MILES TO THE OCEAN WHERE THEY
RANGE FOR THOUSANDS OF MILES
FEEDING AND GROWING FOR SEVERAL
YEARS. BEFORE FIGHTING THEIR
WAY BACK UPSTREAM TO THE SAME
WATERS WHERE THEY WERE BORN
DESPONDENT AND- IF OUR MEMBERS
ARE LUCKY ENOUGH. SOME OF THEM
END UP ON THE HOOKS AND ON THE
BACK DECK OF OUR FISHING BOATS-
AND OF COURSE ALONG THE WAY
THESE FISHER VITAL PRAY FOR
COUNTLESS SPECIES. OF COURSE
FOR HUMANS RECREATIONAL
COMMERCIAL. FISHERS CULVERTS
THE BLOCK STREAMS AND PREVENTS
THEM FROM REACHING THE
FRESHWATER HABITAT INTER OF THE
CYCLE AT EVERY TURN. ARTS BLOCK
MATURE SALMON TRAVELING
UPSTREAM FROM FRESHWATER
HABITAT WHERE THEY COULD SPAWN.
AND THESE FISH AS THEY SEARCH
FOR IDEAL REARING HABITAT N
FRESHWATER STREAMS- ONCE THEY
EVENTUALLY MIGRATE DOWNSTREAM
TO THE OCEAN MUST BE ABLE TO
HAVE PASSAGE. THE AMOUNT OF
HABITAT THAT THESE BARRIERS
ELIMINATE IS HUGE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HUNDREDS OF STREAM MILES
AS MENTIONED EARLIER AND
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF SPAWNING
IN REARING HABITAT. UNLESS
HABITAT WERE THE FISH CAN
REPRODUCE MEANS FOR YOUR FISH
OR ALL. RESULTING IN HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CUMULATIVE IMPACTS TO OUR
MEMBERS AND THE COURTS HAVE
RECOGNIZED THESE IMPACTS- AND
THEY'VE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
LONGER WE WAIT THE GREATER THE
IMPACTS BOTH TO COMMUNITIES AND
TO THE AGENCIES THAT FAILED TO
TAKE REMEDIAL ACTION. FROM
CALTRANS PERSPECTIVE THE LONGER
THEY WAIT THE BIGGER THE HIT
COULD BE. THE DISTRICT COURT IN
A CASE ASSERTING THAT
WASHINGTON STATE'S POOR COVER
DESIGNS AND TRACK RECORD OF
PASSAGE NEGLECT AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- FOUND THAT SALMON
PRODUCTION A QUOTE I'M QUOTING
HERE IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
AMOUNT AND QUALITY OF HABITAT
AVAILABLE LOSS AND DEGRADATION
OF HABITAT HAVE GREATLY REDUCED
SALMON PRODUCTION. IN THAT CASE
AREA. THAT CASES WAS DISCUSSED
EARLIER MADE IT ALL THE WAY THE
SUPREME COURT. IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON IS NOW ON THE HOOK
FOR HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- THAT THEY MUST
ADDRESS- AND THEY'RE SCRAMBLING
WE CAN GET OUT AHEAD OF THIS
PROBLEM. AND IT WAS A TRIBAL
TRUST ISSUE BUT THIS IS A
PUBLIC TRUST STATE AND THE
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCE OF ACCESS
THE SALMON STOCKS AND SENATE
FISHERIES IS KEY IN CALIFORNIA
THE FAILURE TO MAINTAIN
CULVERTS TO PROVIDE PASSAGE. IS
THAT VIOLATION AND PREVENTS OUR
INDUSTRY FROM THRIVING
INCREASING AVAILABLE SPAWNING
HABITAT BY REMOVING CULVERTS
THAT BLOCKS FISH ON THE OTHER
HAND CAN LEAD TO RAPID
INCREASES IN SEVEN POPULATIONS
AS WE'VE HEARD. AND AS THE
DISTRICT COURT IN WASHINGTON
THE US FOUND REMOVING BARRIER
CULVERTS QUOTE PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE BENEFIT IN TERMS OF
SALMON PRODUCTION A SALMON
RAPIDLY RECOLONIZE. THE
UPSTREAM AREA AND RETURN
RETURNING ADULT SPAHN THEIR.
CULVERTS ARE NOT THE ONLY
CHALLENGES SALMON POPULATIONS
FACE. BUT THE DISTRICT COURT
FINDING THAT THEIR MAJOR PART
OF THE PROBLEM IS KEY HERE. IN
THIS AREA WHERE THEY HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT NORTH COAST RIVERS
IN PARTICULAR THE BENEFITS TO
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HAD MAJOR SHUTDOWNS IN THE PAST
LOSS OF MULTIPLE SEASONS IN A
ROW LOSSES OF PARTIAL AREAS
INCLUDING THE KLAMATH
MANAGEMENT'S OWN THAT'S GOING
TO BE KEY. THE DISTRICT COURT
CORRECTLY FOUND IN THAT CASE
THAT REPLACING THE STATE'S
BETTER CULVERTS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFITS SALMON
AND WE BELIEVE THAT. PUBLIC
TRUST BENEFIT WOULD SIMILARLY
BE REALIZED HERE I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE CALTRANS ACHIEVING THE
GOAL OF ADDRESSING ALL OF ITS
PRIORITY PROJECTS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AS THE GENTLEMAN TO MY
RIGHT AND LEFT. HAVE POINTED
OUT THERE'S NO BETTER TIME THAN
RIGHT NOW TO GET THIS DONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ROBIN I MISS
HAVING HIM TALK ABOUT- STOCK
RIGHT- ESPECIALLY. A IS WHAT
THE DOCTOR WAS SAYING EARLIER-
IN THE NEED AND HOW THAT
RELATES. TO THE HEALTH OF THE
INDUSTRY FOR. CALIFORNIANS CAN
YOU GO THROUGH THEIR OF ABIT
AND BECAUSE SEVEN INDUSTRIES
BEEN SUFFERING. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS A CONTRIBUTOR. BROADLY
SPEAKING THE SALMON FISHING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA IS ON
ITS KNEES. WE HAVE ABOUT. 5%
THE STORE NUMBERS OF
PARTICIPANTS- OVER THE PAST
FORTY YEARS NOW HARVESTING THIS
RESOURCE THE IMPACT OF SMALL
STREAMS THE BENEFICIAL IMPACTS
OF HEALTHY SMALL STREAMS CAN'T
BE OVERSTATED- THE PROBLEM IS
WHAT WE DO NOT HAVE ROBUST
MONITORING PROGRAMS IN PLACE IN
ORDER TO QUANTITATIVELY
EVALUATE THESE IMPACTS BUT WE
KNOW THEY'RE REAL WE KNOW THAT
IN MANY PARTS OF THE COAST- IT
IS. ON MARK'S NON HATCHERY FISH
THAT WE KNOW ARE COMING FROM.
STREAMS AND RIVERS- ON THE LAW
ON LONG THE NORTH COAST
HUMBOLDT COUNTY DOWN OR COUNTY
ETCETERA- AND WE KNOW THAT
BARRIERS TO PASSAGE COMING FROM
THE SMALLER KINDS OF
IMPEDIMENTS CALLED CULVERTS-
FED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ETCETERA ARE KEY CONTRIBUTORS
THERE WE KNOW THAT RESOLVING
THESE ISSUES IS GOING TO
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BENEFIT AND CULTURAL BENEFIT-
TO OUR MEMBERS UP ON THE NORTH
COAST. DRUM AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH A GREAT JOB TODAY AND-
BOTH PANELS WERE NOT GOOD. PUT
IT UP FOR CLOSING COMMENTS FROM
EACH OF OUR PANELISTS WILL
START WITH THE DOCTOR TO BE IN
A PROVIDE IS CLOSING COMMENTS
WITHIN GONNA GO TO MISTER
LANCASTER'S DROP IN TIME. WE
WILL THEN TAKE A QUICK FIVE
MINUTE BREAK- AND BRING A
CALTRANS UP TO BE A YOU ARE
CLOSING PANEL WE'RE GONNA TURN
OVER REDUCTION THE STARTED FROM
UC DAVIS YES THANK YOU- I WILL
KEEP IT A QUICK I WANTED TO
JUST COMMENT ON SOMETHING THAT-
KNOWN MENTIONED- DID THAT I
OFTEN ACTUALLY REFLECT ON AS
WELL AND THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. SALMON SOMEONE IS IN
GENERAL HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
FIFTY MILLION YEARS THEY HAVE
BEEN THROUGH EVERYTHING THEY
HAVE BEEN THROUGH VOLCANIC
ERUPTIONS THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH
EARTH CREEK QUAKES
DISCONNECTIONS FROM HABITAT
GLACIERS I MEAN YOU NAME IT.
AND THEY'VE ALWAYS PERSISTED.
IN THE WORLD THE REASON WHY
THEY COULD DO THAT IS BECAUSE
THEY ALWAYS HAVE THE. AB
ATTACHED TO SUPPORT THEM RIGHT
AND ONE OF THE MAIN ISSUES
RIGHT NOW NOT JUST CALTRANS IS
ITS LARGE BARRIERS AS WELL-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THEY
CANNOT ACCESS THE REALLY GOOD
HABITAT THEY CANNOT COMPLETE
THEIR LIFE CYCLE THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT COLD WATER DURING
OVER SUFFERING- AND SO HE
TALKED ON THAT AND I JUST KIND
OF WANTED TO REITERATE I THINK
FROM A HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE.
WE KNOW AND THE THESE ANIMALS
ARE INCREDIBLY GOOD COLONIZERS
POPULATIONS OF BLANKED OUT
POPULATIONS COME BACK THEY
CAN'T DO THAT IF. THEY ARE
GENETICALLY MARGINALIZED AND IF
THEY THEIR HABITAT IS A
MARGINALIZED RIGHT WHICH IS
WHAT WE SEE PARTICULARLY IN THE
VALLEY RIGHT NOW- AND SO
KEEPING THAT IN MIND I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
SHOWS YOU AGAIN IT'S NOT TO
SELL FOR FILLING PROP SEE IF
THE HABIT. HABITAT IS THERE TO
SUPPORT THEM. THEY CAN MAKE A
COMEBACK. THROUGH THE- FAST AND
WHAT YOU JUST SAID IN REGARDS
TO FIFTY MILLION YEARS AND-
THROUGH THICK AND THIN AND AS
MUCH WAS THROWN ADAM- ALWAYS
GETTING BACK WITH THE OC COUNT
ON. WHOSE HEADWATERS RIGHT
WHERE THOSE HISTORICAL WIRES
WERE AND I'M REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU SAYING THAT I'M GLAD YOU
ADDED THAT IN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. TERMS
LANCASTER. CLOSING COMMENTS
PLEASE. A YES IN CLOSING WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO IS TO OFFER UP
MY STAFF OF THREE TO WORK WITH
CALTRANS BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
GOING TO WIN IF WE CAN MOVE
THINGS MUCH FASTER IN THAT THE-
SOME OF THE ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT. IF YOU WILL OF THE
COUNTIES IN THE PARTNERS IN THE
FIVE C. MIGHT NOT HURT TO A- TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
CALTRANS IN MOVING THEIR
PROJECTS FORWARD BECAUSE- WE
BOTH NEED TO KEEP. THE COSTS
DOWN BUT CERTAINLY THE- THE
CALTRANS BUDGET. HOUSE THE
ABILITY TO FIND ROOM FOR.
INCREASED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE PROJECTS AND THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE DOING WAY MORE
THAN DROST. RESTORING SOMEONE
IT'S THERE AS WE SEE THESE
WATERSHED BEING DEVASTATED BY
FLOODS BY FIRES. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY IMPROVING STORM WATER
THEY'RE IMPROVING CAPACITY
SAFETY. WE'VE SEEN A- IN OUR
PROJECT AND NUMBER WILDLIFE
SPECIES THAT NOW UTILIZED THE
CROSSING SO IT'S A IT'S A MUCH
MORE COLLABORATIVE MUCH MORE.
BENEFICIAL THAN JOSH THE CELL
MONADS BUT- TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN HELP PUSH THIS FURTHER
FASTER. SO WE DON'T NEED
AMENDMENTS THIS BE A FIFTY
SEVEN WE STAND READY TO HELP.
THANKS SO MUCH I THANK YASSER
GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATE. YOU
SHOWN US WHAT CAN BE DONE THANK
YOU SO. MUCH FOR IN TURN OVER
NOAH OPPENHEIM FOR CLOSING
COMES PLEASE. GEOLOGIC TIME WAS
MENTIONED IN AUSTIN. IT CAN
FEEL LIKE THE BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS OPERATES AT A GLACIAL
PACE. LET'S REVERSE THAT WHAT'S
ENSURE THAT. THE NEXT FIFTY
MILLION YEARS FRANKLY FEATURE
SALMON IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE IN THE NEXT
FIFTY OR PERHAPS EVEN THE NEXT
FIVE COULD DETERMINE THE
OUTCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER OPPENHEIMER WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THESE THREE
GENTLEMEN WHO HAVE JOINED US
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO GIVE US A
PERSPECTIVE- IN HOW TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE. BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. TIME IS SPENT UP IN
REGARDS TO NEEDING BEER TO GET
THESE FISH BARRIERS COMPLETED.
IN DEVOID RIGHT- AND WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE OF THE THREE OF
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK TO
BE A PROTECT THAT SPECIES JOIN
SURE THAT THEY THRIVE IN THE
DECADES AND IF NOT CENTURIES TO
COME. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
QUICK RECESS WE ARE THEN GOING
TO BE BRINGING UP THE TEAM FROM
CALTRANS- AND WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM JIM DAVIS HE'S A
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CALTRANS WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
MICHAEL KEEPER. HE'S THE CHIEF
PROJECT CHIEF IN THE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT DIVISION FOR
CALTRANS THERE WERE ALSO CAN
HEAR FROM ANNE BAILEY SHE IS
THE OFFICE CHIEF- WITHIN THE
STRATEGIC THIS IS THE WORLD'S
LONGEST TITLE SO HERE WE GO.
THE STRATEGIC BIOLOGICAL PLAY
NEED ADVANCED EDUCATION AND
INFORMATION DIVISION I CALTRANS
HIDING IT WATCH OUT ALL RIGHT
SO- WE'RE GONNA BE BRING IN
THOSE THREE UP AND WE'RE GOING
O ASK. REGION. WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN FIVE MINUTES THANK
YOU
. SO MY CHECK OUT FOR. BEING
HERE WERE NOT TO BE TURNED OVER
TO OUR FINAL PANEL OF THE DAY
WE'RE GONNA BE STARTING WITH
THAT MISTER JIM DAVIS IS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HE'S CAN ME-
MISTER DAVIS- IN AGAIN AS I
SAID EARLIER. HAS BEEN ENGAGE
ON THIS ISSUE AND TRULY
GRATEFUL FOR MISTER DAVIS GOOD
TO SEE YOU AND AS I ALWAYS SAY
WE MISS YOU IN DISTRICT FOUR
SO- DID AN AMAZING JOB HE'S
GONNA BE PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW
OF THEIR- FISH PASSAGE PROGRAM
THEY BEING CALTRANS IT'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IS WELLS
CURRENT STATUS ON FISH PASSAGE
EFFORTS- HE'S GONNA ALSO
DISCUSS FUNDING IN- ALSO
CURRENT CHALLENGES A CALTRANS
HAS IS WELL LOOK I THINK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS- WE KNOW
THERE'S APPROXIMATELY SIX.
THOUSAND. POTENTIAL BARRIERS
WITHIN THE ENTIRE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM A FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY KNOWN- THEIR LOCATIONS
OVER THE YEARS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
CARE OF AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE STATE- BEING THE OWNER OF-
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. IS
ALSO THE LARGEST OWNER- OF FISH
PASSAGE BARRIERS- IN THE GOLDEN
STATE WHICH IS WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY SO WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MISTER DAVIS
MISTER DAVIS WILL HAPPEN. SEVEN
TEN MINUTES BEARD GIVES THE
OVERVIEW WITHIN GONNA BE
TURNING IT OVER TO MR KEEPER
THEN OF COURSE MISS BAILEY
FORESHORES MISTER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE SIR. GOOD MORNING SAM
ACQUIRED JIM DAVIS- SHIFT EVERY
DIRECTOR OF CALTRANS AND GLAD
TO BE HERE WITH YOU TODAY.
EFFECTIVE IN TWO THOUSAND SIX A
SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
REQUIRES IN A PROJECT USING
STATE OR FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS. CONDUCTOR FISH PASSES
HAS BEEN BEFORE PROJECT DESIGN
IF THE PROJECT AFFECTS A STREAM
CROSSING ON THE STREAM OR ANNA
DRAMAS FISH OR HISTORICALLY
WERE FOUND. CALTRANS IS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT AN
ASSESSMENT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND ADDED TO
THE CALIPHATE SHOULD DATABASE.
IF ANY STRUCTURAL BARRIERS.
PASSAGE EXISTS REMEDIATION THE
PROBLEM IS REQUIRED TO BE
DESIGNED INTO THE PROJECT BY
THE IMPLEMENTING AGENCY. ROGERS
MUST BE CONSTRUCTED SO THAT
THEY DO NOT PRESENT A BEAR TO
FISH PASSAGE WHEN BEARS TO FISH
PASSAGE ARE BEING ADDRESSED
PLANS AND PROJECTS A RECORD TO
BE DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. SO STATUS TODAY OF
THE SALMON STEELHEAD BEARS ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. TO
DATE. WE HAVE PROVIDED ACCESS
LIKE DR ROBERT THE SORRY WAS
TALKING ABOUT TWO SEVEN HUNDRED
AND NINETY THREE MILES A STILL
HELD IN SALMON HABITAT FROM
REMOVAL OF SEVENTY FORTY SEVEN
BEARS SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX-
REPEAT THAT SEVEN HUNDRED
NINETY THREE MILES. EXACTLY.
WATER DOCTOR LIST SORRY TALKED
ABOUT WAS OPENING UP
OPPORTUNITIES. WE HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN CURRENT PROJECTS. IN OUR
INVENTORY THAT OUR PLAN TO OPEN
UP A HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILES
NOW THE COST OF THESE TWENTY
SEVEN BEARS IS ESTIMATED AT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. A AND I AM
LOOKING FOR EFFICIENCIES AS
PART OF SB ONE WOULD LIKE TO
SIT DOWN- WITH MISTER LANCASTER
TO SEE THERE'S OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE CAN SEE
HOW THAT THEY DID THIS FOR A
MUCH MORE. EFFICIENT WAY THAN
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO DATE
SENATOR AND YET I'LL GIVE YOU A
NEW NUMBER THERE ARE CURRENTLY
BASED ON NEW INFORMATION WE
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT KNOWN CURRENT BARRIERS ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM. ALL
OF THESE SIXTY EIGHT OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT HAVE
BEEN DETERMINED THROUGH THE SIX
FAT FISH PASSAGE ADVISER
COMMITTEES. CALTRANS
ESTABLISHED ENGAGE OUR PARTNERS
AND STAKEHOLDERS. THESE
COMMITTEES ME QUARTERLY
DETERMINE THIS IS SUITABLE
QUALITY AND QUANTITY OF HABITAT.
THESE COMMITTEES A TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TO IMPROVE
SCIENCE AND DATA ASSESSING
PRIORITIZING AND REMEDIATING
BEARS TO COORDINATION AND
PLANNING. NOW IT IS SIXTY EIGHT
BEARS NOW RATHER THAN SEVENTY
BEARS TWO OCCASIONS A WRIST
RECENTLY DROPPED FROM THE
PRIORITY LIST AS NEW SCIENCE
INSIGHT DATA BECAME AVAILABLE.
INDETERMINATE THEY WERE NOT
GOOD HABITAT OR THERE WERE
OTHER NATURAL BARRIERS. THERE
ARE CURRENTLY EIGHT THOUSAND
TWENTY EIGHT ROAD IN STREAM
CROSSINGS IDENTIFIED FOR
ASSESSMENT ON THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM IN THE RANGE OF SALMON
AND STEEL HEAD IN CALIFORNIA.
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE ASSESSMENTS HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED. OF THESE ONE
THOUSAND FIFTY SEVEN NEED MORE
DETAILED OR SECOND PASS
ASSESSMENTS DETERMINE VERY
STATUS. REQUIRES PERMISSION TO
ENTER FOR DETAILED ASSESSMENT
NEEDS FOUR HUNDRED FEET UP OR
DOWN STRING. FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHTY EIGHT LOCATIONS NEED
RECONNAISSANCE FIRST PASS
ASSESSMENT. IN JULY INITIATE A
CONTRACTOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS TO EXCEL
RIGHT THAT FIRST PASS
RECONNAISSANCE IT'S A THREE
YEAR CONTRACT FOR ONE POINT TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ALTHOUGH THE FIRST BEST REPORT
WILL BE SUBMITTED TO YOU
SHORTLY I WILL PROVIDE YOU THE
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THAT
REPORT. WE HAVE IMPROVE ACCESS
TO PROSS ME THIRTY ONE MILES OF
SALMON AND STEELHEAD HABITAT BY
COMPLETING FIVE MEDIATION
PROJECTS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. A
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN ASSESSMENTS
WERE COMPLETED OF THOSE WE%
IDENTIFIED FOURTEEN NEW
BARRIERS. EIGHTY FIVE NINE
BEARS AND SIXTY EIGHT LOCATIONS
THAT REQUIRE MORE DETAILED
SURVEYS. THE NEW FISH PASSAGE
OF ISAAC COMMITTEE BEGAN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND COVERS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WE HAVE
DEVELOPED INNOVATIVE
ENGINEERING SOLUTIONS TO
STANDARDIZE SMALL BRIDGES AND
ASSISTANT ACCELERATION AND COST
REDUCTION OF FULL SPAN
SOLUTIONS PROFESSED PASSAGE FOR
MEDIATION. THESE PRE DESIGNED
STANDARD PLANS FISH BASHERS
INCLUDE ELEVEN STANDARD DESIGNS
FOR BRIDGES TWENTY TO HUNDRED
FEET HUNDRED FIFTEEN FEET LONG.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY IN THE FINAL
DESIGN STAGES AND SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR FULL DEPLOYMENT.
NEXT YEAR. WE'VE ADDITIONAL
COORDINATION WITH APARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IN NATIONAL
MARINE FISHERIES SERVICE
CALTRANS FERNS FISH PASSAGES
YEARS AT THESE AGENCIES AND
THEY PARTICIPATE IN AN INTERNET
AGENCY FISH PASSAGE ENGINEERING
WORK GROUP. THAT MEETS MONTHLY
TO COORDINATE ON ENGINEERING
SOLUTIONS AND LESSONS LEARNED
IN SUPPORT EDUCATION AND DESIGN
SOLUTIONS. SO IF YOU FOR TO THE
SCREEN HERE'S EXAMPLES OF
TYPICAL STATE HIGHWAY FISH
BARRIERS. CONNECTS I'D IN HERE
ARE EXAMPLES OF TYPICAL SMALL
BRIDGE REMEDIATION OR THE FULL
SPAN SOLUTION THAT OUR EARLIER
SPEAKERS WERE TALKING ABOUT.
TWO OF THE FIVE CEDAR CREEK AND
THEN MENDOCINO COUNTY WAS
COMPLETED. THE NEXT IS JOE COME
MONEY CREEK IN MARIN COUNTY. IT
IS A TRIBUTARY TO ELENA CREEK
IN MARIN COUNTY. THE CARPENTER
CREEK IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY.
THE SAN JUAN CREEK IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE SIX FISH PASSAGE
INJURY WORKSHOPS CONVENE WITH
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FISH PASSAGE
BIOLOGIST ENGINEERING PARTNERS
IN JULY AND AUUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. IF FOCUSING ON
FUNDING IN IMPLEMENTATION
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IS TIED
TO SPECIFIC TRANSPORTATION
ASSETS IN CENTER I'M GLAD YOU
TALKED ABOUT IT BECAUSE WE NEED
TO TREAT THESE BEARS AS AN
ASSET. THE COST OF BERRY
MEDIATION CAN BE HIGH IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF EIGHT TO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE FULL
SPAN REMEDIATION. AS COMPARED
TO THE COST IMPROVING TRAINING
COAL TRAINS COVERTS WHICH YOU
COULD BE IN THE BALLPARK OF A
MILLION TO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. THE DELIVERY THESE
PROJECT TAKES FIVE TO SEVEN
YEARS TO DEVELOP PERMIT IN
CONSTRUCTION. STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THESE FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES.
BERMAN IN SPANISH SOLUTIONS
WERE STANDARD DESIGNS TO
IMPROVE THE REMEDIATION
SOLUTIONS AND REDUCE
ENGINEERING CALL US ONE
STANDARD DESIGNED TO ESTABLISH
PROGRAMMATIC PERMITTING
SOLUTIONS CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED.
WE'RE FEASIBLE USES STANDARD
BRIDGE SOLUTIONS OR FULL SPAN
PRIORITY LOCATIONS TO REDUCE
PROJECT TIME AND COST TO REDUCE
LONG TERM MAINTENANCE AND A
FULLY REMEDIATE FISH PASSAGE. I
BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE A NEXUS
THERE WERE WERE- WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY CAN ALSO. OCCUR.
WE'RE EXPLORING FISH PASSAGE
SOLUTIONS FOR MITIGATION CREDIT
TO FURTHER LINE FISH PASSAGE
MEDIATION NEEDS WITH CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
CALTRANS IS DISCUSSING THIS
APPROACH WITH HIS AGENCY
PARTNERS THE NATIONAL MARINE
FISHERIES SERVICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
INCORPORATING FISH PASSAGE VERY
LOCATIONS INTO ASSET MANAGEMENT
BY PAIRING TEN YOUR BOOK OF
PLAN PROJECTS IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY OPERATION PROTECTION
PROGRAM WITH PRIORITY FISH
PASSES LOCATIONS AND FACILITY
NEEDS. FUNNY TARGETS WERE
ADJUSTED- TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SIXTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FULL SPAN SOLUTIONS FOR
PRIORITY FISH PASSAGE LOCATIONS
TEN OF THE SIXTY EIGHT IN THE
UPCOMING YEARS. I'VE DIRECTED
MAINTENANCE PERSONNEL TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE UPDATED COVERT
ASSESSMENTS ON ALL SIXTY EIGHT
PRIORITY LOCATIONS BY THE END
OF THE YEAR. THIS ALLOWS TO
FIND OPPORTUNITIES TO SPEAKERS-AT SYNCHRONIZE FIX OUR FIRST
PROJECTS WITH FISH PASSAGE
PRIORITIES. WELL PERFORMANCE
TARGETS IMPROVING FISH PATCHES
IS ONE OF THE MANY REQUIREMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT'S TASK WITH
MEETING WITH A FINANCIALLY
CONSTRAIN PLAN. CALTRANS IS
INCORPORATING FIVE PRIORITY
FISH PASSAGE LOCATIONS INTO THE
ASSET MANAGER PLAN IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY SYSTEM MANAGER PLANNED
WITH CLEAR PERFORMANCE TARGETS.
THIS WILL HELP FISH BUDGET
PRIORITIES BE CONSIDERED
ALONGSIDE WITH OTHER
TRANSPORTATION PARTIES AND
OTHER COST PRESSURES. SINCE
ANGEL CENTER MEDIATION TARGETS
FOR PERFORMANCE BY YEAR THROUGH
A TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR
PRIORITY FISH PASSAGE LOCATIONS.
WILL EFFICIENTLY ALIGNED
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
WITH FISH PASSAGE IMPROVEMENT
PRIORITIES. CALTRANS EXPORT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MITIGATION
CREDITS CALTRANS HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN A LINE EFFORTS
RELATED FISH PASTORS PRIORITY
LOCATIONS AND STORMWATER PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS. IN CALTRANS IS
EXPORTED FEDERAL AND OTHER
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES. IN
SUMMARY A VERY EXCITED HERE TO
BE HERE TODAY WITH THIS FISH
PASSAGE PROGRAM AT CALTRANS HAS
MATURED SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
PAST TEN PLUS YEARS THROUGH THE
SAYS ONE OF BEARS
IDENTIFICATION OF EFFICIENT
ENGINEERING SOLUTIONS THE
FORMATION OF PARTNERSHIPS TO
IMPROVE SCIENCE AND DATA. AND
IDENTIFICATION OF PRIORITIES
CALTRANS IS DEDICATED TO EXCEL
IN BERRY REMOVAL TO MORE
QUICKLY IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HABITAT IN THE COMING YEARS
FULLY INTEGRATING FISH
PASSENGER TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING ASSET MANAGEMENT AND
DELIVERY IS KEY FOR INCREASING
FUTURE PROGRESS. AFTER I AM
DONE SPEAKING ANY BAILEY OUR
CHIEF OF OUR MENTAL WILL TELL
YOU MORE ABOUT HOW WE PLAN
PROJECTS AND PRIORITIZE THEM
WHICH WE FALL BY MIKE KEEPER-
WHO WILL TELL. YOU ABOUT OUR
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO EXCEL RIGHT
BUDGET DELIVERY. WITHOUT OPEN
UP TO QUESTIONS FOR NOTHING SO
MUCH AS YOU TO PROJECT YOUR SO
TALK WITH ME ABOUT THE THREE
YEAR CONTRACT WITH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS SCOPE A
CONTRACT IN WHAT IS GOING TO BE
COMPLEX AT THE END OF THOSE
THREE YEARS. THE CONSUMMATE IS
TO ACCELERATE THE AMOUNT OF-
FIRST PASSAGE ASSESSMENTS THAT
WE'RE DOING. ON THOSE ON THOSE
PROJECTS. AND MISS BAILEY MAYBE
CAN GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION TO FOR YOUR
QUESTION SIR. PLEASE MISS
BAILEY. SURE YOU HAVE PART OF
THE PROGRAM WHAT WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT IS IT GIVES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FISH PASSAGE
ASSESSMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ACT AS MENTORS AND TRAINING THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
MEMBERS. TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
FIRST PASS ASSESSMENTS. THERE'S
ALSO SOME INCLUSION OF HABITAT
QUALITY ASSESSMENTS AS PART OF
THE CONTRACT MISS REALLY SO-
EXPLAINED TO ME MIGRANTS AND
APOLOGIZE WHEN YOU SAY FIRST
PASS ASSESSMENT. WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN FOR YOU IT CALTRANS AND
THEN HOW DOES THIS MOVE THE
PROCESS EXPEDITE THE PROCESS.
THE FIRST PASS ASSESSMENTS ARE
PRELIMINARY RECONNAISSANCE
ASSESSMENTS OF A BARRIER LEAGUE
TYPE IF THERE'S THEIR WHAT'S
THERE IS IT A BARRIER IS WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ANSWER. AND IN
SOME CONDITIONS AT SOME
SITUATIONS IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT
ITS BARRIER WE DON'T NEED A NEW
TO DO FURTHER ASSESSMENTS OTHER
OTHER SITUATIONS. MORE
INFORMATION IS REQUIRED TO
DETERMINE IF IT IS A BARRIER OR
NOT. SO WITH THE THREE YEAR
CONTRACT. WHAT HAVE YOU
REQUIRED THAT THE CONSERVATION
CORPS COMPLETE. WE HAVE CREATED
A PLANS FOR WHICH LOCATIONS
WE'D LIKE TO ASSESS FIRST
BECAUSE IT'S A NEW PROGRAM
WE'RE JUST GETTING UP AND
RUNNING WITH THE TRAINING
ASPECTS THAT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
QUICKLY. THEY CAN ASSESS THEM
SO WE DON'T HAVE A CURRENT BURN
RATE OF YOU KNOW LIKE MONTHLY
COMPLETIONS- BUT WE CAN GET
BACK TO YOU AN UPDATE OF THAT
AS WE MOVE TROUGH THE CONTRACT
IMPLEMENTATION BUT WITHIN THE
CONTRACT IS IT SAY THAT AND I'M
MAKING THIS UP RIGHT DOES IT
SAY THAT YOU'RE GONNA NEED TO
DO. FORTY IN THREE YEARS. NOW
IT ALLOWS FOR I BELIEVE AND-
WHEN I CHECKED THIS BUT I
BELIEVE UP TO TWELVE A PERSON
NOW. TO BE OFFENDED THROUGHOUT
THE DIFFERENT- CORE LOCATIONS.
I TO THEN LEAD TEAMS TO DO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OCCUR. IN THE
PRE DESIGNED BRIDGES. WHAT IS
THE GUIDE IN JUST A FEW OTHER
QUESTIONS WILL GO TO MISS
BAILEY I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE ALL OF THE PRE
DESIGNED BRIDGES WHAT PERCENT
OF PROJECTS US ME CAN BE. I
AND- CORRECTED WITH THE PRE
DESIGN VERSUS NOT. I THINK IT'S
OUR OUR OUR SHIFT FROM- PARTIAL
DESIGNED TO FULL SPAN DESIGN IN
OUR COMMITMENT IS WHERE
FEASIBLE TO GO TO THE FULL SPAN
DESIGN BECAUSE I THINK WE SEE.
A NEXUS FOR ALL KINDS OF
IMPROVEMENT TO WILDLIFE
CONNECTED THE WEATHER'S FISH OR
OR FOR LEGGETT- CREATURES OKAY
SO- I GUESS I WAS TAKING YOUR
PRE DESIGN IS THAT YOUR YOU'RE
DOING A DESIGN THAT COULD BE TO
EAT. THAT COULD BE DEPLOYED. IN
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE
NOW. YES SIR WE'RE LOOKING AT-
SPAM LINKS OF TWENTY TO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN FEET HER. TO BUILD-
COME IN AND KIND OF PLUG AND
PLAY YEAH VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
MISTER LANCASTER WAS TALKING
ABOUT USING STANDARD DESIGNS.
OF COURSE OUR STANDARD DESIGNS
HAVE TO DEAL WITH SEISMIC-
VULNERABILITY AND SEISMIC
DESIGN AND HANDLE BIG LOADS IN
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT- DIFFERENT BUT THE
SAME IDEA OF MUCH MORE. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO RE ENGINEER YOU
SOLUTION CAN USE STANDARD
DESIGNED TO PULL OFF THE SHELF
AND PLUG AND PLAY A MOVE FOR
FAT AND MOVE FASTER PRE FAB
RIGHT YEAH SO. THIS IS USE A
SIXTY EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE THE E.
MENTION SO ADDO SIXTY EIGHT.
50% DO YOU BELIEVE COULD BE.
DEPLOYED USING THIS THE PRE
ALLOWS USE THE PRE FAB. HAVE
YOU DONE THAT ASSESSMENT WHAT
I'M TRYING TO GET TO IS- YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO COVER. EXPERTS
ST OF- BLOCKAGES WITH THE PRE
FAB- PRODUCT THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE. MOVING FORWARD WITH YOU
HAVE YOU DONE THAT ASSESSMENT
NO WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT IS
OKAY. SO ON THE PRE FAB HOW
MUCH TIME DO YOU THINK THAT'S
GOING TO CUT OFF OF THE PROJECT.
I'D LIKE TO REFER THAT TO MR
KEEVER TO ADDRESS THAT THANK
YOU IT'LL BE IN MY PRESENTATION
CENTER MCGUIRE BUT SORRY
QUESTION NOW BUT WE HOPE TO-
REDUCE THE TIME FRAME IN FOR
FULL DELIVERY BY TWO YEARS OR
MORE. OKAY. DE RANDAMIE DEF
STILL THE THUNDER AND I
APOLOGIZE I I'M GONNA KEEP
GOING THERE THOUGH AS LONG AS
WE HAVE IN THIS DORMS KEEPER
THAT'S OKAY SO THEN. TALK TO ME
ABOUT THAT NEXT STEP SO YOU.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR SAID. YOU
MOVE ON THE PRE FAB. AND YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TWELVE DESIGNS.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO GO ANYWHERE
FROM TWENTY FOUR TO ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN FOOT WITH ABOUT A
DOZEN STANDARD DESIGNS THAT
WILL BE READY TO GO OR COULD BE
MODIFIED FOR THE SITE OCCUR SO
BE BOTH THE ENGINEERING AND THE
DETAILS. WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP
OF FIGURING OUT FOR THESE.
AGAIN I'M JUST BEING OVERLY
GENERIC RIGHT THE PRE FAB THE
TWELVE DESIGNS. OUT OF THE MOST
CRITICAL PROJECTS. IS GONNA HIT
50% OF THEM. IT IS TO TALK ME
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND THEN.
DOING THE PRO THE ROUTE THE
PROGRAMMATIC E. I. R. A. NOR
THE PERMITTING WHATEVER IT MAY
HAVE TO BE- HOW LONG IS THAT
PROCESS TAKER OF YOUR KICK THAT
OFF- SUBMIT TO LEAN ON ON- IN
ME FOR PART OF THIS BUT- WE-
RELY ON WORKING WITH THE FISH
PACKS TO TRY TO FIND WHAT IS
THE BEST SOLUTION FOR EACH
SITE. AND SO WE DO THINK AS
OPPOSED TO MAYBE WHAT WE'VE
DONE PREVIOUSLY IT'S GOT OPEN
UP MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
FULL SPAN AND FEWER OF THE
PARTIAL SOLUTIONS THAT'S GOOD
FOR US- BOTH FROM A LONG TERM
READ LES MAINTENANCE- ANY
BETTER ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME.
WE ALSO HOPE AS WE DEFINE THE
PROCESS AND HAVE SOME CERTAINTY
WITH THE STANDARDIZED DESIGNS
WAY BE ABLE TO WORK WITH NAMES
AND- CALIFORNIA FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND GET PROGRAMMATIC
PERMITS SIMILAR TO WHAT- MISTER
LANCASTER TALKED ABOUT THAT
THEY'RE DOING- THAT WOULD ALLOW
US TO REDUCE THE TIME IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS AS WELL.
TOO MANY ITEMS I'D BE
INTERESTED IN IS THAT. THAT TWO
YEARS THAT SQUISH YEARS THAT
FIRM DO YOU BELIEVE- AS FAR AS
BEING ABLE TO CUT THE TIME LINE
OFF OF A APPROVAL PROJECT
WHAT'S YOUR GUT. IT'S GOT YEAH
HELLO SO- BUT THERE'S MULTIPLE
PLACES WE THINK WE CAN CUT SO
IT'S THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS BECAUSE WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER UP FRONT SO WE GET
THESE PERMITS- AGREEMENTS UP
FRONT. WE KNOW WHAT WHAT
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME WE'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE. THE DESIGN
PROCESS IS REDUCED OVER TIME IN
DEVELOPING THE PLANS- IS LESS
AND THEN THE TIME IN
CONSTRUCTION AND I'LL BE ABLE
TO SHOW A SLIDE FURTHER ON BUT
ONE OF THE SUCCESSES- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD THE BRIDGE
IN IN. FROM THE TIME THE
FOUNDATIONS WERE DONE IN OUR
PILOT PROJECT AND IT TOOK SOME
TIME TO DO THE FOUNDATIONS BUT
ONCE WE GOT THE MAN. WE BUILT
THE BRIDGE IN TWENTY THREE DAYS.
THESE CLEARLY CAN GET IN AND
GET OUT BETWEEN THE SALMON RUNS
AND POTENTIALLY YOU COULD HAVE
A CONTRACTOR THAT COULD DO
MULTIPLE SITES. BETWEEN DURING
THE DRY SEASON AND REALLY TRY
TO EXPEDITE THESE AND PACKAGE.
PROJECTS THAT- WE GET SEVERAL
PROJECTS DONE OLD HELPING US
WITH SCHEDULE AND REDUCING OUR
COSTS. SO I'M GONNA LOOK AT-
I'M JUST GOING TO USE AN
EXAMPLE HERE SO I'M LOOKING AT-
CEDAR CREEK. I THINK THAT WAS
THE BE DIRECTORS FOR SLIDE A
NINETEEN. SO. WOULD YOU THINK
THIS WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE OF.
THE CANDIDATE FOR PRE FAB. THE
SUCH A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHALLENGE WE WILL WITH A
PARTIAL SOLUTION HERE'S A GOOD
PARTIAL- SOLUTION- EVERY.
SURGEON JENNER YOU THINK YOU
CAN DO ANYTHING BUT- THIS ONE
COULD BE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
CHALLENGE AND I THINK THE FISH
PACKED DID DECIDE THAT THE
PARTIAL SOLUTION AT THIS POINT
WAS THE BEST SOLUTION WE AND IS
WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN THE SHOW
ME EXAMPLE DISCUSS IS IT THE
NEXT FLIGHT TO SHOW ME AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU THINK WE'LL
CERTAINLY HERE. OKAY SO THIS
WOULD BE A PRE THAT GUY
ABSOLUTELY SO HERE WE ARE WE
HAVE A CLEAR BARRIER- SPANNING
OVER THAT IS WHERE YOU'RE NOT
TLKING ABOUT SOMETHING WHERE
THE CULVERT OR SOMETHING IS
FIFTY SIXTY FEET THAT'S WHERE
WE HAVE OUR CHALLENGES WHERE
IT'S NOT VERY ECONOMIC OKAY
CULVERTS BURIED DEEP BELOW THE
ROADWAY ELEVATION. BUT A
LOCATION LIKE THIS VERY
CONDUCIVE OKAY. AND I
APPRECIATE IT HAS ALWAYS TO
THESE FOR ME SEEN THE VISUAL
WHAT. WHAT IS BECOME FOR SO ONE
OF THE QUESTION THE ONE A FALSE
I HAVE IN A SCENE THAT YOU NEED
TO BE ABLE TO. LOOK AT THIS IS
I'D LIKE TO GET A BETTER HAS
SEEN ESPECIALLY IN THOSE ARE
CALLED THE SIXTY EIGHT. LOW
HANGING FRUIT PROJECTS WHAT
PERCENT. EVEN COULD BE.
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THE PRE FAB
BECAUSE I THINK THAT WOULD BE
REALLY IMPORTANT- IT IS A SITE
THAT YOU GO OUT AGAIN MAKING
THIS UP AT THIS POINT RIGHT- IS
THE FACT THAT YOU GO OUT AND
SAY TO. YOU PUT SOMETHING OUT
TO BED OF. WE DO. AGAIN MAKING
IT UP. TEN CREEKS. I UNDER ONE
CONTRACTOR WITH THESE HAVE TO
BE INDIVIDUAL CONTRACTS- SO IF
YOU'RE LOKING AT. TEN
DIFFERENT CROSS SCENES. IN
HUMBLE COUNTY THAT YOU KNOW.
PRE FAB COULD WORK WITH
HYPOTHETICAL. YOU DO THAT ON
ONE CONTRACT COULD YOU TO BE TO
EXPEDITE THIS OR DOES IT HAVE
TO BE INDIVIDUAL. MY LAST
QUESTION AND I PROMISE I'LL
TURN HEARTLESS BAILEY'S ON THE
PROGRAM ATTIC SIDE. TALK ME
THROUGH. TIMELINE TO BE A
FIGURE OUT HOW THAT WORKS
BEFORE WE START ENGAGING THE
RESOURCE AGENCIES. SO
CONTRACTING THESE PROJECTS TO
DO MORE THAN ONE AT A TIME.
SURE CENTER I THINK WHEN YOU
LOOK AT FROM A CONTRACTING
PERSPECTIVE IN AND AS LONG AS
WE HAVE A FIX IT FIRST NEXUS I
THINK. PULLING PROJECTS
TOGETHER MAKES SENSE TO DO THAT
I THINK THERE'S AN ECONOMY OF
SCALE OF DOING A DEPENDING ON
LOCATION USUALLY HAVE TO HAVE
LOCATIONS ARE FAIRLY CLOSE
TOGETHER FOR THE CONTRACTOR
WHEN THEY MOBILIZING GO OUT AND
DO THESE TYPES OF THINGS AND
SO. THAT ALL FACTORS IN TWO
LOCATIONS IN SOME OF THE SIXTY
EIGHT SPAN ALL IN UP ALL OF LL
THE WAY UP AND DOWN THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO AS NOT
ALWAYS CONDUCIVE TO DOING THAT
BUT BUT CERTAINLY- AND LOOKING
AT OTHER. METHODOLOGIES ARE CMG
SEE YOUR CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
GENERAL CONTRACTOR. IS IT AN
ALTERNATE PROCUREMENT THAT WE
CAN USE GETTING THE CONTRACT ON
BOARD TO FIGURE OUT- HOW DO WE
MORE EFFICIENTLY CONSTRUCT-
THESE THINGS. ARE THE DISEASE'S
THESE BRIDGES- BEING IN
CONSULTATION WITH OUR RESOURCE
PARTNERS OUT THERE I THINK THAT
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY THERE
AS WELL. AND IT. REALLY AT TO
TRY TO ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING THE PROGRAMMATIC-
WE'VE ALEADY KICKED OF
DIALOGUES WITH THE NATIONAL
FISHERIES SERVICE AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AVERAGING ONE. ON
PROGRAMMATIC- AND IT HELPED
INFORM THE EFFORTS THAT WERE TO
UNDER GOING WITH- ENGINEERING
SERVICES ON- THE STANDARD
DESIGN SOLUTIONS AND THEN- AN
ASSOCIATE IT AND PYLE STRIKE
ANALYSIS SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. GIVEN THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SUBSTRATES AND WHAT
KIND OF FOUNDATIONS- WOULD BE
NEEDED AND THE ASSOCIATED AND
STRIKES FOR PILES. THAT ALL OF
THAT HELPS US DESCRIBE THE
ACTION IN THE CONSULTATIONS
WITH THE RESOURCE AGENCIES SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE A THAT
STANDARD APPROACH AND THEN THEY
ARE ABLE TO. PERMIT OUR OR
ENTER INTO THE CONSULTATION
AGREEMENT WITH US- AND
PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL. SAID AT THE
TIME LINE ON THAT IS AND KNOWN
UNTIL WE CAN PRESENT THE
INFORMATION WITH THE STANDARD
DESIGNS BEING COMPLETED AND.
THAT PILE STRIKE ANALYSIS I
MENTIONED. ARE YOU LOOKING ATTY.
HEAR WHAT IT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
AGAIN HOLD NEW TO THIS RIGHT
BUT JUST YOUR GUIDE IS. A SIX
MONTH PROCESS A TWO YEAR
PROCESS AND WHEN YOU'RE PROCESS
WHAT YOUR GUIDE. AND HATE TO
COMMIT THE AGENCIES TO I'M NOT
LOOKING FOR AN ITEM THAT I WAS
TRYING TO BE HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN COMPLETE IT WITHIN THE NEXT
TWO YEARS OKAY. YEAH I'M IN MY
LAST QUESTION BEFORE TURN OVER
YOU AYE AYE LATER THEIR AND I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE AND THAT WAS
WILL LAST. TO WARMER TEMPS.
MISTER DEPUTY SAID ALL SIXTY
EIGHT LOCATIONS BY IN THE YEAR
CAN YOU JUST TELL YOU WHAT YOU
HOPE TO WRAP UP IN IS AT TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OR TWENTY
TWENTY. IT IS IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SO WE HAVE SIXTY EIGHT
HIGH PRIORITY FISH PASTORS
BEARS HOME AND SO WHAT I'VE
ASKED MY MAIN IS TEAM TO GO
BACK BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
A NEXUS WOULD FIX IT FIRST ON
TEN OF. THE SIXTY EIGHT MMHM
BUT SOME OF THOSE. FIX THE
FIRST INVESTIGATIONS HAVE NOT
OCCURRED. OR IT'S BEEN A LONG
TIME SINCE THE LAST OCCURRED SO
THERE MAY BE DEGRADATION IN THE
PIPE ITSELF THAT COULD LEAD TO
AN ACCESS FOR US GOING ON FIX
IT. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS GO OUT AND GET THAT
NEXUS- TO SEE I WILL TELL YOU
THAT FOURTEEN OUT OF THE SIXTY
EIGHT ARE ACTUALLY BRIDGES. AND
SO WE HAVE TO SOME MORE-
INVESTIGATION ON WHAT THE BEARS
ARE THAT IN SO WE ALREADY HAVE-
BRIDGES NOW WHETHER THERE'S
APPEAR IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
STRING BAD OR- WHAT WHAT'S
CAUSING THAT WE HAVE TO DO. A
LITTLE MORE RESEARCH ON THAT.
WE JUST GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK
AND SEE IF WE CAN FIND.
ADDITIONAL CULVERTS- OR BRIDGES
THAT WE NEED THAT THAT ARE IN
DISTRESS- OR AS SOME
DEGRADATION THAT WE GO JEAN
USED TO FIX THE FIRST MONEY TO
GO OUT THERE AND FIX AND HAVE-
HAVE WHEN. IT'S GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A PROJECTOR AND TURN
IT OVER NOW- TO IMMEDIATELY-
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANKYOU
MISS BAILEY WHOSE. OF FOCUSING
ON ALL ISSUES OF BIOLOGICAL
PLANING. ADVANCED MEDICATION
INNOVATION. WITH CALTRANS IF I
MEANS MAN FOR YOURS. THANK YOU
SENATOR. MY NAME IS AMY BAILEY
AND I'M NOT OFFICE HE FOR THE
OFFICE OF STRATEGIC BIOLOGICAL
PLANNING ADVANCE MITIGATION
INNOVATION. GERMAN PROVIDED AN
OVERVIEW OF THE FISH PASSAGE
PROGRAMMING PROJECTS I WILL
TELL YOU ABOUT OUR FISH PASSAGE
ADVISORY COMMITTEES. HOW WE
PRIORITIZE FISH PASSAGE
BARRIERS. ARE ADVANCEMENTS IN
SCIENCE AND DATA AND OUR
SUCCESSES FROM PARTNERSHIPS. I
THE SIX FISH PASSAGE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES ARE A JOINT EFFORT
BETWEEN CAL TRANS CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
NAZARIAN FISHERIES SERVICE AND
OTHER INTERESTED ADVOCATES SUCH
AS US FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE. CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORES COASTAL
CONSERVANCY TROUT UNLIMITED
PACIFIC STATES MARINE FISHERIES
COMMISSION AND OTHERS. FOR FISH
PASSAGE EFFORTS. THE FIRST WAS
ESTABLISHED IN DISTRICT ONE
ALONG THE NORTH COAST IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE AND THE MOST
RECENT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THE PURPOSE IS TO SHARE
SCIENCE AND DATA AND KNOWN FISH
PASSAGE BARRIERS DEVELOP
METHODS TO PRIORITIZE LOCATIONS
FOR ASSESSMENTS AND BIOLOGICAL
PRIORITIES FOR REMEDIATION. AT
QUARTERLY MEETINGS WITH EIGHT
TRACKS STATUS OF ACTIVE IN
FUNDED BERRIER REMEDIATION
EFFORTS FROM PLANNING FOR POST
CONSTRUCTION. AND ENSURE THE
BARRIERS ARE ASSESSED AND
DOCUMENTED PRIOR TO PROJECT
DESIGN. THIS COLLABORATION OF
X. EXPERTS ADVOCATES AND
PARTNERS INCLUDE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MEMBERS ALL WITH THE
COLLECTIVE GOAL OF ADDRESSING
TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS WITH
LONG TERM SOLUTIONS THAT
FACILITATE FISH PASSAGE. THIS
PASSAGE ADVISORY COMMITTEES
DEVELOP METHODS TO IDENTIFY
BIOLOGICAL PRIORITIES FOR
REMEDIATING FISH CARRIERS. THIS
BIOLOGICAL PRESERVATION FOR
RECOVERY IS BASED ON BIOLOGICAL
SIGNIFICANCE IN COORDINATION
WITH CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AND NATURAL
FISHRIES SERVICE. RESERVATION
INCLUDES CONSIDERATION OF
SPECIES INFORMATION INCLUDING
PRESENTS OUR HISTORIC PRESENCE
OF SALMON AND STEEL HEAD
SPECIES. DIVERSITY OF SALMON
AND STEEL HEAD AND LISTING
STATUS. IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
SUITABLE HABITAT C<c.cyan> AT UPS.</c>
BOTH QUALITY AND QUANTITY
INCLUDING VALUES SUCH AS COOL
WATER AND VELOCITY REFUGIA
MATURE NATIVE RIGHT PERRY IN
VEGETATION AND FEATURES SUCH AS
RIFLES POOL AND CLEAN WASH
GRAVEL. YET INCLUDES OTHER
KNOWLEDGE OF EXPERTS AND LOCAL
PROFESSIONALS. THEY USE THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND DATA
AND IT'S REFINED OVER TIME. AS
PARTY LOCATIONS ARE FUNDED
THEIR MOVED TO THE ACTIVE
PROJECT LIST AND NEW PRIORITY
BARRIERS ARE ADDED TO THE LIST.
I WANT TO TOUCH ON SOME
INNOVATIONS FOR IMPROVE SCIENCE
AND DATA THIS YEAR A PILOT FISH
PASSAGE BARRIER AND HABITAT
EVALUATION FORM WAS CREATED. IT
ASSIST WITH IDENTIFYING
SPECIFIC BERRIER ELEMENTS IN
AIDS IN DETERMINING THE
SUITABILITY QUALITY AND
QUANTITY OF HABITAT YOUR FISH
BARRIERS. IT HELPS WITH
IDENTIFICATION AND FOCUS ON
BARRIER LOCATIONS WITH THE
GREATEST LIKELY BENEFITS FOR
SPECIES RECOVERY. END OF PHIL'S
BIOLOGICAL DATA GAPS THAT ARE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE FIRST AND
SAYS SECOND PASS ASSESSMENTS IN
THE FISH PACK PASSAGE
ASSESSMENT DATABASE. THE FORM
INCLUDES WATERSHED MAPPING AND
MODELLING WHICH ALLOWS US TO
ESTIMATE LIKELY ACCESSIBLE
HABITAT. AND THERE'S ALSO
INFORMATION AVAILABLE FOR MULTI
SPECIES BENEFITS THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED. I THE DIGITAL DATA
COLLECTED AND COORDINATED THAT
DIRECTLY INFORMS PRESERVATION
EFFORTS. FISH PACKS CONTINUE
ANNUAL IN PERSON TRAINING
EVENTS AND WEBINARS ON FISH
PASSAGE REMEDIATION INCLUDING
BRIDGES AND BIOLOGY SCIENCE AND
DATA FISH PASSAGE ENGINEERING
SOLUTIONS AND PERMITTING. THE
HUMBOLDT STATE UNIVERSITY
ENGINEERING DEPARTMENT IS
CONDUCTING A TWO YEAR RESEARCH
EFFORT THAT CALTRANS FUNDED
INVESTIGATE THE FUNCTION OF
IMPLEMENTED FISH PASSAGE
SOLUTIONS. THE RESEARCH PANEL
CONSIST OF CALTRANS CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND NAZARIAN FISHERIES SERVICE
ENGINEERING EXPERTS WHO ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE INTERN
AGENCY FISH PASSAGE ENGINEERING
GROUP. FISH PACKS IN THE
INTERAGENCY FISH PASSAGE
ENGINEERING GROUP PROVIDING
CONSISTENT VENUE FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE SHARING
OF SCIENCE DATA AND ENGINEERING
EXPERTISE. AND COORDINATION
WITH CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE NAZARIAN
FISHERIES SERVICE AND OTHERS. A
SUPPORT MULTI DISCIPLINARY
COORDINATION FOR SCOPING
DEVELOPING PERMITTING
IMPLEMENTING AND MONITORING
SPECIFIC BERRY REMEDIATION
PROJECTS AND EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND NAZARIAN FISHERIES
SERVICE ENGINEERS THAT JIM
MENTIONED THAT WE FIND THEY
REVIEW PROJECT DESIGNS AND
COURTNEY AND APPROVE
ENGINEERING SOLUTIONS. AND WE
ALSO LOOK TO PARTNERING EFFORTS
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES
THROUGH VARIOUS STATE AND
FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
ENHANCEMENT GRANTS. I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE
PARTNERSHIPS AT PACIFIC STATES
MARINE FISHERIES COMMISSION HAS
PROVIDED CONSTANT SUPPORT FOR
DATA MAPPING AND NEW TOOLS FOR
EFFICIENCIES AND ASSESSMENTS.
THEY MANAGE THE PASSAGE
ASSESSMENT DATABASE AND THIS
PROVIDES FOR SEAMLESS DATA
COMMUNICATION WITH CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
WE'VE SPOKEN A BIT ABOUT THE
CAN'T CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS. AND AS THE THEN. THE
HOPES THAT WE HAVE FOR AND ED
COMPLETING AN ADDITIONAL FIRST
PASS ASSESSMENT ASSESSMENT AND
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONALS.
VEHICLE CREEK AN ACTIVE PROJECT
IN DISTRICT TWELVE ORANGE
COUNTY IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
PARTNERING THAT HAS TRANSLATED
INTO SUPPORT AND CAPITAL
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR OTHER FUNDING
FROM PROGRAM AND PARTNERS.
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM CALCUTTA
WHILE I PROP ONE GRANT NATIONAL
FISH AND WILDLIFE FOUNDATION
GRANT AND THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD AT
GRANTS TOTAL APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY CALTRAIN IT IS
MANAGING THIS PROJECT. IN
DISTRICT TWO SISKIYOU COUNTY A
GRANT FROM YOU SEE DARK THE US
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR HAS
PROVIDED ADD TO THIS WITH
PLANNING SKIPPING AND
PRELIMINARY INVESTIGATIONS FOR
BOTH KATE AND PORTUGUESE.
CREEKS. DIMENSIONS ANALYST AT
STRATEGIES TO INCREASE THE PACE
OF REMEDIATION FISH PASSAGE
REMEDIATION HAS BEEN FUNDED AS
MEDICATION FOR NEARBY OFFSITE
BARRIERS THAT WERE OTHERWISE IN
GOOD CONDITION. CURRENTLY DEL
NOR ONE OH ONE SMITH RIVER
BRIDGE REPLACEMENT IS
DEVELOPING DOMINI CREEK AS
MITIGATION. OTHER COMPLETED
PASSAGE REMEDIATION EFFORTS
FUNDED AS OFFSITE MITIGATION
INCLUDE SOUTH FORK RYAN CREEK
NORTH FORK RAIN CREEK AND áP
CREEK. THIS STRATEGY WOULD
ALLOW FOR INCREASED FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO REMEDIATE
PRIORITY BARRIERS THAT HAVE NO
TRANSPORTATION CONDITION
DEFICIENCY. ALSO THERE IS
INTEREST IN PURSUING
DEVELOPMENT OF ADVANCED
MITIGATION PROJECTS REMEDIATE
BARRIERS WE WILL SEE POTENTIAL
WITH THIS APPROACH AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING TO
EXPLORING A CRACK AT CREDITING
FRAMEWORK WITH OUR AGENCY
PARTNERS TO FURTHER UNDERSTAND
AND IMPLEMENT. WE LOOK TO
CONTINUE THE SUCCESS IN A LYING
FISH PASSAGE PRIORITY LOCATIONS
AND STORMWATER PERMIT CREDITING
REQUIREMENTS. THERE ARE SEVERAL
BENEFITS TO SPENDING SOLUTIONS
FOR FISH PASSAGE REMEDIATION
DESIGN SUCH AS ADDRESSING BAD
IN BANK CORROSION. AND SAID A
MAN AND A PRE TRANSPORT WHICH
REDUCE DIRECT AND INDIRECT
WATER QUALITY IMPACTS SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH CLAIM TO
HIRING FIFTY FIVE COMPLIANT
COMPLIANCE UNITS IN OUR STORM
WATER MANAGEMENT ANNUAL REPORT
RELATED TO FISH PASSAGE
PRIORITY REMEDIATION EFFORT.
LASTLY WE PLAN TO CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH NASH RE FISHERIES
SERVICE IN CALIFORNIA PERMIT A
FISH AND WILDLIFE REGION ONE
AND DEVELOPING THE PROGRAMMATIC
ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT
CONSULTATION AND CONSISTENCY
DETERMINATION. OF TO REDUCE
TIME RELATED PERMITTING FISH
PASSAGE REMEDIATION. IN ORDER
TO TREAT THAT PROGRAMMATIC
AGREEMENT AS MENTIONED WE NEED
TO RELY ON A STANDARD DESIGNS
THAT MIGHT KEEP OUR PROJECT
MANAGEMENT DIVISION SHE FOR
NOTE NOW GO INTO MORE DETAIL ON
AND HOW WE DELIVER. THIS
PASSAGE PROJECTS THANK YOU. YOU
SO MUCH MISS BELLY UP MISS
PHILLY YOU JUST MENTIONED THE
ANNUAL REPORT SO DO. YOU HAVE A
DATE WHEN HE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT. ZERO ALL ADDRESS SAID.
IT'S GOING TO FINAL REVIEWS AND
YOU SHOULD SEE THAT THE NEXT
COUPLE WEEKS NEXT COUPLE WEEKS
BEFORE. THERE IS A BEFORE
CHRISTMAS. FOR CHRISTMAS ALL
RIGHT. TO BE LIKE A GIFT. I DID
LIKE IT AND THEN OBVIOUSLY IS
GOING TO HAVE THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION THAT IS WELL SAID
TO BELIEVE THAT'S RIGHT IT WILL
SIR OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH IT
WILL HAVE THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE THAT I TALKED
ABOUT. OKAY THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU IS REALLY NAGGING
TURNOVER MISSED KEEPER. SHEET
YOU BEING HERE TODAY SIR- IN OF
COURSE IS CHIEF PROJECT MANAGER
DIVISION. IN THE CHIEF HE'S
CHIEF IN THE PROJECT MANAGEMENT
DIVISION FOR CALTRANS FOR
INTERNAL RISKY FORGET FIVE
MISTER. ANDERSON REQUIRE- YOU
CLEARLY KNOW THIS TOPIC YOU
ANTICIPATED MUCH OF MY CONTACT
APOLOGIZE RIGHT TO- JUST MY
PRESENTATION OF WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT- THERE'S A
LOT OF COLLABORATION- THAT-
TOOK PLACE JIM MENTIONED. THE
STANDARD DELIVERY TIME OF OUR
BRIDGE PROJECTS IS FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS AND AMY TALKED
ABOUT THE PROGRAMMATIC
AGREEMENTS. WE'VE WORKED TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND-
BOTH REDUCE OUR PROJECT
DELIVERY TIME AND COST BUT ALSO
IMPROVING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES AND TRYING TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE FISH PASSAGE
REMEDIATION INDOOR GENERAL
PRACTICE AND JIM EMPHASIZE THAT
AS WELL AND SO. THAT'S WHERE A
LOT OF THE COLLABORATION HAS
HAS GONE ON. WE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER- ACROSS DISCIPLINES-
IN MY PREVIOUS ROLE OVER ON THE
BRIDGE OFFICE WE EXCHANGED AN
ENGINEER THAT WENT OVER TO THE
DIVISION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ANALYSIS TO WORK IN THEIR
OFFICE. THEY IN TURN- WE HAD A
BIOLOGIST COME OVER AND WORK
WITH THE ENGINEERS AND THE
GEOTECHNICAL PROFESSIONALS IN
ORDER TO TRY TO SHARE
INFORMATION AND FIND THE BEST
SOLUTION GOING FORWARD. IN
ADDITION WE WORKED- THERE'S
BEEN REFERENCES BRIDGES- AND
BIOLOGY- MELINDA MALL ARE ONE
OF- AMY STAFF WORKED REALLY
HARD TRYING TO STITCH TOGETHER-
BOTH. THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS ON THE OUTSIDE AS WELL
AS THE INTERNAL CALTRANS GROUPS
TO WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO FIND
WHERE ARE THE SOLUTIONS AND
WHAT ARE THOSE- OPPORTUNITIES.
AND FROM THAT CAME A THE A
STANDARDIZED BANNING SOLUTIONS
OR BRIDGE IN A BOX SO VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT MISTER
LANCASTER WAS TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER. AND WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS. ALREADY BUT AGAIN JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE DESIGN IS
DONE. THE DETAILS ARE DONE
NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED FOR THE
SITE. BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
FAR INTO THE PROCESS FOR BOTH
OF THESE. WHEN ITS PRE
FABRICATED YOU CAN BRING IT OUT
TO THE SIDE AND YOU CAN THINK
OF IT LIKE AND I KEY A BRIDGE
YOU CAN ASSEMBLE IT VERY VERY
QUICKLY WHICH IS IMPORTANT-
BOTH FROM A TURN IN TERMS OF-
PUBLIC DISRUPTION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HIGHWAY PROJECTS HERE AS
WELL AS TRYING TO LIMIT THE
IMPACTS TO THE SITE AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND AGAIN
THIS IS WHERE WE SEE THE
PROGRAMMATIC OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK TOGETHER SAY WE'RE GOING
TO GET IN AND GET OUT AND LIMIT
OUR- IMPACTS AND WITH THE FULL
SPAN SOLUTIONS- THE NEED FOR
MAINTENANCE IS GREATLY REDUCED
WE DON'T NEED TO GET BACK AND
WE DON'T NEED A PERMIT NOR TO
DO OUR OUR MAIN DISSOCIATED
ACTIVITY SINCE WE SEE A LOT OF
BENEFITS WITH THE- WITH THE
FULL SPAN SOLUTION. WHAT AREA-
CORRECT YEAH I'VE NEVER
PURCHASED ANYTHING FOR AT FROM
IKEA THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ASSEMBLE. SO WORSLEY OR SOME
REALLY GOOD CONTRACTORS WE WORK.
FACTS ARE CASH IS STILL IN THE
GARAGE. PRETTY WELL. SO THE
CALTRANS VERSION WHICH
HOPEFULLY DRAW THIS
COLLABORATION WILL LEVEL WORK
VERY WELL SO. SO WE TALKED
EARLIER ITS ITS ITS MULTI
FACETED IN THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
REDUCE BOTH COST AND TIME FROM
THE- WITH WE THINK THROUGH THE
COLLABORATION THE PROGRAMMATIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AGREEMENTS THE
DESIGN PROCESS TO CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS. AND REDUCING THE NEED
FOR MAINTENANCE ALL REDUCING
TIME ALL REDUCING- COST AND WE
THINK WITH A BETTER IMPROVE
VARMINT ALLOW COME NOT ONLY FOR
THE- SALMON AND STEEL HEAD BUT
THESE TYPES OF SOLUTIONS ARE
OFTEN GOOD FOR OTHER SPECIES
THAT ARE ABLE TO USE THE- THAT
IS A- CROSSING AREA. WE PREFER-
WHEN WE CAN THE FULL SPENCER
LUCIEN BUT WE HAVE- GUIDANCE
MATERIAL MANUALS ARE FOR
DIFFERENT HYDRAULIC SOLUTIONS
THAT WE USE MANY F OUR PAST
SOLUTIONS HAVE BEEN THE- THE
PARTIAL HYDRAULIC SOLUTIONS- WE
ALSO USE STREAM SIMULATION
DESIGN STRATEGIES- WHEN IT'S
NOT FEASIBLE UT- WE ARE-
DRIVING TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
FULL SPAN WHERE IT APPEARS
THAT. THE. HAVING THAT TOOL
AVAILABLE TO US WHERE IT'S
FEASIBLE AND IT'S THE BEST
ALTERNATIVE AS WE SAID WE GO
THROUGH THIS COLLABORATIVE
STRATEGIZING- PROCESS CITY CAN
YOU GO BACK TO THAT REAL QUICK
SO. IS THAT. YOUR EIGHT TO TEN
MILLION VERSUS. THIS IN MARIN
GIMME. IRAN IS THE EIGHT TO TEN
MILLION DOLLAR TYPE PROJECT AND
IF YOU'RE DOING THE LATTER LIKE
THAT ANY WHAT'S THAT- THERE'S A
LOT MORE AS IT'S READ THE. THE
THREE MEN WONDER WONDER THREE
MILLION TYPE. OF THAT OKAY
THAT'S- CHEAPER THAN THIS IS
CHEAPER. BUT IT ALSO COMES OF
THE MAINTENANCE COSTS AND A
LIFESPAN THAT ISN'T THE SAME AS
THE BRIDGE ALTERNATIVE SO WE
MAY HAVE TO FIND OURSELVES
GOING BACK IN CLEARING OUT-
DEBRIS IN THINGS IN THERE AND
THAT DEBRIS ITSELF CAN DAMAGE.
THE ASSET. AND THEN IT'S NOT AS
EFFECTIVE AND THEN WE NEED TO
GO BACK IN AND GET ANOTHER
PERMIT AND DO ANOTHER PROJECT
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS AGAIN.
THE WORKING POOR WE'RE MOVE
TILTING TOWARD THE FULL SPAN I
THINK WHEN WE CAN DO THOSE AND.
AN EXAMPLE OF THE FORCE OF FULL
SPAN IS THE FORD COUGH CREEK
BRIDGE THIS IS DONE A FEW YEARS
AGO BUT IT REALLY SET THE TONE
FOR WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THE
FULL SPAN. IT'S UP AND SISKIYOU
COUNTY ON ROUTE- NINETY SIX- WE
USED ALL PREFABRICATED
COMPONENTS YOU CAN SEE THE SORT
OF ON THE LEFT THAT PART OF THE
SLIDE THE ORIGINALS. SITE YOU
CAN SEE IN THE MIDDLE SLIDE THE
PREFABRICATED- COMPONENTS BEING
ASSEMBLED- AND THEN THE FINAL
SOLUTION WAS A FULL SPEND
SOLUTION UNATTRACTIVE BRIDGE-
AND- AGAIN FROM THE TIME WE
WERE COMPLETED THE FOUNDATIONS
TO WHEN THEY BEGAN THE WORK YOU
SEE IN THE CENTER WE WERE DOWN
IN TWENTY THREE DAYS. NOW WE
THINK ACTUALLY YOU KNOW THIS IS
A PILOT PROJECT WE WERE
LEARNING AS WE WEREGOING ON.
BECAUSE OF ITS SUCCESS SO
THAT'S WERE RE DECIDED TO
INVEST IN THESE THESE ARE FULL
SPAN SOLUTIONS AND STANDARDIZE
THOSE WE THINK WE CAN DO BETTER
THIS IS THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
AND SO GOING FORWARD WE THINK
THERE IS THERE EVEN GREATER.
OPPORTUNITIES. SO JUST IN
CONCLUSION WE THINK BETWEEN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. PROBLEMATIC
APPROVALS THAT WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH OUR OUR- PERMITTING A
RESOURCE AGENCY PARTNERS ON
WITH THIS UP AS A RESULT OF
STANDARDIZING- THESE TYPES OF
DESIGNS AND REDUCING- THE
TIMELINE IN DELIVERING THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE BENEFICIAL
AND- AND THEN THE COSTS
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS. THE
TIME IN DESIGN TIME IN
CONSTRUCTION AND THE- THE
MAINTENANCE AND WE BELIEVE.
THEY PREFERRED ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOME- NO NEED FOR ROCK
REVETMENT AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
TOTAL FOR THE SIXTY EIGHT AGAIN
IS. UPWARDS OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. BALLPARK. DOES THE
TOTAL OF THE TWENTY SEVEN THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT THEY WERE
ACTING TWENTY SEVEN BUT THEY'RE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION. SIXTY EIGHT WHAT WOULD
THAT RUN YOU HI ESTIMATE WOULD
YOU SAY LET'S JUST SAY TEN
MILLION A PIECE O. SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION. AND TO TALLY.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THE NINE
NEXUS PROJECTS IN THE TOPS
SIXTY OR SEVENTY. THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT- MITIGATION OR
ADVANCED MEDICATION THAT- MISS
BAILEY TALKED ABOUT AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH A RESOURCE
PARTNERS TO SEE IF WE CAN FIND
THAT NEXUS- BECAUSE IF I CAN
FIND A TRANSPORTATION ACTORS
FOR MITIGATION FOR ANOTHER
PROJECT AND THAT GIVES ME THE-
THE A GREEN LIGHT TO GO AHEAD
AND USE THAT AND FIX AND REMOVE
THAT FISH PASSAGE BEAR ON THAT
PARTICULAR PROJECT. IN USING
THAT MITIGATION TO MITIGATE FOR
ANOTHER PROJECT. AND THAT'S
WERE ACTIVELY WORKING WITH WITH
OUR PARTNERS RIGHT NOW. SO WHEN
YOU DO THE ANALYSIS OF THE
SIXTY EIGHT BY THE END OF THE
YEAR YOU CAN  YOU THAT'S GOING
TO GIVE YOU YOUR INVENTORY OF
YOUR. CHAT YOUR REDIRECT NEXUS
FOR TRANSPORTATION. VERSES
THOSE THE ART THAT'S CORRECT
SIR OKAY. OKAY I WILL TELL YOU
THE OTHER THEY'RE STILL ANOTHER
FIVE HUNDRED BARRIERS THAT IF
WE'VE GOT A NEXUS ARE NOT THE
HIGH PRIORITY BUT THEY'RE STILL
BEARS THAT IF WE ARE WORKING ON
A CULVERT OF THAT HAS A VERY WE
NEED TO GO AHEAD AND FIX THAT
AS WELL. AND SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THOSE AS WELL. STANDARD
THOUGHT OF COMPLETING ALL SIXTY
EIGHT IN HOW MANY DECADES. IF
WE GO ALONG AS WE ARE NOW.
CURRENTLY WERE AVERAGING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE A YEAR- SO A
LOT OF YEARS. ALL RIGHT. SO AT
WE GOTTA FIGURE AB AND I KNOW
MISTER DAVIS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE AN
EXPEDITE RIGHT. WELL I THINK
ALSO PT IN OUR ASSET MANAGER
PLANET AND JUST LIKE WE DO WITH
OTHER BRIDGES AND CULVERTS AND
PAVEMENT TO ADD THAT INTO THE
INVENTORY AND THEN WHEN YOU
START LOOKING AT THAT YOU DO
DATA ANALYTICS ON IT YOU PUT AN
R. G. I. US AND SEE WHERE
THERE'S OVERLAP I MEAN I JUST.
I THINK IT WILL. PUT IT AT THE
MAIN LINE IN STREAMLINING. INTO
OUR SYSTEM- THINK WILL HELP
TREMENDOUSLY IN THIS AREA AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT.
CAME SO I'M HAVE SOME FOLLOW
UPS HERE THAT. I'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GO THROUGH. SO ONE OF
THE ITEMS THE COMMITTEE'S GOING
TO BE LOOKING FOR IS. NO IT'S
STILL SQUISHY BUT RETURN WHAT
IS IT THAT WE'RE GONNA REDUCING
THE TIME FRAME USING THE PRE
FAB PROJECTS. NUMBER TWO. WHAT
IS THE PERCENTAGE OF THE SIXTY
EIGHT WE CAN DEPLOY PREFAB
PURSES NOT. NUMBER THREE WOULD
LIKE THE IN NINE NINE OKAY HOLD
MISS BAILEY TO THIS UNDERSTAND
IT WAS A ROUGH MAYBE TWO YEARS
FOR THE PROGRAMMATIC BUT- WHAT
IS A REAL TIME LINE. FOR THAT.
WE ALREADY MENTIONED THE- FIX
IT FIRST VERSES AND NINE NEXUS
IN TEAM WITH THAT INVENTORY IS
WHICH I THINK IS GONNA BE
PRETTY QUICK. THE ANNUAL REPORT
IS GOING TO BE. BY CHRISTMAS.
IT IS CURRENTLY RUNNING THROUGH
THE PROCESS NOW. ANYWHERE THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO AND I KNOW THIS IS WHERE
CALTRAIN WHAT'S GOING ON I'M
LOOKING. AT THE MAP. THE
PROVIDER THIS IS TOP SIXTY
EIGHT ARE TOP SEVENTY PROJECT.
IN THE STATE IN REALLY IT'S.
YOU ARE CLUSTERED YOUR CLOTHES
QUESTION ON THE NORTH STATE
YOUR CLUSTERED IN THE NORTH
COAST. BAY AREA IN AROUND THE
LOS ANGELES REGION RIGHT. SO
TOTAL NUMBER DISTRICTS YOU
THINK THESE PROJECTS ARE IN
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY. THE SIXTY
EIGHT YEAR THEY'RE DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THEM BUT AS
THE DISTRICT ELEVEN TWELVE TWO
AND ONE AND ONE AND THREE HAVE
THE LEAST AMOUNT. RIGHT OKAY.
SO WHAT I A YOU KNOW AGAIN I
THINK WERE WHAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR PANEL IS- DUE TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE I'M
HERE WITH IN THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM. ENDANGERED SPECIES ARE
ON THE BRINK. I AND. THERE'S SO
MUCH THAT WE CAN DO IS THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO HELP THE
RECOVERY AT THESE FISH SPECIES
BOUGHT I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE'RE GONNA
HAVE IS DEVELOPING THAT NIGHT
THOSE STRATEGY FROM THE NINE
NEXUS PROJECTS IN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT REGARDLESS IF IT'S IF IT
TOUCHES- IF IT AS A FIX IT
FIRST INDOOR HIS NINE NEXUS.
THEY'RE ALL PRIORITIES. INSIDE
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO.
DEVELOP THE FUNDING BILL IS FOR
IN IN PARTICULAR MOVE FORWARD
ON THOSE NINE NEXUS PROJECTS.
BECAUSE ON THOSE- FIX IT FIRST
PROJECTS MISTER DEPUTY DIRECTOR.
YOU CAN USE THOSE
TRANSPORTATION UP FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO FIX THAT'S CORRECT SIR.
IN YOU SEE IN THERE IS YOU
BELIEVE THAT. IF THERE ARE NOT
STRUCTURAL CHALLENGES OR
WHATEVER MAY BE WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THAT ONE SPOT
YOU CANNOT USE TRANSPORTATION
DOLLARS I THINK OUR OUR OUR
STRUGGLES SIR IS THAT- WE HAVE
HUGE NEEDS A NON OF DOLLARS
CURRENTLY IN A STATE OUR SYSTEM
MANAGER PLAN. WE HAVE- NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS IT NEEDS AN
FIFTY FOUR ARE FROM NINETY
BILLION DOLLARS A NATIVE FIFTY
FOUR BILLION OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS AND SO IT'S BASICALLY WE
HAVE A HALF OF WHAT WE NEED
CURRENTLY. TO DO TO FIX OUR
FIRST WORK BETTER STRUGGLE. AND
OBVIOUSLY SO LIABILITY SO WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS IT
LIKE. MANY OTHER LIABILITIES
THAT WE HAVE IN THE SYSTEM.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA OFFER
ICHI YOU CLOSING COMMENTS WILL
START WITH THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND- HOLE IN WITH JUST A
THOUGHT OF WHEN WE CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU TO PROJECT YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS PLEASE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SENATOR- WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
A FIX IT FIRST AND OUR FISH
PASSAGE NEXUS I THINK I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT- OUR
COMMITMENT AND THAT'S WHY I'VE
ASKED ARMENIANS FOLKS TO GO
BACK TO THE SIXTY EIGHT HIGH
PRIORITY PROJECTS BY BY
CHRISTMAS TIME. AND IDENTIFY
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY OF THE FIX
IT FIRST NEXUS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF THE SIXTIETH WORKING
ON CURRENTLY WORKING ON. TEN OF
THOSE GOING FORWARD. ALSO WE'RE
GOING TO INCLUDE- ESPECIALLY
THERE'S A PART OF OUR ASSET
MANAGER PLAN AND- MANAGE THAT
JUST LIKE WE DO OUR BRIDGES AND
CULVERTS AND- PAVEMENT. WE'RE
PARTNERING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFEIN
THE NATIONAL MARINE FISHERIES-
TO LOOK AT OF MEDICATION CREDIT
OPPORTUNITIES ON THOSE NINE
NEXUS OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE.
WELL WE'RE ALSO ASKING THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
OTHERS IS- OTHER FUNDING OUT
THERE MAYBE NOT OUTSIDE FEDERAL
HIGHWAYS OTHERS FEDERAL FUNDING
POSSIBILITIES OUT THERE SO
THERE ARE CURRENTLY EXPLORING
HAT FOR ME IT AS WE SPEAK
FURTHER TO GET ALL OVER IT
ESPECIALLY CLIMATE CHANGE. BUT
YOU KNOW I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS LOOK AT THE SAYS ONCE
AGAIN CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS AND SEEING HOW THEY CAN
HELP US XCELERATED LOOKING AT
THESE ASSESSMENTS. AND FINALLY
I WANT TO SIT DOWN. WITH MISTER
LANCASTER FOR THE FIVE SEASON
ONLY LOOK AND SEE IF THERE'S
SOME OPPORTUNITIES THERE THAT
WE COULD- LEVERAGE AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE- WE'RE AWAYS LOOKING FOR
INNOVATION THAT'S WHEN THE
COMMITMENTS OF SB ONE IS FOR.
CALTRANS DELIVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN FISHING
SEIZE EVERY YEAR AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
TO BE DIRECTOR WE'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THE- IN AGAIN I
WAS A THANK YOU THAT THE TEAM
FOR CALTRANS WE'VE HAD- SERVER
PRE MEETINGS LEADING INTO
TODAY'S HEARING AND- WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP- IN JANUARY FOR
ANOTHER IN PERSON MEETING. ON
THE ITEMS OUTLINING TURN OVER.
TO MISS BAILEY FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS. I JUST WANT TO SAY
I'M REALLY PROUD OF ALL THE
WORK THAT- OUR PARTNERS AND
CALTRANS AND SPECIFICALLY MY
STAFF OF DONE ON. WITH THE FISH
PASSAGE ADVISORY COMMITTEES ALL
THE INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE AT
CA FISH PACKED UP WORK. AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE PARTNERSHIPS
BOTH INTERNALLY AND EXTERNALLY
TO HELP US MOVE FORWARD ON
PROGRESS WITH THIS PASSAGE
THANK YOU VERY. MUCH THANKS
RING IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU WERE
IN TURNOVERS KEEPER FOR CLOSING
COMMENTS PLEASE. I THANK
CHAIRMAN AMY OF SUMMER AS WELL
AS FOR THE COMMENTS THANK.
THANK YOU SO OUTLINED AT THOSE-
FOLLOW UP TO THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE TRACKING OBVIOUSLY THE BIG
ONE IS GOING TO BE COMING UP IN
REGARDS THAT IN YOUR REPORT
WHICH WILL BE SOONER. RATHER
THAN LATER- IN WE HAVE THESE
EIGHT ADDITIONAL FOLLOW SAID
AGES VERBALLY MENTION THAT-
MISTER WEST LOW OUR CHIEF
FISHERIES CONSOLE WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH A LIST- SO
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE WHERE- ARE YOU FOLLOW
UPS ARE AND WOULD LIKE TO BE A
TO GET BACK TOGETHER IN
JANUARY. AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
CALTRANS TEAM FOR COMING
TOGETHER HANK YOU SO MUCH.
THEY SING GERMAN WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE OPENING UP FOR-
CLOSE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. WE
WELCOME ANY INDIVIDUAL TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TWO MINUTES- TO BE ABLE TO COME
FORWARD TO GIVE THIS GIVE US
YOUR OF FIRST NAME. AND IF
YOU'RE WITH ORGANIZATION GIVES
ORGANIZATION IS WELL- WE
WELCOME ANYONE TO BE A TO COME
FORWARD IF YOU CAN'T AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
INDUSTRY STINK SO MUCH MAN. IT
WAS GOOD TO SEE YOU TOO THANK
YOU SIR. FOR HELPING US GET
THIS ORGANIZED TODAY. WHAT TURN
OVER TO YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
NICE TO SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. AND THANK YOU PAGE
FAIR BE FISHERIES PROGRAM
MANAGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL AND
RESOURCES AGENCY TANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. I
JUST WANTED TO BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHT SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
BEEN MENTIONED EXPLICITLY YET
TODAY MORE CLOSELY RELATES TO
THIS MORNING'S CONVERSATION AND
DISCUSSION. LAST WEEK AT- PC'S
PUBLIC MEETINGS- COUNCIL
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED
A STRATEGY TO PROTECT WHALES
AND SEA TURTLES. AND ENSURE
THRIVING FISHERIES IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH REDUCING THE
RISK OF ENTANGLEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FISHING GEAR. AT A
HIGH LEVEL THIS INVESTMENT
STRATEGY WITH WHICH ALIGNS
WITH- PC'S REMAINING FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
ADDRESS WILL AND SEE TRAIL
ENTANGLEMENT. INCLUDES
ADVANCING THE FOLLOWING FOUR
PILLARS. COLLABORATIVE
PARTNERSHIPS BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE YOUR INNOVATION AND
ENTITLEMENT RESPONSE AN
OUTREACH. THIS STRATEGY AIMS TO
SUPPORT THE DUNGENESS CRAB
FISHERY IN ADDITION TO OTHER
STATE MANAGE FISHERIES INVOLVED
IN ENTANGLEMENTS. IN PARTICULAR
THIS MORNING WE HEARD ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPROVING BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE INFORMING
RISK ASSESSMENT. RELATED TO
MARINE LIFE ENTANGLEMENT OPC IS
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING AND
SUPPORTING THIS URGENT NEED AND
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTNERS. TO PROTECT WHALES AND
SEA TURTLES AND ENSURE THRIVING
FISHERIES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH US AS WELL WE SHOULD WORDS.
COMING S. OUT LIVE FOR MARIN
COUNTY WELCOME. IT'S GOOD TO
SEE SIR- SENATOR HI MY NAME IS
RICHARD JAMES OF THE CUSTODIAN
AND JUST WANNA MAKE SOME BRIEF
COMMENTS PLEASE PLEASE HAVE
SOME PREPARE STUFF BUT THEN I
ALWAYS BRING UP THINGS
UNGRATEFUL COME TO MIND. I WANT
TO COMMENT ON A COMMENT THAT.
SMOKING MASTER MADE EARLIER AND
HE SAID THAT. OREGON WASHINGTON
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY HAD A
WHALE PROBLEM AND TILL THEY
DID. AN I'D LIKE TO RE FRAME
THAT STATEMENT AND SAY I THINK
THAT IT'S PROBABLY MORE
ACCURATE TO SAY THAT THE WHALES
HAVE KNOWN ALL ALONG THAT THEY
HAVE A HUMAN PROBLEM. YOU KNOW
WE PUT THOSE ROPES IN THE OCEAN
AND- THEY'VE JUST BEEN DOING
THEIR THING FOR A LONG TIME SO.
IF WE- YOU KNOW LOOK AT LOOK AT
ISSUES FROM DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES WE MIGHT COME TO
DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS. I WOULD
LIKE SIMPLY FOR THE WORKING
GROUP EFFORTS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
YOU KNOW WORKING HARD TO TRY
AND DEVELOP HERE. AND GET GIVES
ITS LOST OUT OF THE- THE WATER
AND I APPLAUD THOSE EFFORTS- AS
I SHOWED YOU SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
IN YOUR OFFICE I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT I HOPE THAT-
MOVING FORWARD THOSE EFFORTS
CAN. BE USED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF GEAR THAT GETS LOOSE
AND SHOWS UP ON THE BEACH. AND
YOU'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE SO THIS
THIS BLL WE RIGHT HERE THIS IS
ONE OF THOUSANDS THAT I PICKED
UP FROM- THE BEACHES OF MORAN.
AND AS YOU KNOW I TOOK ONE OF
THESE MOVIES AND I ADDRESSED IT
WITH A WITH A WOOD RASP. AND I
TURNED THAT BILLY. INTO A JAR
OF POWDER. AND THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS TO THESE BOOTIES ON THE
ROPE AND THE CRAP. THE BAIT
JARS. WHEN THEY GET PUSHED UP
INTO THE ROCKS ALONG THE COAST
AND NO ONE PICKS THEM UP. THERE
JUST TUMBLED LIKE A ROCK
TUMBLER. AND IT JUST THIS IS.
THE CRAB FISHERMEN NEED A
HEALTHY OCEAN AS WE HEARD
EARLIER. BUT CRAPPIE FISHING IS
HARD ON THE OCEAN ESPECIALLY
WHEN I WANT TO GEAR GETS LOOSE.
AND LAST WEEK I SPOKE TO A
WOMAN FROM FROM DFW. AND I
LEARNED IN CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND POTS. PERMITTED TO PUT
IN THE WATER. THOSE AREN'T ALL
FINISHED. BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE
RANGING PAY FOR THE FISH AND
THEN THEY DON'T. ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND 400-002-0040 THREE
THOUSAND. POTS ARE FINISHED.
I'VE HEARD THAT ROUGHLY 10% OF
THE GEAR GOES MISSING. SO
THAT'S ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
POTS THE THAT JUST GO MISSING
IN. TURN INTO DEBRIS IN THE-
ALONG ALONG THE SHORES IN IN
THE OCEAN IN VERY QUICKLY WRAP
UP. FISHERMEN WANT TO GET BACK
TO DAYS OF LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE OPENER AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT YOU KNOW THE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA BACK
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY WAS ABOUT
TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE. IT'S
ABOUT FORTY MILLION PEOPLE NOW.
THEN WE CAN'T. KEEP EXPECTING
THEOCEAN TO DELIVER. WHAT IT
HAS DELIVERED. WHEN WE JUST
KEEP MULTIPLYING LIKE RABBITS.
AND SO WE YOU KNOW BEACH WE CAN
EXPECT. THE PLANET TO JUST KEEP
ON DOING WHAT IT'S BEEN DOING
WHEN WE KEEP MAKING BIGGER
BIGGER DEMANDS I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US. TO FOR A
LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE DOING
BECAUSE- I THINK IT'S
UNREALISTIC TO EXPECT THE OCEAN
IS JUST KEEP PROVIDING. WELL
EVEN AT THAT. GEN ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND I
ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU- AS I'VE DONE IN
THE PAST- IF YOU HAVE NOT SEEN
SOME OF THE PICTURES- THAT WHAT
MACHINES IS PICKED UP. ALONG
THE OCEAN IT'S IMPRESSIVE IN
DEPRESSING I AIMED AT VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR WORK- IN YOUR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT I HAD TO
BE A TO KEEP THE SHORES CLEAN
SO WE'RE VERY EVERY TIME I
CAN'T. CAN I SNEAK MISTAKEN ONE
MORE COMMENT QUICKLY PLEASE. AS
CALTRANS WAS HERE IN MY EFFORTS
TO CLEAN THE OCEAN OR TO CLEAN
THE BEACHES OUT MARIN I'VE
FOUND THAT THE EAST BAY
HOMELESS CAMPS. ARE A MAJOR
SOURCE. OF DEBRIS INCLUDING
MEDICAL WASTE IN THE FORM OF
DIRTY SYRINGES AND I'VE BEEN
I'VE MET A LOT OF MY CALTRANS
ROLLED EXES GOT VERY BIG. I'VE
LEARNED IS THAT MANY MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ARE SPENT. CLEANING
UP REPEATEDLY CLEANING UP ALL
ALONG THE HIGHWAYS AROUND THE
STATE. AS THE HOMELESS PEOPLE
MOVE ACROSS THE ROAD WALL THEIR
BELONGINGS ARE THROWN AWAY OR
OR CLEANED UP AND THEN THEY
JUST MOVE RIGHT BACK INTO A
CLEAN UP PLACE THEY DO IT
AGAIN. IF WE CAN FIND HOMES FOR
THOSE PEOPLE OR MEDICAL HELP
FOR THOSE PEOPLE OR IN SOME
CASES JAILS FOR THOSE PEOPLE-
WE COULD SAVE MANY MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THAT COULD BE PUT
TOWARDS FISH PASSAGE IN I KNOW
IT'S PROBABLY A DROP IN THE
BUCKET BUT EVERY DROP HELP SO I
JUST WANT TO THROW THAT OUT
THERE TO. KNOW I APPRECIATE
THEM IS JAMES IN A KNOW THAT- I
DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ME BUT I MISTER
DAVIS BEEN ON. THE FRONT LINES
OF. LITIGATION ON WITH.
DISTRICT FOR- THE BAY AREA
CALTRANS DISTRICT ON ALL ISSUES
OF. LITTER AND TRASH AND THAT-
CALTRANS IS WORKING ON A VERY
AGGRESSIVE PLAN ON THAT ISSUE
RIGHT NOW- IN- YOU'RE GONNA SEE
MORE TO COME. IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS. I THINK WHERE
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO GO ON ALL
ISSUES OF FISH PASSAGES. TAKEN
VERY PROACTIVE APPROACH ON
THIS. NOT SENATE- CALTRANS IS
NOT BY. WHAT YOU JUST POINTED
OUT. ON IN ESPECIALLY WITH THE
CRISIS THAT WE'VE HAD- WITH
ALMOST RESIDENTS AND- LIVING
ALONG OUR HIGHWAY SYSTEM IT'S A
LAST RESORT. AND IT'S ALSO
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CHALLENGES
THAT CALTRANS. I IS DEALING
WITH SO MORE TO COME ONTHAT I
PROMISE YOU. MISTER DAVIS HAS
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF THIS
ONE- AND WORKING THIS- VERY.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE IT'S A
VERY MUCH OUT YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH CITY COUNCIL
OAKLAND. AND BERKELEY AND
TONIGHT I'M GOING TO GO TO A
LAKE MERRITT INSTITUTE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MEETING. THEIR TASK
OF CLEANING UP WEEK MERIT SO
I'M- NOT TRYING. AT ALL ANGLES
BUT I'M GET THOSE SPREAD A
LITTLE SEND SO. YOU'RE YOU'RE
REALLY GOOD SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE LIKE VIDEO LAST CALL
FOR FOLKS WHO LIKE TO BECOME. A
PROVIDE COMMENT TESTIMONY TO
THE COMMITTEE LAST CALL. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. AND JUST TO ADD
SOME QUICK FOLLOW UPS. FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR PRESENTERS.
FOR WITH THIS TODAY- FOR OUR
FIRST PANEL AND OPEN UP CRAB
SEASON. AGAIN NOVEMBER
SIXTEENTH SOUTH OF THE
MENDOCINO CINEMA COUNTY LINE-
EXCUSE ME. NOVEMBER TWENTY
SECOND- AND THEY KNOW IT
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH AS WE MOVE
FORWARD UP. IN MENDOCINO HUMBLE
AND DOWN OR COUNTIES. WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FISH
WILDLIFE IN THE DIRECTOR'S
OFFICE- I'M MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO- GET
THIS LAUNCHED IN PROTECT WHALES
THE SAME TIME. WE WILL BE
HAVING IN PERSON FATHER
MEETINGS WITH CALTRANS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. ON THIS ISSUE OF
FISH PASSAGE AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO DO A FOLLOW UP
HEARING. IN TWENTY TWENTY. MOST
LIKELY IN THE SUMMER OR THE
FALL EVERY ONE YEAR STATUS
REPORT ON WHERE WE'RE AT ON THE
TOP SIXTY EIGHT. AGAIN JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
PRESENTERS HERE TODAY FROM ALL
THE PANELS. AND WISH ALL OF YOU
A WONDERFUL THANKSGIVING AND MY
LAST THANK YOU. IS TO THE
GENTLEMAN TO MY RIGHT. THIS IS
TOM WAS SLOW HE IS THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE. WORKS HIS TAIL OFF
ON ALL ISSUES. OF FISHERIES OUR
CULTURE HERE IN THE STATE
REALLY ONE OF THE BRIGHTEST
MINDS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
SUBJECT. REALLY GRATEFUL TO
WORK WITH HIM- EACH AND EVERY
DAY. SO LAYS IN GENERAL ONE FOR
HOLIDAY YOU. KEVIN
CONGRATULATIONS MY. MAN ON YOUR
RETIREMENT IN YOU CANNOT BE A
STRANGER. IS GONNA BE ATTACK IN
SOME OF THESE FISH AS WELL. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WITH THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED